EVERYONE TO ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY
TODAY'S TUESDAY.
APRIL NINTH.
WE DO NOT YET HAVE A QUORUM BUT
WE WILL START AS SUBCOMMITTEE WE
DO HAVE AND SPECIAL ORDER OF
BUSINESS TODAY AT NINE AM MISTER
WOULD THIS IS AB. EIGHT TWENTY
FOUR SO OUR ITEM NUMBER.
ONE PLEASE GO FORWARD
[inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF FIRST I'D LIKE TO
THANK YOU AND YOUR COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH US ON
THIS BILL I'D LIKE TO ALSO
ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS PROPOSED
BY THE COMMITTEE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WHEN THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
APPROACH MY OFFICE ABOUT
CARRYING THIS BILL I DIDN'T
HESITATE BECAUSE I'VE BEEN
FIGHTING AGAINST THE HIGH COST
OF PRESCRIPTION DRUGS SINCE I'VE
BEEN ELECTED?
FIRST AND FOREMOST TO PROTECT
PATIENTS BUT ALSO FOR ALL THOSE
WHO FEEL THE SQUEEZE OF EVER
INCREASING HEALTH CARE COSTS.
AB EIGHT TWENTY FOUR IS ONE MORE
EXAMPLE OF FIGHTING AGAINST
HI<c.cyan> AND WARRANTED FOR</c>
PHARMACEUTICAL DRUG COSTS.
THIS BILL WILL STOP THE DRUG
COMPANIES PROP PROFIT PROTECTING
PRACTICE OF PAY FOR DELAY.
WE'RE DRUG COMPANIES MAKE
ARRANGEMENTS WHICH IN ERIC'S
DELAY THE PRODUCTION OF LESS
EXPENSIVE GENERIC DRUGS.
AB EIGHT TWENTY FOUR WILL DO
THIS BY PROVIDING A PRESUMPTION
THAT THESE TYPES OF AGREEMENTS
BETWEEN BRAND AND GENERIC DRUG
COMPANIES.
ARE ANTI COMPETITIVE.
THIS PRACTICE IS COSTING
CONSUMERS AND PAYER SUCH AS
MEDICARE HOW MEDICARE AND
EMPLOYERS BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
EVERY YEAR.
THE PHARMACEUTICAL ENGINEERING
COMPANIES WILL TESTIFIED TODAY
THAT THEY LIKE THE STATUS QUO.
BUT LET ME TELL YOU THEY PREFER
THE STATUS QUO BECAUSE IT TILTS
THE BALANCE IN THEIR FAVOR.
WHAT IS THAT FAVOR BRAND NAME
MANUFACTURERS PRO LONG THEIR
MONOPOLY WAY BEYOND THEIR
PATENTS MAKING HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS MORE?
KEEP IN MIND THIS PRACTICE
RESULTS IN GENERIC MANUFACTURERS
MAKING HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS FOR DOING ABSOLUTELY
NOTHING.
AB TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY FOUR WILL
CHANGE THAT.
IT RECOGNIZES THE LEGALLY
PROTECTED RIGHT OF DRUG
MANUFACTURERS TO THEIR PATENTS
ANTI RESTRICTED MONOPOLIES.
I WILL CONTINUE TO FIGHT FOR
AFFORDABILITY AND COST
CONTAINMENT WHEREVER I FIND THEM
I HOPE YOU AGREE THAT THESE
PAPER TO WOMEN'S.
AGREEMENTS PAPER DELAY
AGREEMENTS MUST END I RECOGNIZE
THAT THEIR DRUG MANUFACTURERS
OUT THERE THAT ACTUALLY DO NOT
ENGAGE IN PAY FOR DELAY
AGREEMENTS AND I APPLAUD THAT.
IT'S MY HOPE THAT THIS BILL
ACTUALLY DETERRED DRUG
MANUFACTURER FROM ENTERING INTO
THESE AGREEMENTS BY ESTABLISHING
A STATUS A STANDARD THAT IS PRO
CONSUMER.
JUST TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS --
FOR THE AG IS -- ACTUALLY FOUR
EIGHT IT IS ROBIN FELDMAN -- A
PROFESSOR AT THE AT THE UC
HASTINGS -- AND WE HAVE SOMEONE
FROM HEALTH ACCESS I'M SORRY FOR
THE G. I'VE GOT MY HOW COME IT
WILL SCREW UP ROBIN IS OUR
PROFESSOR WE HAVE A SOME FROM
THE AG'S OFFICE.
HAVE TECHNICAL SUPPORT WE HAVE
SOMEONE FROM HEALTH ACCESS HERE
MY APOLOGIES.
RIGHT THANK YOU I'M GONNA ALLOW
THREE WITNESSES THE FIRST
WITNESS PLEASE THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN STEAMED MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE.
I'M HONORED TO BE HERE TODAY TO
ADDRESS AN ISSUE THAT IS CAUSING
REAL PAIN FOR PATIENTS AND FOR
THOSE WHO ARE TRYING TO HELP
THEM.
THAT ISSUE IS PAY FOR DELAY AND
ITS EFFECTS ON CALIFORNIA'S
CITIZENS.
SO WHEN TO COMPETITORS SHAKE
HANDS AND AGREE TO KEEP THE
CHEAPER DRUGS OFF THE MARKET.
THAT'S BAD FOR CONSUMERS AND
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE IS TRYING TO ADDRESS.
SO WITH PAY FOR DELAY A DRUG
COMPANY PAYS A CHEAPER
COMPETITOR TO STAY OFF THE
MARKET FOR A PERIOD OF TIME.
IT IS AN END RUN AROUND A SYSTEM
THAT'S DESIGNED TO BRING GENERIC
DRUGS TO THE MARKET MORE QUICKLY.
NOW THE TEMPTATION FOR COMPANIES
TO ENTER IN TO PAY FOR DELAY
SETTLEMENTS CAN BE EXTREMELY
POWERFUL BECAUSE THERE IS SO
MUCH MONEY INVOLVED.
SO FOR A BLOCK BUSTER BRAND NAME
DRUGS THE DELAY OF EVEN SIX
MONTHS CAN BE WORTH A HALF A
BILLION DOLLARS.
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS ARE PAYING
FOR THAT.
AND PAY FOR DELAY IS A GROWING
PROBLEM.
LOOKING AT THE MOST RECENT SIX
YEARS OF GOVERNMENT DATA THEY
WERE ALMOST NINE HUNDRED
SETTLEMENTS BETWEEN BRAND AND
GENERIC COMPANIES.
THERE WERE A HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
IN THE MOST RECENT YEAR ALONE.
NOW 90% OF THOSE RECENT
AGREEMENTS IN SOME WAY
RESTRICTED A CHEAPER DRUGS FROM
ENTERING THE MARKET.
IF COMPANIES AGREED TO KEEP
CHEAPER MEDICINES OFF THE
SHELVES WE ARE GOING TO SEE
PRICES COME DOWN IN THE
CALIFORNIA MARKET PLACE.
THE FINANCIAL EFFECT OF THE
PAPER DELAYED REMAINS A
SUBSTANTIAL RECENT GOVERNMENT
REPORTS GIVE A FIGURE FOR A
SMALL SUBSET OF THESE AGREEMENTS
AND THAT SMALL SUBSET ALONE
PROTECTED FIFTEEN BILLION
DOLLARS IN ANNUAL BRAND NAME
DRUG SALES.
GIVEN CALIFORNIA'S SHARE OF
NATIONAL HEALTHCARE SPENDING
CALIFORNIANS ARE ON THE HOOK FOR
A LOT OF THAT MONEY.
AND IT IS WORTH ASKING TODAY WHO
IS PAYING THE BILL FOR THIS TYPE
OF BEHAVIOR.
THE HEAVY BURDEN FALLS IN
CALIFORNIA'S EMPLOYERS.
WHEN EMPLOYERS HAVE TO PAY MORE
FOR HEALTHCARE COSTS THEY HAVE
LESS MONEY IN THEIR HIRING
BUDGET?
SO CALIFORNIA PAYS IN THE FORM
OF LOST JOBS LOWER WAGES AND OF
COURSE AT THE END OF THE DAY
CALIFORNIA'S CITIZENS THEMSELVES
HAVE TO PAY IN THE FORM OF
HIGHER HEALTHCARE PREMIUMS.
AND HIGHER OUT OF POCKET COSTS
TO BUY MEDICINES BECAUSE VERY
SIMPLY THE PAY FOR DELAY DEALS
ARE HELPING TO FUEL THE
SKYROCKETING COSTS OF MEDICINE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
QUITE SIMPLY IN A FREE MARKET
ECONOMY WE WANT COMPETITORS
EXPOSED TO FREE MARKET FORCES WE
WANT THEM GOING HEAD TO HEAD TO
DELIVER THE BEST PRODUCT FOR THE
CHEAPEST PRICE FOR CONSUMERS.
WE DON'T WANT COMPETITORS
ENTERING INTO AGREEMENTS TO KEEP
CHEAPER MEDICINES OFF THE
SHELVES.
AND ONE DRUG COMPANIES AGREE
THAT THE CHEAPER MARKET THE
CHEAPER DRUG TO STAY UP THE
MARKET WHAT'S GREAT THE TWO
COMPANIES IS GREAT FOR BOTH
SIDES.
THE REST OF US PAY AND PAY.
SO I WOULD LIKE TO OFFER ONE
OBSERVATION SPECIFICALLY ABOUT
THE BILL THAT IS BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE TODAY.
IMPORTANTLY THE BILL DOES NOT
FORBID PAY FOR DELAY SETTLEMENTS
BETWEEN BRADENTON AIR COMPANIES.
RATHER THE BILL FOLLOWS
CALIFORNIA ANTI TRUST LAW
LANGUAGE AND IT SAYS THAT IF
COMPANIES ENTER INTO THESE
AGREEMENTS.
THEY NEED TO SHOW THE AGREEMENTS
ARE PRO COMPETITIVE IN OTHER
WORDS COMPANIES NEED TO SHOW
IT'S GOOD FOR CALIFORNIA
CONSUMERS.
IN THIS WAY THE BILL YOU HAVE
BEFORE YOU IS A MEASURED
RESPONSE TO DEEPLY TROUBLING
PROBLEM.
SO SO MANY CITIZENS UPSET AND
OFTEN FRIGHTENED AT THE COSTS OF
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT MEDICINES
THE TIME IS RIGHT FOR THESE
ISSUES AND THE PAY FOR DELAY
BILL IS AN IMPORTANT STEP.
YOU CAN HELP PHARMACEUTICAL
MARKETS BECOME MORE FAIR AND
MORE EFFICIENT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
WITH A POSITIVE SOCIAL QUORUM
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL STONE HERE
GALLAGHER CHAO [inaudible] TO
GONZALEZ [inaudible]
HOLDEN KALRA [inaudible]
KILEY MAIENSCHEIN [inaudible]
OBERNOLTE [inaudible]
PETRIE-NORRIS [inaudible]
WRATH.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A QUORUM.
THAT'S WHAT IS PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS YES MEAN PILOT HERE ON
BEHALF OF HEALTH ACCESS
CALIFORNIA THE STATE WIDE HEALTH
CARE CONSUMER ADVOCACY COALITION.
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB.
EIGHT TWENTY FOUR MEMBERS I
THINK WE CAN ALL AGREE THAT
SOMETHING NEEDS TO BE DONE TO
TACKLE THE SOARING COST OF
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS.
HEALTH ACCESS WAS PROUD TO CO
SPONSOR SB SEVENTEEN IN TWO
THOUSAND AND SEVENTEEN WHICH
CREATED FIRST IN THE NATION
TRANSPARENCY AND PRESCRIPTION
DRUG PRICE INCREASES.
HOWEVER THE TRANSPARENCY LAW
DOESN'T ADDRESS DRUG PRICES THAT
ARE ARTIFICIALLY HIGH BECAUSE OF
A LACK OF A LOWER COST
ALTERNATIVE THAT IS PURPOSELY
DELAYED TO MARKET.
CALIFORNIA CAN BE FIRST ONCE
AGAIN BY PASSING AB EIGHT TWENTY
FOUR TO ADDRESS THE PRACTICE
KNOWN AS PAY FOR DELAY.
AB EIGHT TWENTY FOUR WOULD CRACK
DOWN ON THESE COLUSA AGREEMENTS
BETWEEN BRAND NAME DRUG
MANUFACTURERS AND GENERIC
COMPANIES IN WHICH THE BRAND
NAME COMPANY PAYS THE GENERIC
COMPANY TO DELAY THE LOWER COST
DRUGS FROM COMING TO MARKET.
MEMBERS WHAT IS THE POINT IN
CREATING LIFE SAVING MEDICATIONS
OF PATIENTS CAN'T AFFORD THEM OR
GO BANKRUPT IN ORDER TO ACCESS
THEIR MEDICATIONS.
WE ARE JUST TALKING ABOUT HIGHLY
SPECIALIZED DRUGS WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT INSULIN AND ANTIBIOTICS
DRUGS THAT HAVE BEEN AROUND FOR
DECADES.
LET'S BE CLEAR THIS PRACTICE IS
ALREADY ILLEGAL UNDER ANTI
COMPETITION LAW BUT AB EIGHT
TWENTY FOUR SHIFTS THE BURDEN OF
PROOF IN EXISTING LAW.
AND LEVELS THE PLAYING FIELD SO
THE DRUG MANUFACTURERS NEED TO
PROVE WHY THESE TYPES OF
AGREEMENTS ARE ANTI ARE NOT ANTI
COMPETITIVE.
BOTH BRAND NAME AND GENERIC
COMPANIES HAVE BIG THIS PRACTICE
INTO THEIR BUSINESS MODELS
BECAUSE BOTH COMPANIES BENEFIT.
THIS PRACTICE IS THE DEFINITION
OF CORPORATE GREED AND AT THE
EXPENSE OF MILLIONS OF PATIENTS
EMPLOYERS AND THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
A TWO THOUSAND TEN FEDERAL TRADE
COMMISSION REPORT FOUND THAT PAY
FOR DELAYED AGREEMENTS COST
CONSUMERS THREE POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS PER YEAR.
ACCORDING TO NATIONAL HEALTH
EXPENDITURE DICK EXPENDITURE
DATA THREE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
THREE BILLION DOLLARS WAS SPENT
ON PRESCRIPTION DRUGS IN TWO
THOUSAND AND SEVENTEEN IT IS
CLEAR THAT PAY FOR DELAY
AGREEMENTS.
ARE ONE OF THE DRIVERS OF
INCREASING DRUG COSTS.
HEALTH ACCESS HAS A LONGSTANDING
HISTORY OF WORKING TO ENSURE
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS ARE BOTH
AFFORDABLE AND ACCESSIBLE.
WE BELIEVE EVERYONE SHOULD BE
ABLE TO PAY THEIR MEDICAL BILLS
BUT WHEN THESE PHARMACEUTICAL
COMPANIES CONSPIRE TO KEEP DRUGS
OFF THE MARKET TO INFLATE PRICES.
HARD WORKING CALIFORNIANS
FAMILIES ARE FORCED TO EITHER
PAY OUT OF POCKET OR THROUGH
THEIR PREMIUMS FOR THESE REASONS
WE ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU THAT'S WITH THIS
PLEASE [inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS RUNNING COULD GEORGE
AND I AM A LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE
WITH THE OFFICE OF THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL.
ON BEHALF OF ATTORNEY GENERAL
THE SERRA I WOULD FIRST LIKE TO
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD FOR
OFFERING THIS IMPORTANT PIECE OF
LEGISLATION AND IS LEADERSHIP
AND PROTECTING HARD WORKING
CALIFORNIANS FROM HIGH
PRESCRIPTION DRUG COSTS.
ATTORNEY GENERAL THE SERRA IS
PLEASED TO SPONSOR AB EIGHT
TWENTY FOUR WHICH AIMS TO REDUCE
PURCHASED PRESCRIPTION DRUG
COSTS BY INCREASING ENFORCEMENT
AGAINST COLUSA PAY FOR DELAY
AGREEMENTS.
WE'VE ALREADY HEARD A LOT IN
TERMS OF TESTIMONY FROM
PROFESSOR FELDMAN.
AND FROM OUR HEALTH AXIS PARTNER --
SO I'LL I'LL LEAVE YOU WITH
THESE. TWO POINTS -- THESE
AGREEMENTS ALLOW DRUG COMPANIES
TO EXTEND ITS MONOPOLY OVER
BRAND NAME DRUGS BY KEEPING
LOWER PRICE GENERICS OUT OF THE
MARKET PLACE FOR CONSUMERS FOR
YEARS A PRIME EXAMPLE OF THAT.
IS THE PRO -- WHICH WE SAW IN IN
THIS SUPER CASE THAT WENT ALL
THE WAY UP TO THE CALIFORNIA
SUPREME COURT THEIR CIPRO AN
ANTIBIOTIC THAT WOULD THAT'S
USED TO TREAT BACTERIAL%
INFECTIONS.
PAID ITS COMPETITORS OVER FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS TO STAY
OFF THE MARKET FOR SIX YEARS.
DURING THIS TIME SURPRISE
MANUFACTURER MADE OVER A BILLION
DOLLARS IN SALES.
WHAT WAS THE PRICE IMPACT TO
CONSUMERS WILL AT ITS HEIGHT
CIPRO COST OVER FIVE DOLLARS PER
TABLET?
BEFORE THE GENERIC ENTERED THE
MARKET ONCE THE GENERIC ENTER
THE MARKET THE PRICE DROPPED.
TO LESS THAN TWENTY CENTS PER
TABLET.
THE SECOND POINT I'D LIKE TO
MAKE IS IS JUST TO HIGHLIGHT --
WHAT PROFESSOR FELDMAN SAID
ABOUT WHAT THIS BILL DOES WE'RE
NOT CHANGING THE SUBSTANTIVE LAW
HERE WHAT WE'RE DOING IS
SHIFTING THE PRESUMPTION -- TO
PUT IT WITH THE PARTY THAT CAN
BEST BEAR THE BURDEN THE ONES
THE THE PHARMACEUTICAL COMPANIES
THAT HAVE ALL OF THE EVIDENCE IN
THE DOCUMENTS IN PLACE TO REALLY
SHOW WHY THESE AGREEMENTS AREN'T
ANTI COMPETITIVE IF IF THAT'S
THE CASE.
I'M.
WHEN WE FEEL THAT THAT IS THE
BEST WAY TO PROTECT CONSUMERS?
FROM THESE HIGH PRICED
PRESCRIPTION DRUG COSTS -- AT
THIS TIME I WOULD JUST ASK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND ASK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION.
AND ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE
RESPECTFULLY ASKS FOR YOUR AYE
THOSE WE CAN ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE LIKE.
TO SHARE THEIR SUPPORT OF THE
BILL IF YOU COME FORWARD TO THE
MICROPHONE GIVE US YOUR NAME AND
YOUR AFFILIATION PLEASE.
WHERE MEMBERS GET?
SIR FLOCKS CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CHEN FLOOR ON
BEHALF OF WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING -- IN A CENTURY ON
BEHALF CONNECTION CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT.
JOY DEVON BOND BEHALF OF A A RP
AND IT'S THREE POINT THREE
MILLION MEMBERS IN CALIFORNIA WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
BECAUSE WE DON'T THINK SENIORS
OR ANYONE SHOULD HAVE TO CHOOSE
BETWEEN THE PRESCRIPTION GROCERS
MAKING FURTHER TESTIMONY TO
SECURE SUPPORT THANK YOU ANYONE
ELSE IN SUPPORT.
RIGHT SEEN NONE AS THEIR
OPPOSITION.
SEE THE COULD YOU CLEAR THE
TABLE FOR THEM
[inaudible]
WARNING WARNING.
PLEASE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS JEFF FRANCE SIR I AM -- THE
GENERAL COUNSEL OF THE
ASSOCIATION FOR ACCESSIBLE
MEDICINES WE REPRESENT THE
MANUFACTURERS OF GENERIC AND
BASS SIMILAR MEDICINES IN THE
UNITED STATES.
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN GENERIC
MEDICINES SAVED THE UNITED
STATES HEALTH CARE SYSTEM ONE
POINT SIX SEVEN TRILLION DOLLARS.
TWENTY TWO BILLION IN CALIFORNIA
ALONE.
WE SHARE THE GOALS OF THE
SPONSORS OF THIS BILL WHICH IS
TO AND DELAYED ACCESS TO
MEDICINES.
ARE COMPANIES FIGHT OFF BRAND
NAME DRUG PATENTS EVERY SINGLE
DAY.
AND JUST BY.
I COULD GIVE YOU ONE EXAMPLE
THAT THE DRUG HE MERA WHICH IS
THE HIGHEST GROSSING A
PRESCRIPTION DRUG IN THE UNITED
STATES HAS ONE HUNDRED THIRTY
SIX PATENTS.
THAT GO OUT TO THE YEAR.
TWENTY THIRTY FOUR A NUMBER OF
COMPANIES HAVE SETTLED WITH THE
MANUFACTURE OF THAT DRUG AB V. --
TO BRING COMPETITION IN TWENTY
TWENTY THREE THIS IS ELEVEN
YEARS EARLIER THAN THE
EXPIRATION OF THE PATENTS AND
OUR CONCERN IS THAT THE WAY THE
BILL AS DRAFTED.
THAT THAT SETTLEMENT WHICH WILL
BRING A BY A SIMILAR TO HUMAN
ERA -- ELEVEN YEARS BEFORE THE
PATENT ACCESS WOULD BE DEEMED
ILLEGAL.
WE BELIEVE THAT -- THE BILL
SHOULD ALLOW FOR PRO COMPETITIVE
PATTON SETTLEMENTS AND AS IT'S
CURRENTLY DRAFTED THAT THE BILL
WOULD NOT.
AND THAT'S BECAUSE THE BILL
WOULD MAKE IT PRESUMPTIVELY
ILLEGAL TO SETTLE PATENT
LITIGATION EVEN IF IT EXCEPT
EVEN IF IT ACCELERATES GENERIC
ENTRY.
IF ANYTHING OF VALUE INCLUDING
CONTRACTUAL PROVISIONS -- GOES
TO THE GENERIC OR THE BY A
SIMILAR THIS IS WHY THE SUPREME
COURT OF THE UNITED STATES AND
THE CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT HAD
SAID THAT THE PROPER WAY TO LOOK
AT THESE TYPES OF SETTLEMENTS IS.
IS THROUGH WHAT'S CALLED A RULE
OF REASON ANALYSIS WHERE YOU
LOOK AT THE PRO COMPETITIVE YOU
LOOK AT THE ANTI COMPETITIVE
THERE'S NOT A PRESUMPTION EITHER
WAY BECAUSE THESE ARE VERY
COMPLICATED -- TRANSACTIONS.
BECAUSE OF THE SUPREME COURT'S
DECISION ACTIVISTS THE FTC HAS
BEEN STUDYING THIS.
THIS ISSUE AND IN ITS LAST
REPORT -- I WILL I JUST WANT TO
READ TO YOU.
THE F. T. C. FOUND THAT -- THAT.
ONLY FIVE OF ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY
FINAL SETTLEMENTS IN FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY FIFTEEN INCLUDED
COMPENSATION TO THE GENERIC AND
A RESTRICTION ON GENERIC ENTRY
THE F. T. C. CONCLUDED THAT THIS
THIS IS THE LOWEST PROPORTION OF
POTENTIAL.
PAY FOR DELAY SETTLEMENTS
RELATIVE TO TOTAL FINAL
SETTLEMENT SINCE FY TWO THOUSAND
FOUR AND OTHER WORDS OF ONE
HUNDRED SEVENTY SETTLEMENTS THE
FTC FOUND ONLY.
FIVE WERE POTENTIALLY PAY FOR
DELAY.
THE ACTIVISTS DECISION IS
WORKING THIS TYPE OF RULE OF
REASON ANALYSIS IS ELIMINATING
THE TYPES OF SETTLEMENTS THAT
ALL OF US BELIEVE SHOULD BE
OUTLAWED.
AND WE'RE HAPPY TO WORK WITH YOU
TO TRY TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
GOOD SETTLEMENTS DON'T GET
THROWN OUT.
WITH THAT SETTLEMENTS.
THANK YOU THIS WITNESS PLEASE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS LINE IS
REALISTIC SENIOR DIRECTOR OF
STATE POLICY WITH THE
PHARMACEUTICAL RESEARCH AND
MANUFACTURERS OF AMERICA.
PHARMA HAS ADOPTED A POSITION OF
OPPOSE AND LAST AMENDED ON AB.
EIGHT TWENTY FOUR BEFORE THE
ASSEMBLY HEALTH COMMITTEE THE
AUTHORS OFFICE IN THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE WERE GRACIOUS
WITH THEIR TIME TO HEAR OUR
CONCERNS -- WITH THE BILL AS
CURRENTLY DRAFTED AND WE HOPE TO
CONTINUE THOSE MEETINGS AFTER
THE BILL IS HEARD TODAY.
ON THAT IS BECAUSE FARMER WANTS
TO WORK WITH CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATORS TO COME TO A MIDDLE
GROUND ON AB.
EIGHT TWENTY FOUR SPECIFICALLY I
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT ARE CONCERNED
WITH THE FRAMEWORK CREATED BY
THIS BILL WE'RE CONCERNED WITH
THE CREATION OF A PRESUMPTION
THAT CERTAIN AGREEMENTS ARE ANTI
COMPETITIVE.
COUPLED WITH THE HIGHER EVENT
ENTRY STANDARD OF CLEAR AND
CONVINCING EVIDENCE AND THE
LIMITS -- IN WAYS IN WHICH THE
DEFENDANTS CAN REBUT THE
PRESUMPTION THIS IS AN AREA
WHERE WE BELIEVE -- IMPROVEMENTS
CAN BE MADE TO THE BILL ALSO THE
BILL'S PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION
POTENTIALLY EXPANDS LIABILITY
FOR CONDUCT THAT IS ALREADY
SUBJECT TO SCRUTINY UNDER STATE
LAWS AND WILL FURTHER.
INCREASE UNCERTAINTY FOR BRANDON
GENERIC MANUFACTURERS THANK YOU
FOR YOUR ATTENTION AND WE ARE
HOPEFUL TO REACH AN AGREEMENT ON
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
WHAT ELSE IN OPPOSITION IF YOU
COULD GO FORWARD TO THE
MICROPHONE?
ALL RIGHT SEE NONE I'M GOING TO
BRING THIS.
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE MISS WHAT
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD I THINK THIS
HIGHLIGHTS.
A SIGNIFICANT TENSION BETWEEN
PATTON LINE AT A TRUST LAW.
WHICH HAS BECOME MORE AND MORE
SOPHISTICATED OVER THE YEARS
CONSTITUTION OBVIOUSLY THE
SOURCE OF THE PAT Là
INTENTIONALLY GIVING A MONOPOLY.
AND THAT HAS OFTEN BEEN ABUSED
IN AS WE TRY HAS TRIED TO
NAVIGATE THIS OVER THE YEARS.
BOTH OF THE FEDERAL THE STATE
LEVEL [inaudible]
BUILDING IN.
ANY TRUSTED IN GOING AFTER THOSE
WHO ARE ABUSING THEIR
SIGNIFICANT.
MARKET POWER HAS HAS ALWAYS BEEN
A REAL CHALLENGE SO FROM OUR
STANDPOINT FROM THIS COMMITTEE
STANDPOINT TRYING TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE CREATE A FRAMEWORK AND
SHIFT THE PRESUMPTION SAID OF
BEN.
BEN OUT THERE BECAUSE WITH THE
LARGE PHARMACEUTICAL
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF POWER IN
THE MARKET PLACE.
SMALLER GENERIC BRANDS WHICH ARE
GOOD FOR CONSUMERS ANDGOOD FOR
GETTING DRUG THERAPIES OUT INTO
THE MARKET IS REALLY WHAT THIS
IS ABOUT SO I THINK.
YOUR APPROACH IS IS CORRECT.
AND AS YOU TO CONTINUE SOUNDS
LIKE THERE'S PROBABLY GONNA BE
SOME CONTINUE NEGOTIATIONS I
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT YOU
LET US KNOW AS THAT GOES MISTER
WOULD BECAUSE I'M GOING WE'RE
GOING TO BE VERY CRITICAL I
THINK OF SHOOTING THIS TOO FAR
AWAY SO THAT WE I DO.
NOT WANT TO CREATE A SITUATION
WHERE WE WERE BACK.
TO I'M COMPETITIVE SO
ESSENTIALLY AND A TRUST BEHAVIOR
WITHOUT THE OVERSIGHT.
AND ESTABLISHING A PRESUMPTION
AND THIS AND THE ABILITY REBUT
IT AS DONE IN IN THIS BILL I
THINK IS A PRETTY GOOD FRAMEWORK
FOR BEING ABLE TO HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION THAT IS CLEARLY
SHIFTED I THINK TOO FAR THE
OTHER DIRECTION SO.
APPRECIATE YOU.
IN THIS FORWARD [inaudible]
I'M SORRY.
IT WAS THERE DID I MISS AN
OPPOSITION WITNESS I APOLOGIZE
MISTER JIMMY JACKSON ON BEHALF
BY A COMMON OPPOSITE OPPOSITE
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU.
OTHER.
COMMENTS BIZRATE'S.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I I DO
WANT TO THANK DOCTOR WOULD FOR
PRESENTING THIS BILL.
YESTERDAY IN SUB ONE WE TALKED
ABOUT THE VERY ISSUE.
OF THE HIGH COST OF PRESCRIPTION
DRUGS.
I APPRECIATE THAT THERE
CONTINUES TO BE CONVERSATION BUT
I I JOIN WITH YOU MISTER CHAIR
IN MAKING SURE THAT.
IN THE END WE HAVE THE
PROTECTION FOR THE CONSUMER --
WE DO WANT TO BE ABLE TO TO WORK
WITH THAT WITH THE
PHARMACEUTICAL COMPANIES.
BUT IN THE END OF THE PURPOSE OF
THE BILL IS TO PROTECT CONSUMERS.
AND MAKING SURE THAT THAT -- I
HATE TO USE THE WORD COLLUSION
BUT JUST.
EIGHTY EVERYTHING THAT WE
LEARNED FROM THIS PARTICULAR
BILL IS WHAT'S WRONG WITH THE
SETTLEMENTS -- AS YOU'VE
MENTIONED IT DOES PROVIDE IT'S
IT'S A REBUTTABLE PRESUMPTION.
IT DOESN'T MEAN THAT THAT'S THE
END ALL THE IT IS A REBUTTABLE
PRESUMPTION BUT I THINK THAT IT
LEVELS THE PLAYING FIELD WHEN
YOU HAVE THAT PRESUMPTION FROM
THE VERY BEGINNING.
THE IN THE AND WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT -- LOSS OF REVENUE WERE
TALKING ABOUT LOTS OF THINGS BUT
IN THE END IT'S THE CONSUMER
THAT WE HAVE TO BE MOST
CONCERNED WITH.
AND HAVING THESE CONTROLS IS
SOMETHING THAT IS VERY GOOD I
THANK YOU FOR BRING IT FORWARD
AND WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO MOVE
THE BILL.
THANK YOU YOU HAVE A MOTION IS
THERE A SECOND.
THANK YOU AT THE SITE
[inaudible]
MR OBERNOLTE.
I THANK YOU MISTER TERRACE
SOMEONE AND I THINK THIS IS AN
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT ISSUE THAT
YOU HIGHLIGHTED AND I THINK
YOU'RE DOING A REALLY GREAT JOB
OF WORKING WITH.
ALL SIDES TRYING CRAFTED A FAIR
AND COMPREHENSIVE SOLUTION TO IT
AND I'M I'M TRYING TO GET TO A
POSITION OF SUPPORT.
I HAD A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS FOR
THE BILL'S SUPPORTERS ONE FOR
HEALTH ACCESS AND ONE FOR THE AG
IF WE COULD -- GET THEM BACK UP.
SO FIRST FIRST HEALTH ACCESS WE
HEARD THE OPPOSITION TESTIFIED
THAT GENERIC DRUG MANUFACTURERS
FEEL.
THAT THIS MIGHT HAVE A CHILLING
EFFECT ON THE AVAILABILITY OF
GENERICS BECAUSE SOMETIMES THE
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENTS RESULT IN
GENERICS BEING AVAILABLE EARLIER
THAN THEY WOULD HAVE.
UNDER THE PATENT EXPIRATION.
CAN YOU ADDRESS THAT CONCERN
BECAUSE THAT'S ALSO CONCERNED
THAT I SHARE -- TO HEALTH
ACCESSORY YOU DON'T THINK SO ST
OKAY -- SERVICES ON A WE
DISAGREE THAT THE BILL WILL HAVE
A CHILLING EFFECT -- AND THAT
GENERICS WILL ACTUALLY NOT COME
TO MARKET SOONER AND I CAN TURN
IT OVER -- TO THE AG'S OFFICE TO
PROVIDE MORE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE THERE BUT WE DISAGREE
WITH THAT -- AND IT'S CLEAR THAT
THESE AGREEMENTS.
PRO LONG THE TIME THAT THE BRAND
NAME IS ON THE MARKET AND SORT
OF THE GENERIC AND THE BILL --
ADDRESSES THAT AN ALTERNATE OVER
THE J. AG'S OFFICE TO PROVIDE
MORE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE THERE.
OR PERHAPS I COULD END THIS IS
PROFESSOR FELDMAN.
IT'S TOUGH TO BE GENERIC THESE
DAYS THE INDUSTRY IS REELING
FROM A VARIETY OF ANTI
COMPETITIVE BEHAVIOR SINCE.
FROM BRAND NAME COMPANIES.
WE WANT THE GENERIC INDUSTRY TO
THRIVE BY GETTING ITS PRODUCT ON
THE MARKET AND SELLING CONSUMERS.
IF THE ONLY WAY YOU CAN SURVIVE
IS TO GET PAID BY OUR
COMPETITORS TO STAY OFF THE
MARKET.
THAT'S NOT A SUSTAINABLE
BUSINESS MODEL THAT'S NOT WHAT
WE WANT TO SEE FOR THAT INDUSTRY.
SURE -- I THINK GO AHEAD SO I
CHAU JOHNSON FOR THE AND I PRESS
SECTION OF THE AG'S OFFICE ARE
BILL SPECIFICALLY ALLOWS PRO
COMPETITIVE -- PAPER DELAY
AGREEMENTS IT'S SIMPLY SHIFTS
THE BURDEN IS TO SHOW THAT
CONSUMERS ARE BENEFITTED BY THAT
PARTICULAR AGREEMENT.
I KNOW THE MENTIONED THE HUMANE
TREATMENT.
AND AND CITED THAT IS AN EXAMPLE
OF A POSSIBLE PRO COMPETITIVE
AGREEMENT.
THERE IS NO EVIDENCE THAT THERE
IS ANY PAYMENT AND THIS SO THIS
BILL WOULD NOT REALLY.
IMPACT AN AGREEMENT WHERE THE
PARTIES HAVE LOOKED AT THE
PATENTS AND MADE.
OF THE STATE THAT THE PATENTS
AND SETTLED THIS DOESN'T PREVENT
THAT AT ALL THE FACT THIS
ENCOURAGES THE PARTIES TO SETTLE
ON THOSE LINES WITHOUT PAYING
[inaudible]
OKAY -- BUT I THINK THAT THEY
KNOW THE THE BILL ENCOMPASSES
THE DESIRE. TO TO ALLOW PRO
COMPETITIVE BEHAVIOR WOULD AND
AVOID ANTI COMPETITIVE BEHAVIOR
BY THE EXEMPTION THAT'S IN THERE
BUT I WOULD ENCOURAGE -- YOU
MISTER WOULD TO WORK WITH THE
GENERIC DRUG MANUFACTURERS AND
MAKE SURE THAT HERE'S ENOUGH
LATITUDE IN THE PROOF PROVISIONS
OF THE EXEMPTION -- THAT THEY
HAVE THE ROOM TO BE ABLE TO DO
THAT BECAUSE WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT CONSUMERS GET THE
BENEFIT OF EARLY ACCESS TO
GENERIC DRUGS AND WE WOULDN'T
WANT TO STAND IN THE WAY THAT.
YOU AND I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
QUESTION IN YOUR COMMENTS AND I
ABSOLUTELY WILL CONTINUE IN THAT
IN THAT DIRECTION.
I THINK THAT YOU KNOW SOME OF
WHAT YOU'VE HEARD TODAY -- IS
ACTUALLY A WHOLE NOTHER LAYER OF
THE ONION THAT THAT THAT WE
COULD PEEL OFF BUT WE'RE NOT AND
THAT'S AROUND THE PATENTS AND
THERE ARE PATENTS THEIR FILE
BETTER WE CALL WEAK PATENTS.
THAT MAKE IT -- AND THAT REALLY
OBSTACLES -- FOR EVERYONE --
THEY'RE DIFFICULT TO FIGHT
THEY'RE EXPENSIVE -- AND THEY
AND THEY PROTECT THE BRAND NAME
EVEN MORE AND SO WE'RE WE'RE
FOCUSED ON ONE ONE ISSUE HERE
AND THAT IS THESE AND WHAT WE
BELIEVE OR NOT.
OR ANTI COMPETITIVE --
ACTIVITIES AND THAT'S THAT'S
WHERE FOLKS ON HERE BECAUSE WE
THINK IT'S GOOD FOR CONSUMER
WELL I LOOK FORWARD TO YOUR
FUTURE LEGISLATION ON THAT TOPIC.
MY SECOND QUESTION IS FOR THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT THAT THE AG IS
GONNA BE EMPOWERED UNDER THIS
BILL TO ENFORCE THE PROVISIONS
OF THE BILL.
BUT THERE'S ALSO A PART OF THE
BILL.
THAT GIVES THIRD PARTIES THE
ABILITY TO SUE UNDER THE UNFAIR
PRACTICES ACT.
A FOUR DAY ADDITIONAL DAMAGES
I'M WONDERING WHY THAT'S IN
THERE BECAUSE IT SEEMED LIKE THE
UNIVERSE OF DRUG MANUFACTURERS
BEING SO SMALL THAT THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL WOULD BE THE APPROPRIATE
VENUE TO BRING SUIT AND TO
ENFORCE THE MEASURES OF THE BILL.
WELL CERTAINLY THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL CANNOT BE EVERYWHERE AND
THEY CANNOT GO AFTER A LIVE
THESE AGREEMENTS.
EVEN WITH THIS BILL THESE CASES
ARE GOING TO BE EXTREMELY
RESOURCE INTENSIVE -- TAKE THE
EXAMPLE THE FTC OVER THE LAST
FOUR YEARS.
LAST NINE YEARS AS ONLY BROUGHT
FOR ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS THEY
TYPICALLY HAVE TO HAVE. THIRTY
FIVE ATTORNEY SAID EVEN THOUGH
WE'VE ADJUSTED THE BURDEN OF
PROOF THEY'RE STILL GOING TO BE.
IS SUBSTANTIAL EXPERTISE AND
YEARS OF LITIGATION WE HAVE JUST
CHANGED.
SAME FIELD SO IT'S A LITTLE BIT
MORE THAN.
AND SO WE STILL ANTICIPATE THAT
WHAT EVER ENFORCEMENT IS DONE BY
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL.
IS GOING TO NEED TO BE
SUPPLEMENTED BY PRIVATE
LITIGANTS.
YEAH BUT THIS -- DOES NOT ALTER
THE PENALTIES AT THAT ARE MADE
AVAILABLE UNDER THE HEART RIGHT
AFTER.
THE UNFAIR PRACTICES
[inaudible]
OKAY SO.
IF I COULD I FOLLOW UP WITH WHAT
MY COLLEAGUE SAID -- YOU KNOW
ONE THING TO ALSO CONSIDER
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IS THAT --
CURRENTLY UNDER CURRENT LAW THE
PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION EXISTS
AND WHAT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE
ABOUT THIS PARTICULAR TYPE OF
LAW IS REALLY THE SUBJECT MATTER
EXPERTISE THAT'S INVOLVED AND SO
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
A HANDFUL OF ATTORNEYS THAT
COULD BRING THIS TYPE OF CASE
THAT HAVE EXPERTISE IN PATENT
LAW AND ANTI TRUST LAW AND
REALLY GET AS AS OF MY COLLEAGUE
NOTE NOTED THE EXPENSE OF THESE
CASES REALLY IT'S IT'S VERY FEW
TYPES OF PLAINTIFFS -- THAT CAN
BRING THIS KIND OF ACTION SO
WE'RE NOT LOOKING AT THE KIND OF
PLAYER IF.
IN RATHER IN ORDER TO DETERMINE
THE CORRECT TYPE OF PLAYER FOR
ASIAN OF THESE AGREEMENTS WE WE
NEED THE ABILITY FOR THEIR TO BE
PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION IN
ADDITION TO WHAT THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL CAN BRING -- BECAUSE IS
AS MISS JOHNSON NOTED ON THERE
THERE'S NO WAY FOR GOVERNMENT TO
BE EVERYWHERE AT ALL THE TIME.
RIGHT SO.
THE WHOLE REASON FOR HAVING A
BILL LIKE THIS IS BECAUSE WE
DON'T WANT THERE TO BE A PROFIT
MOTIVE TO KEEP GENERIC DRUGS OFF
THE MARKET.
BUT LIKE WHY IS -- I DON'T THINK
WE WANT TO CREATE A PROFIT
MOTIVE FOR PREDATORY LAW FIRMS.
TO GO RAKE PHARMACEUTICAL
MANUFACTURERS WHO AREN'T BEING
ANTI COMPETITIVE OVER THE COALS
AND IF YOU LOOK AT THE UNFAIR
PRACTICES ACT THERE ARE A LOT OF
LAW FIRMS THAT ARE GOOD ACTORS
IN THAT RESPECT AND THERE ARE A
FEW THAT.
ACTIVELY GO OUT AND SEEK THESE
BECAUSE THEY HAVE A PROFIT
MOTIVE NOT BECAUSE THEY'RE
TRYING TO IMPROVE THE PLAYING
FIELD FOR CONSUMERS.
SO -- IT TO THE EXTENT THAT THE
AG DOESN'T HAVE THE RESOURCES TO
GO AFTER.
THE THE THEY IS THE
PHARMACEUTICAL MANUFACTURERS
THAT WE THINK ARE BEING ABUSIVE
I WOULD LIKE US TO GIVE YOU MORE
RESOURCES TO DO THAT RATHER THAN
TO RELY ON PRIVATE INDIVIDUALS
WHO MAY NOT HAVE THE BEST
INTEREST OF THE CONSUMER APART
SO.
I MEAN IF IF I VOTED AGAINST THE
BILL THIS WOULD BE THE REASON
BECAUSE I'M A BIT CONCERNED
ABOUT THAT SO I'M GONNA
SUPPORTER TODAY I THOUGHT I'D
LIKE TO ENCOURAGE YOU.
ASSEMBLYMAN WOULD TO AS THE BILL
MOVES FORWARD SERIOUSLY CONSIDER --
TONING THAT PART OF THE BILL
DOWN BECAUSE I WOULD I THINK THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S THE
APPROPRIATE VENUE TO BRING SUIT
TO ENFORCE THE PROVISIONS THE
BILL.
BUT I THINK YOU I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONCERN I WOULD JUST NOTE
THAT THE PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION
DOES EXIST ALREADY -- AND THE
PEOPLE THAT WOULD LIKELY BRING
SUIT OTHER THAN THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL OR PEOPLE LIKE EMPLOYERS --
PAYERS -- LABOR UNIONS -- HARDLY
YOU KNOW CLASS ACTION LAWSUIT --
TYPE THINGS AND PARTLY BECAUSE
THE COST OF LITIGATING THESE IS
SO HIGH IT MAY COST FIVE TO TEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN EXPERT
WITNESSES ALONE TO TRY CASES
LIKE THIS.
SO THIS IS NOT THE KIND OF CASE
THAT IS GOING TO BE -- BROUGHT
WITH FRIVOLOUS LAWSUITS THESE
ARE THESE ARE REALLY DIFFICULT
CASES -- TO UNRAVEL AND THAT'S
PART OF WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO
IS TO CHANGE THE BURDEN OF PROOF
HERE.
ON THIS AD TO SAY YOU KNOW THESE
ARE NOT ANTI COMPETITIVE
AGREEMENTS THEN THEN SHOW US
INSTEAD OF HIDING BEHIND -- THE
EGGS THE THE CURRENT THE CURRENT
STATUS QUO AND SO WE'RE TRYING
TO SHIFT THIS PENDULUM -- IN
FAVOR OF CONSUMERS -- WERE IT
CLEARLY ISN'T RIGHT NOW I THINK
WELL I I RESPECT YOUR OPTIMISM
THAT IT WOULD NOT BE ABUSED BUT
EXPERIENCE SHOWS THAT HAS BEEN
ABUSED.
IN OTHER VENUES AND THAT'S WHY
I'M SO CAUTIOUS ABOUT IT BUT I
THANK YOU FOR THE GOOD WORK ON
THE BILL.
WELL WHILE WE'RE BASHING
ATTORNEYS I THINK WE SHOULD ALSO
POINT OUT THAT WHAT WAS.
WHAT WAS MENTIONED THERE THE
THESE THE HIGH PRICE PREDATORY
ATTORNEYS OFTEN HAPPEN ON THE
SIDE OF THE VERY LARGE DRUG
COMPANIES HERE BECAUSE?
UNFORTUNATELY THE PATENT LAWS
HAVE OFTEN BEEN USED.
STRATEGICALLY PAT PROSECUTION IS
USED TO TEACH ECCLES BY THE HIGH
PRICE LAW FIRMS IN ORDER TO
ENFORCE REINFORCED A COMPETITIVE
ADVANTAGE IN THE MARKETPLACE
WHAT THIS BILL DOES BECAUSE WERE
SHIPPING IT. TO ANTI TRUST IS
BALANCE SOME OF THAT OUT BECAUSE
THE LARGE CORPORATIONS WITH THE
LARGE BANK ACCOUNTS HAVE THE
ABILITY TO STRATEGICALLY GO
AFTER.
VERY SMALL PATTON'S IS A WAY OF
BLOCKING ANYBODY ELSE FROM
GETTING INTO THE GENERIC MARKET.
THAT'S THE COMPLEXITY OF OF
PATENT LAW SO YOUR COMPLAINT IS
ACTUALLY MORE HAS BEEN MORE
ABUSED ON THE SIDE OF PAT
PROSECUTION.
AS OPPOSED TO PATENT.
ENFORCEMENT FOR SMALL COMPANIES
TRYING TO FIND THEIR THEIR NICHE.
SO MS GONZALEZ AND THEN AS
PETRIE-NORRIS IN THE MISTER
CHILD.
THE CHAIR OF HELP ME UNDERSTAND
MY QUESTION MORE AND I'M ALWAYS
A CLEAR WHEN I DON'T.
UNDERSTAND A PORCH IN THE LAW.
I DON'T REMEMBER LEARNING THIS
IN LAW SCHOOL I MIGHT HAVE SLEPT
THROUGH THIS PORTION -- IT'S
VERY DENSE AND I'M SMART ENOUGH
TO ADMIT WHEN I DON'T KNOW
SOMETHING SELMA START WITH THAT --
NO EXPERIENCS Là THE VALUES I
UNDERSTAND I'M WITH YOU I SECOND
I'M GONNA VOTE WITH US.
BUT I'M TRYING TO GET TO WHAT
CAN OR MAYBE IS BEING TALKED
ABOUT BEING FIXED AND ONE OF MY
QUESTIONS -- HAD TO DO I MEAN
MAYBE I UNDERESTIMATED -- OR
MAYBE OVER ESTIMATE WHAT TAKES
TO GET A PATENT BUT IT HAS TO
WITH THE PRESUMPTION OF VALIDITY
OF THE PATENT.
I UNDERSTAND THE REASON THE
REBUTTABLE PRESUMPTION -- WHEN
IT COMES TO THE ANTI COMPETITIVE
BEHAVIOR BUT?
I AID DON'T.
UNDERSTAND THE VILLAGE DIDN'T
YOU'RE LOOKING AT ME LIKE.
MAYBE I SHOULD BE ASKING NO GO
AHEAD OKAY MAYBE YOU CAN ANSWER
SHE'S GOT THE ANSWER OKAY.
SO WHY WHY IS THAT NECESSARY FOR
THE JUDGE AND JURY THE THE
PRESUMPTION OF VALIDITY THE
POUND.
SURE -- AND AND GOSH I HOPE YOU
NEVER FELL ASLEEP IN ANY OF ANY
OF MY CLASSES IN IT OR AYE AYE
MIGRATED ACTUALLY FALSELY BUT
THIS IS REALLY I MEAN TO TRY TO
GET TO THE LEGAL ISSUES HERE IS
REALLY.
NOT MY SPECIALTY I'M ALWAYS I'LL
BUT TALK ABOUT LABOR LAW EVERY
DAY OF THE WEEK BUT THERE WAS
ONLY START WITH THE THIRTY
THOUSAND FOOT VIEW IN THE
TOXICITY CLEA -- ABOUT THAT THE
THE PRESUMPTIONS IN THE BILL --
ARE THERE TO HELP THE COURTS TO
GET TO WHAT THIS IS ABOUT AND
THAT IS IF YOU'RE GOING TO PAY
YOUR COMPETITOR TO STAY OFF THE
MARKET.
YOU NEED TO SHOW US THAT THERE
IS A GOOD PROGRAM HEADED OF
REASON TO DO IT THAT'S THAT'S
WHAT THE LOSS IS SUPPOSED TO BE
ABOUT.
AND THE YOU KNOW THAT THAT
SWEEPS ASIDE SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT COURTS HAVE GOTTEN CONFUSED
ABOUT.
I BUT I DO WANT TO ADDRESS YOUR
YOUR ISSUE ABOUT PATENTS --
BECAUSE THE SYSTEM FOR RAPID
ENTRY OF GENERIC DRUGS WAS
DESIGNED TO ENCOURAGE GENERIC
DRUG COMPANIES TO DO BATTLE
AGAINST THE BIG GUNS.
AND CONGRESS RECOGNIZE THAT
THERE ARE A LOT OF PATENTS OUT
THERE THAT ARE NOT VALID AND
THEY'RE A LOT FANS OUT THERE
THAT MAY BE VALID BUT DON'T
APPLY TO PARTICULAR GENERIC
DRUGS.
SO THERE ARE -- OF INCENTIVES
CREATED WITHIN THE LAW TO PUSH
GENERICS AMOUNT OF THESE
CHALLENGES IN COURT.
NOW THE BRAND DRUG COMPANIES
HAVE FOUND IN AND RUN ABOUT THEM
DON'T DON'T FIGHT IT OUT IN
COURT -- WIFI TO NURSING COURT
JUST JUST PAY THEM HANDSOMELY
AND THEN LET THEM AGREE TO STAY
OFF THE THE MARKET.
THAT'S WHAT'S GOING ON IF ALL
PATENTS WERE GOOD AND SOLID.
WE WOULDN'T HAVE THIS PROBLEM
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
SO WE JUST HAND OUT PATENTS ARE.
ANYTHING AT THE AYE I DIDN'T
KNOW THIS THIS IS OUR YEAH WELL
SO.
IT'S GOOD TO KNOW.
AND HAVE IT ANSWERED BY MAYBE
MORE ON A PASSING ANYONE EVER
WANTS TO KNOW.
WELL I THINK THE FACT THAT YOU
HAVE DRUGS WHICH CLAIMED THERE
ARE A HUNDRED AND THIRTY SIX
PATENTS THAT COVER.
A SINGLE DRUG SUGGEST YOU THAT
MAY BE TOO MANY PATENTS SERBIAN
ISSUED OR MAYBE TOO MANY.
ARE BEING USED TO CLAIM
PROTECTION FOR THE DRUG WE HAVE --
INSTANCES WHERE YOU HAVEN'T AND
CHAPTER FOR INSTANCE SENDING
CHECKS AT THE NORTH FROM MARK
INSULIN.
AND YET EACH OF THOSE LITTLE
NEEDLES THAT HAVE BEEN IN USE
FOR FOR YEARS MAY HAVE FIFTEEN
OR TWENTY PATENTS THAT THEY
CLAIM.
COVER VARIOUS ASPECTS OF THEM SO
THESE PATENTS ARE OFTEN VERY
NARROW AND THE GENERIC CAN WORK
AROUND THEM OR DOESN'T INFRINGE
THEM BUT YET THEY CLOG.
THE THEY STOP COMPETITION SO
THAT THE SCHEME OF OUR
PHARMACEUTICAL LAWS WAS TO
ENCOURAGE THE GENERICS.
WHO BEST KNOW WHAT THOSE PATENT
WHICH PANTS ARE GOOD WHICH ONES
COVER WHAT THEY MIGHT DO? TO
CHALLENGE THE PATENTS AND FREE
THEM FREE UP THE MARKET PLACE
FOR OTHERS TO IT FOR GENERIC
ENTRY [inaudible]
BUT LETTER TO I I WILL I WOULD
LOVE TO HEAR ANOTHER PERSPECTIVE --
AS WELL WELL IT'S A SIMILAR
PERSPECTIVE WHEN IT COMES TO THE
PATENT SYSTEM AND OUR COMPANY IS
THE GENERIC MANUFACTURERS ARE
CONSTANTLY.
DOING BATTLE IN COURT AGAINST
OUR FOR OUR FRIENDS FROM THE THE
BRANDED SIDE OF THE ECOSYSTEM
AND YOU KNOW THERE ARE DOZENS OF
PATENTS THAT ARE AT STAKE.
IN THE MOST MODERN BIOTECHNOLOGY
DRUGS THESE PATENTS COST.
WHAT'S BEEN ESTIMATED BY THE
FEDERAL CIRCUIT TO BE BETWEEN.
A MILLION AND THREE MILLION
DOLLARS PER PATENT TO PROSECUTE
IT'S ENORMOUSLY EXPENSIVE
ENDEAVOR SO WE HEAR ACCUSATIONS
THAT OUR COMPANIES ARE LAYING
DOWN AND LETTING THEMSELVES BE
BRIBED.
NOTHING COULD BE FURTHER FROM
THE TRUTH WE GO TO COURT WE
SPENDING NORMAIS LEGAL FEES BUT
SOMETIMES AS IN AND ANY OTHER
TYPE OF LITIGATION THE THE
BETTER COURSE OF VALOR RATHER
THAN.
BOTH -- THE BRAND COMPANIES IN
THE GENERIC COMPANIES CHURNING
OUT MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OF LEGAL FEES IS TO
SETTLE.
THE QUESTION HERE IS.
DO WE WANT THERE TO BE FAIR
SETTLEMENTS ARE NOT AND IF WE DO
IF WE WANT SETTLEMENTS THAT WILL
ACTUALLY BRING DRUGS TO MARKET
BEFORE THE EXPIRATION OF PATENTS.
WE CAN'T PUT SUCH A PRESUMPTION
THAT THE SETTLEMENTS ARE ILLEGAL
SUCH THAT THESE SETTLEMENTS WILL
BE CHILLED.
AND THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS
UNDER THIS BILL.
THE GOVERNMENT WOULDN'T HAVE TO
PROVE THAT THERE WAS DELAY
GENERIC ENTRY THEY WOULD JUST
HAVE TO PROVE THAT THERE WAS A
SETTLEMENT.
AND THAT SOMETHING OF VALUE NO
MATTER HOW SMALL WENT TO THE
GENERIC AND THEN ALL THE SUDDEN
YOU'RE FACED WITH ENORMOUS.
INCLUDING PRIVATE RIGHT OF
INCENTIVES NOT TO SETTLE.
SO THAT'S A PRESUMPTION THAT'S
REBUTTABLE.
THANKS BYE AS SOMEBODY WHO PUTS
A LOT OF REBUTTABLE PRESUMPTION
Là I'M NOT GONNA ARGUE WITH.
WITH WHAT'S BEEN DONE HERE I'M
SICK OF IT YES THE HIGHEST
POSSIBLE STANDARD OTHER THAN --
I JUST. ONE COMMENT ONE QUICK
FINAL QUESTION.
AS IT SEEMS TO ME WITH ALL DUE
RESPECT TO THE MORE I HEAR AS
THIS ISSUE WAS PRESENTED.
FROM ALL SIDES THAT -- THAT
THERE'S A LOT OF JUST GET YOU
YOU GUYS ARE ENGAGED IN A GAME.
I'M LARGELY.
AS OF A GENERIC WANTING TO SUE
SO THAT THEY CAN BE FIRST IN
LINE.
WHEN THE PATENT EXPIRES IN HAVE
EIGHT TIMES BY WHICH THEY'RE THE
FIRST GENERIC CAM I MEAN THERE'S
A LOT GOING ON HERE?
THAT IT'S A FINANCIAL MOTIVE AS
WELL TO DO THESE LAWSUITS AND
THAT'S WHAT THE FEDERAL LAW
CREATED I I UNDERSTAND AND SO
THE FEDERAL LAW SEEMS VERY
MESSED UP IN CREATED LIKE A GAME
THAT'S BEING PLAYED OUT IN
COURTS AND SETTLEMENTS AND
THAT'S I THINK WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO GET.
IT THAT'S MY UNDERSTANDING.
TRYING TO BREAK THIS DOWN FOR
THE FOLKS AT HOME -- THAT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT IT SEEMS
LIKE IT'S HAPPENING ON ALL SIDES
IN IN BECAUSE OF FEDERAL LAW IS
WRITTEN IN A WAY THAT ALLOWS
KIND OF THIS -- THIS BEHAVIOR
THAT.
GAMES A SYSTEM FOR EVERY BUT
AGAIN FOR EVERYBODY EXCEPT THE
CONSUMER.
SO I UNDERSTAND THAT IS MY
UNDERSTANDING OF THIS LAW AND
THAT'S WHY I'M SUPPORTIVE BUT I
DO HAVE ONE QUESTION I HEARD A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THEIR STILL
THINGS WERE WORKING ON AND
POSSIBLY CAN WORK ON I WOULD SAY
FROM THE PROPONENTS WHAT DO YOU.
DO YOU FEEL THE SAME WAY THAT
THERE IS STILL THINGS WE CAN
WORK ON TO TO HELP MOVE THIS
BILL AND WHAT ARE THOSE THINGS.
HI DOCTOR WOULD MAYBE YEAH I
WOULD JUST I WOULD JUST SAY I'M
ALWAYS OPEN TO WORKING TO
WORKING ON THIS I THINK THAT ONE
OF THE CHALLENGES IS.
THE PENDULUM HAS BEEN SO FAR IN
FAVOR OF THE DRUG COMPANIES --
THROUGH THE FTC PROCESS THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO SHIFT IT THE
OTHER WAY SO WE'RE GOING TO FAR
I'M MORE THAN HAPPY TO TO LISTEN
TO THAT AND AND AND LOOK FOR A
RESOLUTION THERE.
BUT I THINK IT'S TIME THAT MAYBE
THE CONSUMER GETS THE UPPER HAND
OR AT LEAST GET A FAIR SHAKE AND
I THINK WE'VE HAD A FAIR SHAKE
FOR A LONG LONG TIME.
SO IF THERE'S AN ISSUE OUT THERE
THAT IS BEING WORKED ON IT
HASN'T BEEN NIGHT YOU HAVEN'T
FOUND ONE YET IDENTIFIED THAT
YOU'RE CONTINUING TO WORK ON
WILL WE I I HAVEN'T CAN I
HAVEN'T FELT WOULD BE A NEW
ISSUE THAT.
THEY BRING UP FROM THE BILL THAT
WOULD BE WORKED ON OKAY I JUST
WANNA BE CLEAR AS THIS MOVES
BECAUSE EXPECTATIONS.
I'VE LEARNED YES VERY IMPORTANT
FOR EVERYBODY'S EXPECTATIONS TO
BE IN THE SAME PLACE MY DOOR IS
ALWAYS OPEN I WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE IF THERE IF THERE
ARE REASONABLE -- PROBLEMS
BROUGHT TO US THAT DO NOT
WEEKEND THE INTENT OF WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO ABSOLUTELY WE WILL
CONSIDER THEM [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THIS PETRIE-NORRIS AND
THEN MR CHAU.
I THINK I'M ONE OF TWO NON
LAWYERS ON THIS COMMITTEE SO A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS FROM THAT
PERSPECTIVE SO.
IF I UNDERSTOOD CORRECTLY THE
OPPOSITION ASSERTS THAT THIS
BILL IS IN CONFLICT WITH THE
SUPREME COURT'S RELIVE RECENT
TEST.
AND CLEARLY THE THE AUTHOR IN
THE SUPPORTERS OF THE BILL.
DO NOT BELIEVE THAT.
THAT SEEMS LIKE A PRETTY
FUNDAMENTAL.
I DISCONNECT CAN YOU HELP I
GUESS CALPERS HELP ME WRAP MY
MIND AROUND -- I GUESS.
IN WHY THERE'S THAT THAT
DISCONNECTED INTERPRETATION AND
WHAT WOULD BE REQUIRED. TO
RESOLVE THAT.
CERTAINLY SO -- FILL THERE ISN'T
THERE ISN'T A CONFLICT BETWEEN
RULE OF REASON LAW AND WHAT THE
BILL DOES.
THE BILL LOOKS AT WHO BEARS WHAT
BURDENS AS THAT LAW PLAYS OUT
THE QUESTION IN A RULE OF REASON.
IS IS THERE A PRO COMPETITIVE
BENEFIT THAT STILL IN THE BILL
IT'S STILL FOLLOWS BOTH THE
FEDERAL ANTI TRUST LAW AND
CALIFORNIA'S STATE ANTITRUST LAW.
THEY'RE THERE TO SYSTEMS FOR
ANTI TRUST AND THEY ARE ALLOWED
TO EXIST AND THAT THEY HAD THEY
ARE DIFFERENT IN SOME WAYS
CALIFORNIA'S IS ACTUALLY OLDER
THAN THE FEDERAL SYSTEM -- BUT
NONE OF THIS CHANGES THE BASIC
NOTION THAT WERE ASKING IF YOU
WANT TO DO THIS IS THERE A PRO
COMPETITIVE REASON AND ASKING
THAT THE COMPANY'S PROOF THAT.
AND HOW DOES THAT DIFFER FROM.
YOUR INTERPRETATION AND THE
ACTIVISTS DECISION THE SUPREME
COURT AND A DECISION THAT WAS --
AUTHORED BY JUSTICE PRIOR.
UP REJECTED.
AN AUTOMATIC PRESUMPTION THAT A
SETTLEMENT BETWEEN A BRAND AND
GENERIC IS AUTOMATICALLY ANTI
COMPETITIVE THEY SAID THAT SUCH
A PRESUMPTION WAS APPROPRIATE
QUOTE ONLY WHERE AN OBSERVER
WITH EVEN A RUDIMENTARY
UNDERSTANDING OF ECONOMICS.
COULD CONCLUDE THAT THE
ARRANGEMENT QUESTION.
WOULD HAVE AN ANTI COMPETITIVE A
FACT ON CUSTOMERS AND MARKETS
AND QUOTE.
AND SO WHAT THE SUPREME COURT
HELD WAS THAT IF THERE IS SUCH A
SETTLEMENT THAT.
THERE THE GOVERNMENT HAS THE
BURDEN TO PROVE THAT IT WAS ANTI
COMPETITIVE BECAUSE SOME OF
THESE SETTLEMENTS XCELERATED
GENERIC ACCESS AND AND AND ONLY
A SMALL NUMBER DO NOT.
THIS BILL -- REJECTS WHAT THE
SUPREME COURT HELD AND INCLUDES
A PRESUMPTION THAT IS ONLY
REBUTTABLE BY CLEAR AND
CONVINCING EVIDENCE WHICH IS A
VERY HIGH STANDARD -- THAT.
A WHOLE BOLUS OF SETTLEMENTS
THAT.
THE F. T. C. HAS FOUND ARE FINE
BECAUSE THE F. T. C.
AUTOMATICALLY GETS THE DETAILS
OF ALL OF THEM -- IT THAT IT
JUST -- CREATES A DIFFERENT
STANDARD.
AND THE IT'S NOT THAT THE YOU
KNOW FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS
ALWAYS RIGHT AND STATE THROW IS
WRONG BUT THIS IS A SHARP
DEPARTURE.
FROM WHAT THE FTC HAS BEEN DOING
FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS AND WHICH
HAS RESULTED IN.
THE AN EXTREME SMALL AMOUNT OF
OF SETTLEMENTS THAT HAVE VALUE
GOING TO GENERICS. SIX THEN YOU
WOULD ASSERT THAT JUST THE
NOTION OF A REBUTTABLE
PRESUMPTION IN THIS ARENA.
IS IN CONFLICT WITH THE RESERVE
REPORT EXPRESSLY REJECTED THAT.
THIS READ.
I WOULD JUST LIKE TO SAY FIRST I
THINK THE BILL IS CONSISTENT
WITH THE FTC PROCESS -- THE FTC
ACTION ON THEIR WEBSITE --
INDICATES THEY WANT LEGISLATION
ON THIS ISSUE -- SECOND -- THE
CURRENT WE IT THE FTC PROCESS
ALLOWS FOR PRIVATE RIGHT OF
ACTION SO THIS IS NOT THERE'S
NOT INCONSISTENT.
I THINK THE DRUG MANUFACTURERS
ACTUALLY WANT YOU TO BELIEVE
THAT -- THERE IS PREEMPTION ON
THIS ISSUE BY CLAIMING
INCONSISTENCY WITH THE FTC
PROCESS I THINK YOU'VE HEARD
THAT HERE TODAY.
LET ME TELL YOU THERE'S NO PRE
EMPTION HERE -- CALIFORNIA HAS
LONG AND HAD A HISTORY OF
ADOPTING A STRONGER ANTI A TRUST
LIKE LEGISLATION AND WE'RE
COMPLETE WITHIN OUR RIGHTS TO DO
SO -- TO HAVE STRICTER RULES
STRICTER LAWS IN CALIFORNIA AND
WE DO THAT ON A NUMBER ON A
NUMBER OF ISSUES -- SO I DON'T
BELIEVE IT'S I DON'T BELIEVE
IT'S ANTICOMPLY ID THAT IS IN
CONFLICT -- WITH THE SUPREME
COURT IN ANYWAY I THINK IT
ACTUALLY THEY ACTUALLY GO SIGNED
THEY GO SIDE BY SIDE.
WELL AND I'M.
JUST MAYBE TO ANSWER THEM PLUS A
QUESTION THERE.
WERE FULLY WITHIN OUR RIGHTS AS
A LEGISLATIVE BODY TO NOT AGREE
WITH THE SUPREME COURT AND SET
OUR OWN STANDARDS.
I MIGHT ALSO NOTE THAT THE
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT HAS
DEALT WITH THE ISSUE OF THESE
PAY FOR DELAY AGREEMENTS.
AND HAS TAKEN A DIFFERENT
APPROACH FROM THE US SUPREME
COURT IT HAS FOUND.
AGREEMENTS ARE VERY HARMFUL TO
CONSUMER AND HAS URGED TO
STANDARD THAT IS MUCH MORE
STRIPPED.
AND HAS URGED MORE ROBUST
ENFORCEMENT RECOGNIZING THE
FRAILTIES THAT THE ACT OF THIS
DECISION.
RIGHT THIS IS THAT YOUR QUESTION.
THANK YOU WITH A CHOP.
I'M I'M WONDERING WHETHER
ANYBODY CAN ACTUALLY CAN SHARE
WITH US EITHER -- AN EXAMPLE OR
A CASE.
WITH FACTS THAT WOULD -- SHOW A
STAT THE PRESUMPTION CAN BE
REBUTTED EITHER IN TERMS OF THE
VALUE BEING FAIR OR HAVING THE
PRETTY COMPETITIVE BENEFITS --
OF THE OUT WAIT YOU KNOW.
ALL WEATHER WISE.
WELL I KNOW IT'S A I KNOW IT'S
FACTUAL I KNOW IT'S A YOU KNOW
EVERYTHING'S CASE BY CASE BUT
WHAT ARE SOME OF THE FACTORS
THAT ARE BEING CONSIDERED FOR
EXAMPLE THAT COULD BE USED IN
THE WEIGHING OF THE A THE
BALANCING OF THE OF THE TO DO
YOU.
KNOW THE TWO PROBLEMS WITH THE
THREE PROBLEMS WELL FOR INSTANCE
LET'S SAY THE GENERIC DRUG
COMPANY HAS PURCHASED -- AN
INVENTORY OF ACTIVE INGREDIENT
FROM THE BRAND COMPANY.
SO THE BRAND COMPANY MAY BE.
THIS IS SO SO THERE'S PAYMENT
BUT THE COMPANIES CAN SHOW THAT
THERE IS VALUE FOR THAT PAYMENT
REASONABLE VALUE FOR THAT
PAYMENT -- SO THAT IS NOT PAID
FOR DELAY IT'S PAY FOR SOME
ALTERNATIVE PRODUCT OR SERVICES
AND IT'S A REASONABLE --
APPROXIMATION OF THE VALUE OF
THAT PRODUCT OR SERVICES THAT'S
BEING.
SHARED BETWEEN THE COMPANIES.
SO THAT'S THE CASE WERE TO VALUE
COULD BE DEEMED FAIR.
IN THAT PARTICULAR CONTEXT IN
RIGHT AND IT WOULD BE UP TO THE
DRUG COMPANIES TO ESTABLISH THAT
THAT WAS WHAT WAS TRULY
HAPPENING.
TYPICALLY IN THESE CASES THE
DRUG COMPANIES DON'T PROVIDE
DOCUMENTS AS TO WHAT ACTUALLY
WENT ON IN THESE AGREEMENTS.
THEY WITHHOLD THE DOCUMENTS AS
PRIVILEGED SO IT IT CREATES A
VACUUM OF EVIDENCE WHICH GIVES
AN UNFAIR ADVANTAGE TO TO THE
DRUG COMPANIES AND THAT'S PART
OF WHAT THE BILL DOES HERE.
IS TO ALIGN THAT PRESUMPTION
WITH THE PERSON WHO POSSESSES
THE EVIDENCE THAT WILL BE A JURY
QUESTION.
THAT WOULD BE A JURY QUESTION
QUICK QUESTION FOR THE JURY TO
ANSWER IS FACTUAL QUESTION
ESSENTIAL YES OKAY.
THANK YOU.
IF I COULD RESPOND I THINK THAT
THAT'S A GREAT EXAMPLE OF WHERE
THERE SHOULD BE VERY CLEAR CARVE
OUT.
FROM A VERY STRONG PRESUMPTION
AND I AGREE WITH THE ETERNAL
GENERAL'S OFFICE THAT -- IN THAT
CASE WHERE THERE IS A FAIR
MARKET VALUE EXCHANGE OF GOODS
OR SERVICES -- THERE SHOULD BE A
THERE SHE YOU SHOULDN'T HAVE TO
FACE.
THE POTENTIAL LIABILITIES THAT
THAT THIS.
BILL WOULD PUT INTO A FACT AND
SO YOU KNOW ONE OF THE THINGS WE
LOVE TO TRY TO WORK WITH THE
WITH THE SPONSOR WOULD BE A TO
HAVE SOME VERY.
CLEAR SAFE HARBOR SAID THAT --
HE IS SO THAT COMPANIES WHO
DON'T WANT TO TAKE A RISK OF
HAVING TO GO TO COURT AND FACE
ENORMOUS LIABILITY.
CAN STILL BRING ABOUT
SETTLEMENTS -- INCLUDING THAT
THE PROVISION THAT THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE JUST TALKED
ABOUT -- WHERE THEY THEY KNOW
VERY CLEARLY WITHOUT HAVING TO
GO TO COURT -- THAT THEY ARE
ACTING CONSISTENTLY WITH THE LAW.
SEARCH THANK YOU OTHER.
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
ALL RIGHT.
SEEING NONE MISTER WOULD YOU
MAKE CLOTHES FIRST WELL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THIS ROBUST
DISCUSSION -- I LOST MY NOTES --
FOR DECADES WE'VE HAD A RICH
TRADITION HERE IN CALIFORNIA --
PROHIBITING ANTI COMPETITIVE
ACTIVITY AND THIS -- WITH THE
CAR RIGHT ACT ON THIS BILL IS
NOT ABOUT LOVE LITIGATING PATENT
INFRINGEMENT THIS IS ABOUT --
SIMPLY CAR FIND A PARTICULAR
BURDEN OF PROOF -- FOR THE
CONSUMER IF IT WERE NOT SO
DIFFICULT TO GET THIS
INFORMATION TO THE CURRENT FTC
PROCESS WE WOULDN'T BE HERE
TODAY.
BUT IT IS REALLY DIFFICULT TO
GET THE INFORMATION -- AND WHEN
WITHOUT I WOULD ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE STONE BY STONE AYE
GALLAGHER.
CHOW.
CHOW I CHIU GONZALEZ.
INSULTS AYE HOLDEN KALRA.
KILEY.
MAIENSCHEIN ARE MAIENSCHEIN AYE
OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE I PETRIE-NORRIS.
PETRIE-NORRIS IRIS.
REYES AYE.
THE BILL THE SOUTH THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SO ARE.
OTHER WE WILL MOVE.
TO ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN AB.
SEVENTEEN THIRTY ONE AND IS THIS
ORDER HOREB COMES UP I'LL TAKE A
MOTION ON THE CONSENT AGENDA
UNLESS SOMEONE WOULD LIKE TO
REMOVE AN ITEM FROM CONSENT.
SO WE DO HAVE A MOTION IS THEIR
SEOND AND A SECOND ON CONSENT.
THANK YOU.
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE STONE BY
STONE AYE GALLAGHER CHOW.
CHOW I CHIU GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I HOLDEN KALRA.
KILEY.
MAIENSCHEIN.
MENTION I OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE I
PETRIE-NORRIS [inaudible]
REYES [inaudible]
REYES AYE.
THAT NEEDS ONE MORE SO THE
CONSENT AGENDA IS ON CALL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THIS BOERNER HORVATH.
YES WELCOME THANK ITEM NUMBER
FOURTEEN AB. SEVENTEEN THIRTY
ONE SEVENTEEN THIRTY ONE GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
TODAY IMPRISONING AB SEVENTEEN
THIRTY ONE TO SUPPORTER STATES
COASTAL CITIES -- THAT ARE
WRESTLING WITH BEST PRACTICES
FOR ONLY A SHORT TERM VACATION
RENTAL COMPANIES -- FIRST I'D
LIKE TO THINK THE CHAIR AND IS
WONDERFUL STUFF REALLY THE WORK
THAT THEY'VE DONE ON THIS BILL.
AND I'M HAPPY TO PRESENT THIS
BILL WITH A MOMENT AMENDMENTS
WE'VE AGREED UPON -- AND I LIKE
TO BE CLEAR WHAT THESE
AMENDMENTS ARE AS AMENDED AB
SEVENTEEN THIRTY ONE IS A
DISTRICT BILL.
IT ALLOWS A HOW HOSTING PLATFORM
TO LIST A RESIDENTIAL PROPERTY
WITH AND SAN DIEGO COUNTIES
COASTAL ZONE.
AS A SHORT TERM RENTAL YEAR
ROUND SO LONG AS THE PRIMARY
RESIDENT LIVES ON SITE THE
MAJORITY OF THE YEAR.
IT AUTHORIZES EACH HOUSING
PLATFORM TO RENT A RESIDENTIAL
PROPERTY FOR THIRTY DAYS PER
YEAR IF THE PRIMARY RESIDENCE IS
NOT ON SITE.
AND IT ALLOWS THE PROPERTY TO BE
MADE AVAILABLE FOR YEAR ROUND AS
A SHORT TERM RENTAL IF PROVIDING
LOW COST ACCOMMODATION ONE OF
THE BIGGEST PROBLEMS WE HAVE IN
THE COASTAL ZONE IN SAN DIEGO
COUNTY.
IS REALLY EVERY CITY CAN
REGULATE SHORT TERM VACATION
RENTALS WITHIN THEIR OWN PER
VIEW UNLESS YOU'RE IN THE
COASTAL ZONE.
AND WHAT'S HAPPENING IN THE
COASTAL ZONE IS REALLY FULL TIME
SHORT TERM VACATION RENTALS ARE
REMOVING HOUSING FROM OUR
HOUSING STOCK.
AND THIS IS CAUSING AN INCREASE
IN LONG TERM RENTAL PRICES AND
REMOVING LONG TERM RENTALS FROM
OUR MARKET.
THAT'S INCREASING GENTRIFICATION
AND NEIGHBORHOODS THAT HAVE
TYPICALLY HAD YOU KNOW DOCTORS
LIVING NEXT TO A TEACHER LIVING
NEXT -- TO A SMALL BUSINESS
OWNER AND THIS IS AN ACUTE
PROBLEM AN AREA WHERE IT IS
DIFFICULT TO BUILD HOUSING AND
THERE'S A NUMBER OF OTHER BILLS
ADDRESSING -- HOW DO YOU DRESS
THE HOUSING CRISIS?
SO WHEN WE LOOK AT THIS WE ARE
NOT TRYING TO BAN ANY SHORT TERM
VACATION RENTAL WE'RE SAYING HOW
DO YOU PROPERLY AND
APPROPRIATELY REGULATE.
THE ONES THAT ARE REMOVING
HOUSING FROM THE HOUSING STOCK
SO YOU STILL PROVIDE ACCESS TO
THE COAST YOU'RE STILL PROVIDING
LOW COST ACCOMMODATION BUT
YOU'RE PREVENTING THIS REMOVAL
THE HOUSING STOCK THAT'S
MASSIVELY HURTING OUR
COMMUNITIES.
AND SO -- THE MEMONS ALSO
CLARIFY THIS BILL MILLER
CIRCUMVENT NOR PRECLUDED CITIES
EXISTING OR PERSPECTIVE SHORT
TERM VACATION RENTAL ORDINANCE
AND I THINK THAT WAS A KEY
AMENDMENT WE GOT FROM THE CHAIR
AND STUFF THAT I REALLY
APPRECIATE.
THAT THE ALL THE REGULATIONS
THAT HAVE BEEN ALREADY
NEGOTIATED WITH THE COASTAL
COMMISSION THAT ARE MORE
RESTRICTIVE THAN OUR ORNETTE OUR
OUR SUGGESTION.
THEY STAY IN PLACE.
AND ABOVE ALL THIS IS REGULATING
THE POP FORMS SO WE'RE NOT
TOUCHING AND A BIT ANYBODY'S
INDIVIDUAL PROPERTY RIGHTS TO
HAVE AN INDEPENDENT WEBSITE TO
LIST THEIR SHORT TERM VACATION
RENTAL.
RIGHT WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO GET
IS THE CRUX OF THIS PROBLEM
WHERE THROUGH AN INDIVIDUAL
ACTION OF RENTING OUT A SHORT
TERM VACATION RENTAL FULL TIME
THAT HAS AN INDIVIDUAL BENEFIT.
BUT IT DESTROYS THE COMMUNITY IN
ITS ENTIRETY AND THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE REALLY TRYING TO GET OUT
WITH -- THIS BILL AND IN THE
MIDST OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
WHEN HOUSING CRISIS THE HOUSING
SHORTAGES PARTICULAR CUTE IN THE
COASTAL ZONE CITIES FACE
COMPOUNDING VARIOUS TO
REGULATING SHORT TERM VACATION
RENTALS.
WHEN SINGING TO MINIMIZE OR
REGULATE THE NUMBER OF THESE
RENTALS IN RESIDENTIAL
NEIGHBORHOODS?
THERE IS A SPIKE IN SHORT TERM
VACATION RENTALS -- UNITS
REDUCES THE AVAILABILITY
AVAILABILITY OF ALREADY SCARCE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN MANY
COASTAL COMMUNITIES.
AND ANY UNIT RESERVE RESERVE
REMOVED FROM HIS OWN HOUSING
STOCK IS DIFFICULT IF NOT
IMPOSSIBLE. TO REPLACE AND I
THINK YOU KNOW IF YOU LOOK AT
THE COASTAL ZONE FOR EXAMPLE
ANTHONY IS THE CITY I'M FROM
ABOUT THREE FORCE MAYBE EVEN
MORE THAN THAT IS IN THE COASTAL
ZONE.
AND OTHER CITIES LIKE OCEANSIDE%
IS JUST WEST OF THE ONE A ONE
THEIR SMALLER AREAS -- AND
CITIES IN CALIFORNIA NATION ONE
HAVE BEEN STRUGGLING TO STRIKE A
BALANCE TO REGULATE ON MY
VACATION RENTALS. FOR ALMOST A
DECADE SHORT TERM PLATFORMS INTO
AND THEIR OWN TELLING HAVE BEEN
A RESOURCE FOR MIDDLE CLASS AN
EXTRA SOURCE OF INCOME FOR
FAMILIES IN NEED. FOR AN
ECONOMIC VIEW A BOOST HOWEVER
THE SHIFT IN THE INDUSTRY THOSE
PROVIDING DETRIMENTAL SMALL
RESIDENTIAL COMMITTEES WERE FOR
DOUBLE RIGHT.
HOUSING IS ALREADY CHALLENGING
TO FIND.
SHORT TERM VACATION RENTALS --
BENEFITS PROPERTY OWNERS BUT THE
COLLECTIVELY CREDIT TRAGEDY OF
THE COMMONS.
THAT MAKING HOUSING AND HIGHLAND
VALLEY AREAS EVEN MORE
AFFORDABLE AND THIS IS SOMETHING
WE CAN'T TO EVERYBODY HOSTAGE DO
THEIR FAIR SHARE IN ADDRESSING
OUR HOUSING CRISIS AND THIS IS
ONE OF ONE OF THE THINGS WE NEED
TO DO.
AND THE DECADES TWO MORE THAN
ELEVEN THOUSAND THE MAJORITY OF
WHICH ARE ENTIRE HOMES THAT ARE
BEING RENTED OUT FOR SHORT TERM
STAYS.
SHORT TERM RENTALS OF CREATED
NEXUS BETWEEN TOURISM HOUSING
THAT IN AREAS THERE ARE
EXPENSING EXPERIENCING THE MOST
PROFOUND AFFORDABLE HOUSING
CHALLENGES.
AND IT HURTS RENTERS.
THE UCLA ANDERSON SCHOOL
BUSINESS CONSIDERS LA'S COST OF
HOUSING IN A SIGNIFICANT DRAG ON
JOB CREATION THE NEARLY TEN
THOUSAND UNITS TAKEN OFF THE
RENTAL MARKET BY SHORT TERM
RENTAL PROPERTY PLATFORMS.
IS EQUIVALENT TO SEVEN YEARS OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING CONSTRUCTION.
THIS IS A REAL PROBLEM WHEN THEY
REMOVE FULL TIME -- IN VENICE ON
AS MANY AS TWELVE POINT 5% OF
ALL HOUSING UNITS HAVE BECOME
SHORT TERM VACATION RENTALS.
WITHOUT PUBLIC APPROVALS THEN
THAT EQUATES TO ABOUT -- THREE
HUNDRED SIXTY SHORT TERM
VACATION RENTALS PER SQUARE MILE --
AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY ONE COMBATS
THE UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES A
SHORT TERM RENTAL PLATFORMS AND
WE GIVE CALIFORNIA'S COASTAL
CITIES COMMONSENSE TOOLS TO HELP
INSURE ONLINE MENTAL PUFFINS ARE
OPERATE WAY.
THEY WERE INTENDED WHILE
PRESERVING ACCESS TO THE COAST
FOR SHORT TERM RENTALS.
OTHER -- FOR PRIMARY RESIDENTS
WHO LIVE ON SITE SO PEOPLE CAN
RENT OUT ROOMS IN THEIR HOUSE IF
THEY LIVE IN THE EIGHTY IN THE
BACK THEY CAN STILL RUN OUT THE
FRONT HOUSE.
YOU'RE STILL PROVIDING THE
ACCESS TO THE COAST AND THIS
LEGISLATION CLEARLY ALSO SAYS --
THAT SAN DIEGO COUNTY WITH A
SUNSET DATE OF TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE THE BILL WOULD ALSO REQUIRE
THE HOUSING PLATFORM FACILITATOR
OF THE SHORT TERM RENTAL TO COOK
THE SAME TRANSIT ORIENTED TAX
THAT.
HOTELS ARE REQUIRED TO COLLECT
TO ENSURE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE
FAIRLY COMPENSATED FOR THE
INCREASE PUBLIC SERVICE COST AND
CONSERVE OUR INCURRED BY LOOK
SERVINGS TOURISTS.
OUR STATE HOUSING GOALS TO
PROVIDE THREE POINT FIVE MILLION
AND AFFORDABLE.
AND ADDITIONAL HOUSING UNITS ON
THE MARKET BY.
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE HOWEVER SHE
HOUSING UNITS THAT WENT ON A
SHORT TERM BASIS LESS THAN
THIRTY DAYS AT A TIME FOR THE
ENTIRE YEAR.
BY DEFINITION REMOVE THAT
HOUSING STOCK AND OFTEN THIS IS
A PERMANENT CONDITION.
WE HAVE A HOUSING CRISIS NOT A
SHORT TERM VACATION RENTAL
CRISIS IN CALIFORNIA.
I ALSO THIS LEGISLATION TO
PROVIDE TOOLS FOR COASTAL CITIES.
JUMP POWER SHORT TERM RENTAL
PLATFORMS TO CONTINUE TO OPERATE
AS THEY INTENDED.
TO AND DID YOU TOUR THE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES.
OF REMOVING HOUSING FROM THE
HOUSING STOCK AS EXPERIENCE OF
COMMUNITY STRUGGLING TO GET BY.
WITH ME TODAY AND SUPPORT WE
HAVE DEAL CARLSON CO FOUNDER OF
SHARE BETTER S. F..
IN CONSULTANT ON HOUSING
POLICIES WITH A NUMBER OF LABOR
AND AFFORDABLE HOUSING
ORGANIZATIONS.
AND JOHN CALDWELL.
BUT THE CALIFORNIA HOTEL LODGING
ASSOCIATION SO TURNED OVER TO
THEM.
THANK YOU FIRST WITH US PLEASE
THIS SHERMAN JOHN CALDWELL ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA HOTEL
LODGING ASSOCIATION.
MY JUST A LITTLE BACKGROUND ON
THIS ISSUE WE'RE DEALING WITH
HERE.
WHEN MOST PEOPLE THINK OF AIRBNB
IN SHORT TERM RENTALS THEY THINK
OF HOME SHARING -- THAT THE
RETIRED COUPLE WHO LETS OUT
THEIR HOUSE MAKE SOME MONEY SO
THEY CAN PAY PAY OFF SOME DEBTS.
HOME SHARING IS NOT A PROBLEM
NOT TO US NOT TO THE AUTHOR.
THE PROBLEM HERE IS WITH THE NEW
YORK ATTORNEY GENERAL CALLED
COMMERCIAL USERS YEARS AGO WE
GOT THE RECORDS FOR AIRBNB NEW
YORK CITY HE FOUND A
DISPROPORTIONATE -- NUMBER OF
UNITS WERE OWNED BY THESE
COMMERCIAL USERS HE FOUND FOR
EXAMPLE TWELVE COMMERCIAL USERS
OWNED EIGHT HUNDRED UNITS AND
ACCOUNTED FOR TWENTY FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS IN RENT ONE YEAR.
THE AG FOUND THE COMMERCIAL USER
REPRESENTED 6% OF AIRBNB HOSTS
BUT ALMOST 40% OF THE REVENUE.
THESE THESE ARE INDIVIDUALS AND
COMPANIES A BY UP APARTMENT
BUILDINGS AND TURN THEM INTO
ILLEGAL HOTELS.
HE'S PERSONAL HOSE USERS PRESENT
A NUMBER OF PROBLEMS ALL OF
WHICH THIS BILL IS AIMED AT
DEALING WITH.
THIS CLEARLY HAVING A NEGATIVE
IMPACT ON HOUSING.
APARTMENTS AND HOMES ARE BEING
TAKEN OFF THE LONG TERM RENTAL
MARKET. EIGHT A UNITE HERE
OFFICIAL TOLD ME THAT HOTEL
EMPLOYEES ALL OVER THE STATE ARE
FINDING THEY HAVE TO MOVE
FURTHER AND FURTHER AWAY FROM
THEIR JOBS BECAUSE FORMALLY
AFFORDABLE HOMES AND APARTMENTS
WHEN A LONGER AVAILABLE.
SO THE BILL LIMITS NOT BANDS FOR
TERMINALS BY COMMERCIAL USERS IN
ONE COUNTY IN THE COASTAL ZONE
FOR A FEW YEARS.
AND IT SHOULD BE ADDED THAT THE
AUTHOR HAS WRITTEN THE BILL SO
IT HAS NO IMPACT ON THOSE WHO
JUST SHARE THEIR OWN HOMES.
THEN THERE'S TAXES. ONE OF THE
FEW REVENUE STREAMS THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS HAVE WITHOUT LIMITS
IS THE T. T. O. T. TRANSIT
OCCUPANCY TAX OUR HOTELS AND BED
AND BREAKFAST PAY THE DOT.
WHICH IN PLACES.
LIKE THE GERMANS -- THAT THE
CHAIRS DISTRICT ARE AS HIGH AS
10% OR ABOVE 10%.
SHORT TERM RENTALS SHOULD PAY
THAT TAX AS WELL.
BUT IN MOST CASES THEY DON'T PAY.
THAT PUTS LEGITIMATE HOTELS IN
BED AND BREAKFAST AT A
SIGNIFICANT COMPETITIVE
DISADVANTAGE ALL THINGS BEING
EQUAL IT COSTS 10% MORE TO STAY
AT A HOTEL OR BED AND BREAKFAST.
BUT IT ALSO DENIES CITIES AND
COUNTIES.
OF A LOT OF NEEDED REVENUE WHICH
IS WHY THIS BILL MANDATES THE
PLATFORMS COLLECT THAT TOT THAT
SOLD.
NOW THE OPPONENTS HAVE A NUMBER
OF ARGUMENTS IN THE ANALYSIS
AGAINST THIS. FOR THE ALICE'S IT
APPEARS THAT SOMEBODY IS ARGUING
THAT IN SOME CASES A SHORT
TERMINALS DON'T HAVE TO BE THE
DOT.
THAT ONE SURPRISE ME GENERALLY
THEY DON'T ARGUE THAT PUBLIC --
OTHERS ARE ARGUING THAT ASKING
FOR THE PLATFORMS TO COLLECT
LEGALLY -- TAXES FROM THEIR HOST
IS A TAX INCREASE.
AN ARGUMENT THAT THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS RIGHTLY DISMISSED.
THE ANALYSIS ALSO POINTS OUT
THAT AIRBNB HAS NUMEROUS
CONTRACTS WITH CITIES ALL OVER
THE STATE IN WHICH THEY COLLECT
YOUR TO FOR THE HOST.
BUT HERE'S HOW THE DEAL WORKS
AIRBNB WILL NEVER TELL THE THE
RENTAL UNITS ARE I DO NEED YOU
TO WRAP UP PLEASE.
AIR TO AIRBNB WILL WILL NEVER
TELL THE CITY OR COUNTY WHERE
THE UNITS ARE LOCATED.
THERE THE AIRBNB WILL SIMPLY
WILL SIMPLY JUST SAY THIS IS%
WHAT WE WE THINK.
THAT THE THE T. O. T. FOR FOR
THAT AREA IS IF YOU DON'T AGREE
THAT YOU DON'T GET TO COLLECT
THE DOT.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS THE MOST
SHORT TERM RENTALS DON'T PAY
THEIR DOT AND THE MERE
SUGGESTION THIS BILL THAT THE
PLATFORM TO MAKE SURE THE MONEY
IS PAID IS MET WITH I THINK.
THE TOP ARGUMENTS.
THANK YOU SIR.
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE MISTER
CHAIRMAN MY NAME IS STILL
CARLSON -- I AM THE A CO FOUNDER
SHARE BETTER SAN FRANCISCO WHICH
IS AN ECLECTIC COALITION.
OF HOTELS AND HOTEL WORKERS
UNIONS.
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION OWNERS
APARTMENT OWNERS AND TENANT
ORGANIZATIONS -- AND
NEIGHBORHOOD ASSOCIATIONS FROM
BOTH THE EAST AND THE WEST SIDE.
OF TOWN AND THESE ORGANIZATIONS
RARELY FIND AGREEMENT ON MUCH OF
ANYTHING BUT ON ISSUES RELATED
TO AIRBNB [inaudible]
THEY DO.
THEY SING FROM THE SAME HYMNAL.
THE ISSUES ARE THE SAME FOR ALL
THESE ORGANIZATIONS AIRBNB IS
DRAMATICALLY REDUCING.
HOUSING OPPORTUNITIES IN THE
CITY.
AND REDUCING THE AFFORDABILITY
OF HOUSING IN THE CITY.
IF I CAME BEFORE YOUR COMMITTEE
MISTER CHAIRMAN.
WITH A PROPOSAL TO DEMOLISH
ELEVEN THOUSAND UNITS IN THE
CITY OF SAN DIEGO ALONE.
AND NOT REPLACE THE YOU WOULD
THINK I WAS A LITTLE NUTS.
BUT THAT'S EFFECTIVELY WHAT'S
HAPPENED IN SAN DIEGO. ELEVEN
THOUSAND YEARS ALMOST ALL OF
THEM IN THE COASTAL ZONE IN
ALMOST ALL OF THEM RENTED FULL
TIME.
ON AIRBNB IN THE OTHER SHORT
TERM RENTAL PLATFORMS.
AT A TIME WHEN WE'RE SUFFERING
THE WORST HOUSING.
AFFORDABILITY CRISIS IS.
CERTAINLY IN THE STATE'S HISTORY
I THINK.
THE SECOND SET OF ISSUES I WANT
TALK ABOUT OF THE ECONOMIC
BENEFITS THEY'RE BEING BE CLAIMS
A CHORE TERMINALS BRING TO
CITIES.
IN SAN FRANCISCO OUR CITY'S
CHIEF ECONOMIST LOOKED AT THE
ISSUE.
AND DETERMINE THAT FOR EVERY
UNIT CONVERTED TO A FULL TIME
SHORT TERM RENTAL THE CITY LOST.
LOST. TWO HUNDRED FIFTY TO THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
ECONOMIC ACTIVITY.
NEIGHBORHOOD SERVING MERCHANTS
DON'T SEE THE BENEFIT.
OF TOURISTS IN RESIDENTIAL
NEIGHBORHOODS.
THEY MIGHT.
EAT AT A RESTAURANT THEY MIGHT
PICK UP A COCKTAIL IT UP IN A
NEIGHBORHOOD BAR.
BUT THERE'S NO USE THE DRY
CLEANER THAN I USED TO COPY SHOP.
THEY DON'T USE.
GET A HAIR CUT.
IS THAT IT IT IS HOLDING IT IT
HURTS A NEIGHBORHOODS ECONOMY IT
HURTS NEIGHBORHOOD SERVING
MERCHANTS.
AND THE LACK OF HOUSING MAKES IT
MORE DIFFICULT FOR THOSE
MERCHANTS TO FIND EMPLOYEES.
THE ECONOMIC POLICY INSTITUTE
RECENTLY ISSUED A REPORT ON
SHORT TERM RENTALS AND WHY THEY
SHOULD BE REGULATED.
AND THEY SAID THAT 224% OF THE
MONEY AIRBNB CLAIMS TO BE
GENERATING BY ITS TOURISTS
COMING INTO CITIES.
IS NEW MONEY IS FOUND MONEY.
THE REST OF MONEY THAT WOULD
ALREADY HAVE BEEN SPENT.
BY PEOPLE COMING AND STAYING IN
LEGITIMATE HOTELS.
I LIKE TO TALK ABOUT THE TRANSIT
OCCUPANCY TAX REVENUES THAT THEY
GENERATE FOR CITIES.
BUT IN SAN FRANCISCO I'M IN THE
LAST TIME.
WE HAD ANY NUMBERS FROM AIRBNB
WAS TWENTY FIFTEEN WHEN THEY
SAID THEY HAD GENERATED TWELVE
MILLION DOLLARS.
IN T. O. T. REVENUE.
SAN FRANCISCO HOTELS GENERATE
FOUR HUNDRED MILLION. FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION TWELVE MILLION
DOLLARS IN A BUDGET THAT'S
SEVERAL BILLION IS IS SORT OF A
DROP IN THE BUCKET.
SO THE ECONOMIC BENEFITS ARE
INFLATED.
THE IMPACT ON HOUSING
AVAILABILITY IN ON AN
AFFORDABILITY IS SEVERE IT'S
SIGNIFICANT THIS LEGISLATURE'S
WORKING OVERTIME TO FIND NEW
WAYS.
OF GENERATING AND STIMULATING
HOUSING PRODUCTION IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA FROM THE MEXICAN
BORDER TO THE OREGON LINE.
YOUR CHEEK BE EQUALLY ENERGETIC
ABOUT EFFORTS TO PRESERVE HOUSES.
BECAUSE THE MOST AFFORDABLE
HOUSING WE HAVE.
IS A HOUSING THAT ALREADY EXISTS
WE CANNOT AFFORD. TO REPLACE
THESE UNITS SO I URGE YOU TO
EMBRACE THIS BILL THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT IF YOU
GIVE US YOUR NAME AND YOUR
AFFILIATION PLACE I DEBORAH CARL
TO THE CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
MICHAEL YOUNG WITH CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION ALSO YOUR
SUPPORT.
SHANE GUSMAN ON BEHALF OF UNITE
HERE AND THE TEAMSTERS IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE OPPOSITION.
YES MY NAME IS PETER READ ON A
CROWD COME TO THE TABLE IF YOU
LIKE.
I'M SORRY YOU'RE WELCOME TO COME
TO THE TABLE IF YOU LIKE
[inaudible]
YES.
MY NAME IS EIGHT AND I'M A
PROPERTY OWNER IN THE SAN DIEGO
AREA -- WE HAVE DEALT WITH A
PROPOSITION LAST YEAR THAT WAS
PROPOSED -- TO HAVE A SWEEPING
BAN OF SHORT TERM RENTALS KNOWN
AS S. T. OURS -- I HAVE AN ISSUE
WITH THIS PROPOSITION BECAUSE OF
THE MAIN ARGUMENT IS CITING THE
LACK OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
THE PROPERTY WE OWN IF ANYONE
HEARS FAMILIAR WITH SAN DIEGO IS
LOCATED IN MISSION BEACH SO TWO
MILE STRETCH OF COASTAL
COMMUNITY IN SAN DIEGO WHICH WAS
INITIALLY ESTABLISHED UNDER THE
NAME OF TENT CITY BECAUSE IT
THRIVED UNDER SHORT TERM.
VACATION RENTALS AT THE TIME
WHICH WERE MERELY TENTS WHICH
REPLACED ON THE BEACH THAT IS
INEFFECTIVE.
A SHORT TERM RENTAL IT'S THE
SAME AS A HOTEL -- THE COASTAL
COMMISSION HAD INITIALLY ARGUED
WITH THE INITIAL PROPOSAL THAT
BY HAVING A SWEEPING BAN OF
SHORT TERM RENTALS THAT WOULD
LIMIT PUBLIC ACCESS.
TO THE BEACH COMMUNITY -- MY
PROPERTY THAT I PURCHASED --
WITHOUT GOING INTO SPECIFICS I
DOES NOT QUALIFY AS A COST
EFFECTIVE HOUSING TO SAY THE
LEAST.
I'M WE BOUGHT IT WITH THE
UNDERSTANDING AT THE TIME THAT
IT WAS A SHORT TERM RENTAL WE
STILL USED AS A SHORT TERM
RENTAL WE HAVE BY USING IT AS A
SHORT TERM RENTAL WE HAVE A
ROTATING -- EMPLOYEES OF SIX TO
EIGHT PEOPLE RANGING FROM
PROPERTY MANAGERS WINDOW
CLEANERS -- HOUSE CLEANERS--
THINGS LIKE THAT THAT WE
EMPLOYEE EVERY SINGLE WEEK TO
TURN OVER THE PROPERTY TO
ANOTHER RENTER.
WE HAVE RENTERS THAT ARE ABLE TO
STAY ON THE BEACH TWENTY STEPS
FROM THE SAND THAT OTHERWISE
WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO AFFORD A
PLACE TO STAY ALONG THE BEACH.
THERE ARE ONLY FOUR HOTELS IN
THE MISSION BEACH AREA WHERE
ELSE ARE THE RENTERS OR PEOPLE
THAT WANT TO COME VACATION
SUPPOSED TO STAY.
CALM THE IDEA THAT THEN THERE
CAN BE -- THE I'D THE IDEA THAT
THAT BY.
HAVING THIS BROAD SWEEPING BAN
WOULD SOMEHOW BENEFIT THE
COMMUNITY DOES NOT APPLY TO
CERTAIN COMMUNITIES IN SAN DIEGO
WHICH HAVE BEEN ESTABLISHED AS
LONG TERM SHORT TERM RENTALS --
THERE IS NO ONE THAT WOULD BE
ABLE TO AFFORD TO RENT ON A
MONTHLY BASIS THE PROPERTY THAT
WE YOUNG.
THE ONLY WAY WE CAN EVEN AFFORD
THE MORTGAGE AND THEREFORE
EMPLOY THE SIX OTHER BUSINESSES
IS BECAUSE WE ARE DOING IT AS A
SHORT TERM RENTAL -- I BELIEVE
THAT THE IF THERE IS GOING TO BE
A BAN IN PLACE THERE ARE CERTAIN
AREAS IN SAN DIEGO LIKE IN ANY
OTHER IN ANY OTHER CITY WHERE IT
WOULD BE MORE APPROPRIATE TO
CARVE IT OUT WHERE IT'S A
COMMUNITY BASED WHERE THERE'S A
SCHOOL.
THERE IS NOT EVEN A ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL IN MISSION BEACH RIGHT
NOW THEY HAVE TORN THAT DOWN IN
A BUILDING CONDOS BECAUSE IT IS
JUST KNOWN AS A VACATION.
YOU GO TO VACATION THERE -- I
WOULD REQUEST IF THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT IS GOING TO BE
CONSIDERED THAT THERE SHOULD BE --
TIME TAKEN TO CONSIDER CARVING
OUT CERTAIN NEIGHBORHOODS IF
ANYONE HEARS MY WAS SEEN IT GO
MISSION BEACH IS.
KNOWN AS A BEACH TOWN AS A
VACATION TOWN THERE ARE MORE --
AREAS FURTHER ALONG THE COAST
SUCH AS THE PLAN WHICH EVEN
THOUGH IS ALSO A BEACH TOWN.
IS MORE OF A COMMUNITY BASED
TOWN BECAUSE OF THE VALUE OF THE
HOMES AND ALSO THE QUALITY OF
EDUCATION'S YOU HAVE THERE.
BUT AT A MINIMUM IF MISSION
BEACH OR SOME OF THESE OTHER
AREAS COULD BE CARVED OUT OF
THIS IS AN EXCEPTION I THINK
THAT THAT WOULD BE WORTH. THREE
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THAT'S WITH US PLEASE.
A GOOD MORNING JOHN ROSS ON
BEHALF OF AIRBNB I'M GONNA TALK
BRIEFLY ABOUT ACCESS THE
AFFORDABLE AFFORDABILITY IN
HOUSING ISSUES WERE RAISED.
TIED COLLECTION AND IF THERE'S
TIME AT THE END SOME SIGNIFICANT
WORKABILITY ISSUES WITH THE BILL.
UP FIRST ON ACCESS -- THIS BILL
WE'RE CONCERNED MAKES IT HARDER
FOR PEOPLE NOT FORTUNE UP TO
LIVE AT THE BEACH TO VISIT THE
BEACH.
THE COASTAL ACT REQUIRES THE
COMMISSION TO ASSURE ACCESS THE
COMMISSION IS DETERMINED THAT
THE COST OF OVERNIGHT
ACCOMMODATIONS AS A BARRIER TO
ACCESS AND FOR THAT REASON --
THE COMMISSION HAS REJECTED
LOCAL PROPOSALS TO LIMIT --
SHORT TERM RENTALS IN COASTAL
AREAS -- THAT HAD PERMISSIONS
FAR MORE LIBERAL THAN WHAT IS
PROPOSED BY THIS BILL -- THIS IS
BECAUSE THE GAS.
PARTICULARLY FAMILIES -- SEE
SHORT TERM RENTALS AS THE WAY TO
VISIT THE BEACH THE AVERAGE AT
LEAST ON OUR PLATFORM FOR
COASTAL RENTAL IS NINETY THREE
THIRTY AT NIGHT.
THAT'S THIRTY DOLLARS LOWER THAN
THE AVERAGE -- COSTS FOR
ACCOMMODATIONS RIGHT ALONG THE
BEACH SO YOU KNOW PART OF THIS
EQUATION IN THE COASTAL
COMMISSION HAS DONE GREAT WORK
AROUND THIS IS TO UNDERSTAND.
THE IMPACT OF RESTRICTIONS WELL
INTENTIONED UPON THE ABILITY OF
PEOPLE WHO DON'T LIVE AT THE
BEACH TO VISIT THE PAGE.
SECOND ON AFFORDABILITY -- AND
HOUSING ALTER AND BE RELATIVELY
BRIEF ON THIS -- THE BAY AREA
COUNCIL COMMISSIONED A STUDY --
ON HOME SURE IN SAN FRANCISCO
THE LOOKED AT THE EXPERIENCE AND
SAN FRANCISCO TO KEEP TAKE AWAY
FROM THAT FIRST -- STRICT
RESTRICTIONS ON THE ABILITY OF A
HOMEOWNER OR RENTER TO RENT
THEIR UNIT.
IS GOING TO MAKE IT HARDER FOR
THAT PERSON TO PERSON TO AFFORD
TO LIVE.
I IT TAKES INCOME OUT OF THEIR
POCKET THAT OTHERWISE COULD HELP
THEM PAY RENT AND MEET OTHER
EXPENSES -- THE ABILITY TO RENT
A ROOM OR A HOUSE. FOR A WEEK
AND IS USED BY HOST -- IN
EXPENSIVE AREAS AT ROUGHLY RATE
OF 32% -- STUDIES SHOW HI DOBSON
RENT OR MORTGAGE OR OTHER OTHER
EXPENSES.
IN TERMS OF THE IMPACT ON THE
AVAILABILITY OF HOUSING -- WE
THINK THE CONCERN IS GROSSLY
OVERSTATED. TWO REASONS FIRST
JUST THE SIMPLE ABOUT ECONOMICS --
IF YOU ARE BUYING A PROPERTY TO
INVEST YOUR TRYING TO MAXIMIZE
INVESTMENT RETURN.
THE BEST WAY TO MAXIMIZE YOUR
RETURN TO LEASE IT FOR A YEAR.
THE BAY AREA COUNCIL STUDY
SHOWED THAT FOR A SHORT TERM
RENTAL TO EQUAL WHAT YOU WOULD
GET ANY YEAR FOR EXAMPLE IN
BERNAL HEIGHTS WITHOUT THE
RENDON THREE OR NINETEEN NIGHTS.
AT AVERAGE RATES TO BE RENTED --
IN THE MARINA AND COVER WHAT YOU
GET FROM YOUR LEASE WOULD BE YOU
WOULD HAVE TO BE HONORING
SIXTEEN NIGHTS SO THE FACT IS
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE AVAILING
THEIR UNITS FOR SHORT TERM
RENTALS ARE DOING IT FOR OTHER
REASONS.
THAN TO MAXIMIZE RIGHT THEY'RE
NOT TAKING THESE UNITS UP THE
MARKET THEIR USE IN EITHER MEET
EXPENSES OR THEY'RE USING IT SO
THAT THEY CAN SUSTAIN A SECOND
PROPERTY.
AND AFFORD IT AND PAY THE
MORTGAGE -- ONTO THE TRANSFER
YOU ARE ABOUT OUT OF TIME.
CAN I HIT ON ON THE POINTS OF
THE OUT THAT THAT PROPONENTS
MADE ABOUT THE TRANSIT OCCUPANCY
TAX PLEASE -- I'M SORRY SECONDS
HERE.
ALRIGHT I WILL GIVE YOU THIRTY
SECONDS SURE WE CAME TO THIS
LEGISLATURE FOUR YEARS AGO AND
WE ENCOURAGE THE STATE WIDE
SOLUTION THAT THESE FOLKS A PLUS.
OPPOSED WHERE WE WOULD COLLECT
THE TEN TRANSIT OCCUPANCY TAX ON
ALL TRANSACTIONS THAT DIDN'T
WORK FOR THEM.
MORE IMPORTANTLY IT DIDN'T WORK
FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENT SO WE CAN
GO AND JURISDICTION TO
JURISDICTION CURRENTLY HAVE
DEALS WITH FORTY CITIES EIGHTEEN
COUNTIES WERE COLLECTING TRANSIT
OCCUPANCY TAX.
ON THE VAST MAJORITY OF UNITS ON
OUR PLATFORM CURRENTLY IN
CALIFORNIA THE IRONY OF THIS
BILL IS A FOR A NUMBER OF CITIES
LIKE SAN DIEGO LIKE CARLSBAD
WHERE WE CURRENTLY HAVE
AGREEMENTS.
THIS WILL REDUCE THEIR TRANSIT
OCCUPANCY -- REVENUES BECAUSE
YOU CAN REDUCE THE NUMBER NICE
THAT'S AVAILABLE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION IF YOU
COULD JUST GO FOR GIVE US YOUR
NAME AND YOUR AFFILIATION PLEASE.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS COURTING
JENSEN WITH TECH THAT OPPOSITION.
JOINT COMMITTEE CALIFORNIA'S
MANIC CHAMBERS OF COMMERCE --
THOUGH IF THAT'S OF AMENDMENTS
TO THE BILL -- WE FEEL THAT AB
SEVENTY THIRTY ONE STILL
SEVERELY LIMITS I OFFERED WE'RE
NOT TAKING FURTHER TESTIMONY AT
THIS LEVEL ACCESS I THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
A GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
CREAM GREASY ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL IS PROPOSED TO BE AMENDED
THANK YOU.
WHERE MISTER CHAIRMAN OF THE
COMMITTEE RICHARD LAZAR EXPEDIA
GROUP IN OPPOSITION?
GOOD MORNING BUT SHEPHERD
REPRESENTING THE CAL ASIAN
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE RESPECT
RESPECTFULLY IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING CHRISTIAN NUMBERS
REPRESENTING BAY AREA COUNCIL
RESPECTFULLY IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION.
ALRIGHT SING NONE RING BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS MS GONZALEZ.
HAVE A QUESTION I THINK YOU SAID.
THE AVERAGE.
COST OF A HOUSE IN THE COASTAL
ZONE WAS NINETY THREE DOLLARS
AND SEVENTY CENTS THE AVERAGE
PER PERSON RENTAL IN THE COASTAL
ZONE ON OUR PLATFORM IS NINETY
FIVE COMPARED TO AN AVERAGE OF A
HUNDRED PER PERSON.
RIGHT LOT OF TIMES PEOPLE WILL
RENT.
SO I KNOW A FAMILY CAN GET A
HOUSE WITH TWO OR THREE BEDROOMS
WERE IS IN A HOTEL IT UP TO GET
MULTIPLE ROOMS TYPICAL.
MOM [inaudible]
DIFFICULT.
MAY I GOT A PRETTY BIG FAMILY
AND ME TOO WE STAY IN ONE ROOM
SELF JUST AND BE REALLY CLEAR.
WHAT YOU'RE LOOKING FOR
AFFORDABLE?
I I THINK MAYBE WE HAVE
DIFFERENT DEFINITIONS I I WAS
THANK YOU FOR CLARIFYING THAT
BECAUSE I WAS DOING THE MATH AND
THINKING.
THAT'S ALL IT IS ALL GO RENT AT
THE BEACH -- WHICH WOULD BE VERY
AFFORDABLE FOR WAS NINETY FIVE
DOLLARS A DAY.
AS COMPARED TO SOME OTHER
COMMUNITIES IN SAN DIEGO -- I
HEARD YOU TALKING ABOUT LIKE THE
MARINE ARYANS OF OBVIOUSLY THIS
IS JUST SAN DIEGO NOW.
I I WANT TO MOVE THIS BILL I I'M
VERY I'M GRATEFUL FOR THE AUTHOR
FOR BRING IT FORWARD I I THINK
IT'S A VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE --
VERY FAMILIAR WITH MISSION BEACH.
LIVED IN PACIFIC BEACH I LIVE IN
CROWN POINT -- I I UNDERSTAND
YOU KNOW BEFORE AIRBNB THOSE
WERE RENTALS DONE IN A DIFFERENT
FORM AND THEY STILL COULD BE
DONE IN A DIFFERENT FORM FROM
WHAT I UNDERSTAND THIS LIMITS.
THEIR B. AND B. PORTION OF IT --
NOT YOUR ABILITY TO RENT OUT I
WOULD SUGGEST -- I KIND OF MAYBE.
IT'S NOT THIS BILL IS NOT GOING
IN THIS DIRECTION BUT I AM
CONCERNED ABOUT EXEMPTING --
ASSESSOR YOU DWELLING UNITS
ESPECIALLY ONES THAT ARE BUILT
UNDER -- PERHAPS UNDER NEW RULES
IN DIFFERENT CITIES AND AREAS
THAT MAKE IT EASIER TO BUILD
BECAUSE WE THINK IT'S IT'S AT
DEALING WITH THE HOUSING CRISIS
AND IN FACT IF IT'S JUST BEING
BUILT -- TO WITH UNDER THOSE
PROVISIONS IN ORDER TO BE AN
AIRBNB DOESN'T SOUND VERY A
WE'RE NOT MATCHING OUR GOALS UP
SO I DON'T KNOW IF THERE COULD
BE CLEAR FIND LANGUAGE ON NOT --
I UNDERSTAND YOU'RE GONNA
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH FOLKS ON
THIS PIECE OF LEGISLATION BUT I
THINK IT'S PRETTY NARROW AND I I
UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
DO AND I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING IT FORWARD.
THANK YOU SO WE DO HAVE A MOTION
IS THERE A SECOND.
AND A SECOND THANK YOU.
OTHER COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
ADDRESS.
I JUST WANT TO CLARIFY THAT.
THIS ONLY REGULATES NUMBER OF
DAYS FOR HOSTING PLATFORMS LIKE
AIRBNB AND THE RPO.
BUT THE HOMEOWNER.
AND STILL ROUTE.
THE IT THEY KEEP DEBATE RENTED
HIS VACATION RENTAL -- PERSON TO
PERSON OR ANY OTHER WAY IT'S
JUST LIMITS THOSE -- THE HELP
POSTING PLATFORMS IS THAT
CORRECT THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER
**** YES -- TWO CLARIFICATIONS --
ONE EVERY SHORT TERM VACATION
RENTALS WITH OR WITHOUT THIS
BONE STILL HAS TO FOLLOW THEIR
LOCAL REGULATIONS.
AND YOU KNOW SOME IN MY CITY
THAT HAS TO DO WITH NOTICING --
NOISE PERMITS AND STUFF LIKE
THAT AND THE SECOND THING IS --
THIS IS ONLY REGULATING THE
PLATFORM SO IF INDIVIDUAL --
SHORT TERM FATE VACATION RENTAL
OUR INDIVIDUAL HOMEOWNER WANTS
TO HAVE THEIR OWN WEBSITE AND
LISTED OR DO IT WITH FRIENDS
THIS ABSOLUTE DOES NOT TOUCH
THEIR PROPERTY RIGHTS.
AND WE CAREFULLY CRAFTED THAT
BILL THIS BILL TO ENSURE THAT
THOSE RIGHTS ARE STILL RETAIN --
THIS IS ONLY THE THANK YOU.
MR.
TO WHEN ASKED AS ACOSTA
COMMISSION WEIGHED IN ON THIS
ACCOUNT.
SO I BELIEVE THE COASTAL
COMMISSION WHEN WE MET WITH THEM
SHE'S GOING TO SURGERY TODAY FOR
ANY SURGERY.
AND THEY HAVE -- GONE THROUGH A
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS WHERE THEY
HAVE REVIEWED THE BILLS THEY
HAVE NOT TAKEN POSITIONS ON THE
BILLS BUT IN FACT THE COSTA
COMMISSIONER FROM SAN FRANCISCO
MADE A COMMENT SAYING HE WAS SO
EXCITED ABOUT THE BILL.
AND HE LOOKS FORWARD FOR TO THE
OPPORTUNITY OF BEING ABLE TO
SUPPORT IT -- I BELIEVE THAT
WILL HAPPEN IN MAY AT THEIR NEXT
MEETING.
I HAVE.
TO MENTION AND I'VE HAD A COUPLE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE AUTHOR
FIRST OF ALL VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE.
THE WORK YOU'RE PUTTING TO THIS
THIS IS A REALLY DIFFICULT SET
OF ISSUES -- AS I HAD MENTIONED
TO YOU -- IN SAN FRANCISCO I
SPENT SEVERAL YEARS CRAFTING SAN
FRANCISCO'S REGULATORY STRUCTURE
BEFORE I CAME HERE TO THE
ASSEMBLY AND IT WAS REALLY THE
FIRST TIME IN OUR STATE.
THAT WE HAD GRAPPLED WITH THESE
ISSUES AND A FEW THINGS I WOULD
SAY ABOUT THAT ARE ONE FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE EVERY JURISDICTION
HAS VERY VERY LOCAL CONDITIONS
THAT.
DETERMINE WHAT OUGHT TO HAPPEN
HERE -- BUT FOR FOR ME AS A
CHAIR THE HOUSING COMMITTEE I
THINK THE AFFORDABILITY
ARGUMENTS ARE CUTS BOTH WAYS ON
THE ONE HAND I CERTAINLY SUPPORT
THE IDEA THAT.
YOU SHOULDN'T BE ALLOWED TO RENT
A SPACE FULL TIME AROUND THE
YEAR THAT DOES ABSOLUTELY
DEPRIVE HOUSING TO A LOCAL
COMMUNITY.
BUT ON THE OTHER HAND -- AS WAS
MENTIONED THERE ARE SO MANY
PEOPLE WHO ARE STRUGGLING TO PAY
THE RENT AND PAY THE MORTGAGE
AND I THINK GIVING SOME
FLEXIBILITY. TO THOSE
INDIVIDUALS ALLOW THEM TO LIVE
IN HIGH COST AREAS AND THAT
CERTAINLY WAS THE CASE IN SAN
FRANCISCO ON WHICH IS WHY WE
CAME UP WITH THE NINETY DAY MARK.
AS OPPOSED TO I KNOW THE THIRTY
DAY MARK THAT IS BEING DISCUSSED
HERE -- I ALSO JUST WANT TO SEND
THE ISSUES OF TAXES I'M STILL A
LITTLE PUZZLED AS TO WHAT THE
TAX COLLECTION ISSUES HAVE BEEN
GIVEN HOW MANY CITIES ARE
COLLECTING TAXES.
WITH REAL ACCOUNTABILITY I'M NOT
REALLY I'D LOVE TO KNOW MORE
ABOUT WHY SAN DIEGO HAS HAD
CHALLENGES -- IN THAT REGARD --
AND I ALSO WANT TO SAY BECAUSE
IT WAS SUGGESTED THAT SOMEHOW OF
A IN OUR CITY FULL TIME RENTALS --
ARE CONTINUING TO CREATE AN
ISSUE AND AND WE HAVE BAND FULL
TIME RENTALS AROUND THE CLOCK IN
SAN FRANCISCO AND WHEN WE DID
THAT.
WE SAW THE NUMBER OF LISTINGS GO
DOWN BY HALF.
AND I THOUGHT THAT WAS
APPROPRIATE -- BUT I JUST WANNA
MENTIONED -- THAT I AGREE WITH
THAT ASPECT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
TODAY -- AS I CHAIR WITH YOU I
THINK IF THIS WERE A STATEWIDE
BILL I WOULD GIVEN THE
REGULATORY STRUCTURE THAT WE HAD
WORKED SO HARD AND OUR CITY TO
DO.
I PROBABLY WOULD BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT THIS BUT AT THIS MOMENT
I'M GOING TO NOT I'M GONNA LAY
OFF THE BILL AT TODAY TO SEE HOW
THE PROGRESS GOES.
IN UPCOMING HEARINGS AND HOPE
THAT THERE'S A LITTLE BIT MORE --
ABILITY TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE
NUANCES OF THIS THIS IS A VERY.
DIFFICULT AND THORNY AREA OF
REGULATORY POLICY I APPLAUD YOU
FOR DIVING INTO IT -- AND LOOK
FOR TO TO SEE HOW THIS PROCEEDS
OVER TIME.
SURE AND JUST FOR CLARIFICATION
THIS BILL WAS A EACH PLATFORM
CAN ONLY LET.
WHEN THE PRIMARY RESIDENT IS NOT
ON SITE?
THE PLATFORM CAN ONLY LIST THAT
VACATION RENTAL FOR THIRTY DAYS
THERE ARE THREE PLATFORMS THAT
EQUALS NINETY DAYS SO THAT IS.
FOR THE REASON THAT THERE IS THE
SMALL THAT USED TO HAVE A NINETY
DAY REGULATION AND HOW DOES
SECOND FORCE ACROSS THE THREE
PLATFORMS EACH PLATFORM CAN ONLY
LIST THAT FOR NINE HAVE FOR
THIRTY DAYS THAT WHOSE WHOSE
ASCERTAINING THAT HOW YOU.
SO EACH PLATFORM CAN ONLY LIST
THE SHORT TERM VACATION RENTALS
FOR THIRTY DAYS SO THERE'S NO
THERE'S NO Q. MOTIVE THERE'S NO
WAY WITHIN THE INDUSTRY TO HAVE
A CUMULATIVE ASSESSMENT THEY
HAVE TO SHARE DATA.
BETWEEN THEM AND THERE'S NO WAY
TO DO THAT SO SORRY I'M I
MISSPOKE THEY CAN ALL EACH
PLATFORM IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
THEIR THIRTY DAYS THAT THEY CAN
LIST.
AND ARE THEY REQUIRED TO LET THE
CITY KNOW WHEN SECOND I'M JUST
CURIOUS AT WE WE WE DOVE INTO
THESE ISSUES A SAN FRANCISCO HOW
A PLATFORM ASCERTAIN STATES AND
AND I'M JUST WONDERING WHAT THE
MECHANISM THE ENFORCEMENT
MECHANISM IS SO SO CURRENTLY --
AIR AS THE SHORT TERM VACATION
RENTAL PLATFORM CAN LAST ANY
SHORT TERM VACATION RENTAL
WHETHER OR NOT THE CITY ALLOWS
IT WHETHER OR NOT THERE'S A
BANNER NOT IN THE CITY WHETHER
OR NOT IT VIOLATES THE CITY'S
PERMITTING WHETHER OR NOT THAT
PERSON HAS A CITY PERMIT.
SO THERE'S NO WAY TO REGULATE
THAT -- SO THAT'S WHY WE'VE GONE
WITH THIS VERY NEARLY CRAFTED
SAYING WHAT IS THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF THE PLATFORM
THE PLATFORM SAYS IF THE
RESIDENTSNOT ON SITE.
THEN THE UNIT CAN BE RENTED OUT
FOR THIRTY DAYS PERIOD SO IF
KEPT VERY NARROW SO WHAT THE
PLATFORM CAN AND CAN'T DO.
AS FOR YOUR THING ON TO UT I
KNOW OUR EXPERIENCE IN IN CITY
THIS WAS -- WE REQUESTED THAT WE
STRUCK A DEAL WITH AIRBNB TO
COLLECT TOT IN RETURN THAT TO
THE CITY WE WERE TOLD WE WOULD
NOT BE TOLL WE WOULD NOT BE
GIVEN INFORMATION ON WHICH UNITS
FOR HOW LONG WERE BEING RENTED
OUT.
WE WOULD JUST GET THE TOT.
SO WE WOULD HAVE TO TRUST AIRBNB
TO GIVE US THOSE UNITS WE WOULD
HAVE NO WAY TO CROSS REFERENCE.
DOES IS THAT UNIT RENTING OUT
ACTUALLY CONFORM WITH OUR
SHORTER VACATION RENTAL
PERMITTING PROCESS WHICH WAS
VERY LOW IT'S TWENTY FIVE
DOLLARS TO GET A PERMIT YOU TO
FOLLOW CERTAIN REGULATIONS --
AND SO THAT'S A LITTLE BIT OF
THE CHALLENGE OF THE TOT I THINK
ONE THING I WOULD SAY WE A
FIGURE THIS OUT IN MANY CITIES
INCLUDING OURS.
I KNOW THAT -- MISTER ROSS
DIDN'T HAVE AN OPPORTUNITYTO
TALK ABOUT THE DOT ISSUE BUT IF
YOU COULD JUST ADDRESSES FOR A
MOMENT BECAUSE SEEMS LIKE.
IF THERE'S A MEETING THE MIND ON
THIS ISSUE I WOULD ABSOLUTELY
SUPPORT YOUR JURISDICTION BE
ABLE TO COLLECT THE TAXES ON
JUST A LITTLE PUZZLED AS TO
VOTERS WAS HEARD ABOUT.
THE REALITY THOUGH IS SMALL
CITIES CAN'T NEGOTIATE LIKE
LARGE CITIES.
SO THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS THIS
BILL DOES IS A EMPOWERS SMALL
CITIES TO NOT HAVE TO GO THROUGH
THE NEGOTIATIONS.
IN THE SAME WAY THAT BIG CITIES
CAN DO IT WE ARE AT AN ISN'T AS
WE HAVE A STAFF OF TWO HUNDRED
PEOPLE WE HIRED.
A PART TIME STAFF FOR NINE
MONTHS JUST TO LOOK AT THE
PLATFORMS AND WHAT UNITS WERE
BEING RENTED OUT. TO CROSS
REFERENCE THEM TO SEE DID THEY
PULL OUR PERMITS.
THIS IS FOR SMALL CITIES WE
DON'T HAVE THE CAPACITY TO DO
THIS.
TONIGHT I APPRECIATE THAT I MY
GUESS IS THIS THE COUNTY OF SAN
DIEGO PROBABLY WOULD HAVE THE
ABILITY TO PULL EVERYONE
TOGETHER ON THIS RIGHT AND
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL IS.
I I AND AGAIN I DON'T KNOW BUT
THE POLITICS OF YOUR COUNTY SO I
WANT TO I WANT TO FIGURE OUT HOW
OUR EXPERIENCES.
IN OTHER PARTS THE STATE COULD
HELP YOU GUYS COLLECT THE TAXES
BUT IF I COULD JUST ASK MISTER
ROSS BRIEFLY B. AS IN OF THE
CHAIRS GETTING IMPATIENT IT'S
UNKNOWNS JUST WAITING FOR HIM.
I WAS TALKING ALLOW YOU TO STEP
IN UNLESS YOU ASK THE QUESTION
THANKS AND THAT'S THE QUESTION.
SO HI WE'VE GOT AGREEMENTS WITH
CITIES LARGE AND SMALL THE
CHALLENGES YOU LEARNED IN SAN
FRANCISCO IS THAT THE ORDINANCES
THE TOT ORDINANCES ARE CREATURES
OF LOCAL LAW THEY'RE NOT STATE
LAW.
I AND FOR THAT AND THE PAY WAR
UNDER THOSE AGREEMENTS AS ALWAYS
THE POST NOT US SO WE ENTER
BALLER VOLUNTARY COLLECTION
AGREEMENTS.
WE HAVE ENTERED AGREEMENTS WITH
CITIES ACROSS THE STATE WHO HAVE
FOUND ALL THE INFORMATION THEY
NEEDED TO AUDIT AND ENSURE THAT
THE THAT THE CHARGES -- WERE
BEING REMITTED APPROPRIATELY --
AND I JUST NOTE THAT IN THE
PROCESS OF TRYING TO DO A
STATEWIDE BILL WHAT WE DID COME
TO IN NEGOTIATIONS WITH THE
LEAGUE OF CITIES AND OTHERS WITH
A SENSE OF WHAT A SORT OF
STANDARD AGREEMENT WOULD LOOK
LIKE AND THAT'S WHAT'S BEING
REPLICATED.
IN SMALL JURISDICTIONS ACROSS
THE STATE SO THERE ISN'T A LOT
OF THE THERE AREN'T A LOT OF
THESE ISSUES THAT ARE LEFT TO BE
NEGOTIATED THEY'VE BEEN FIGURED
OUT AND LEAST EXPERIENCE IN THE
CITIES.
THE WE'VE ENGAGE WITH THOSE IT'S
BEEN RELATIVELY EASY TO GET TO
AN AGREEMENT QUICKLY THAT ALLOWS
US TO COLLECT THE TAX I'LL JUST
NOTE I MEAN ON THE THIRTY DAY
THING I DON'T UNDERSTAND.
THE STATE INTEREST INSANE YOU
CAN WRITE YOUR UNIT FOR NINETY
DAYS BUT WE'RE GONNA DECIDE THAT
THE MARKET IS THIRTY THIRTY AND
THIRTY SO IF YOU'RE HAPPY WITH
THERE BE IN THE LITTLE BEYOND
WHAT YOU THE QUESTION THE OR I
THINK THAT'S WHAT DAVID AS AN AT
AND WHAT.
I WOULD SAY AGAIN APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATION I'M MORE THAN HAPPY
I'M VERY SYMPATHETIC TO THE
SITUATION OR TRY TO DEAL WITH
AND I'M HAPPY TO ENGAGE WITH
YOUR FURTHER AS THE AS THE
MACHINES.
CAN ABSOLUTELY AND AND ONE ONE
COMMENT ON ONE OF THE WITNESSES
THAT SPOKE OPPOSITION -- SEC.
THIS BILL IS INTENDED TO ONLY
LOOK AT RESIDENTIALLY ZONED
PROPERTIES SO IF THERE IS A
RESIDENTIAL TOURISM CATEGORY IN
A CITY.
THIS BILL IS NOT INTENDED TO
LOOK AT THE RESIDENTIAL TOURISM
ZONE SO IF MISSION BEACH IS
ZONED AS RESIDENTIAL TOURISM
LIKE THEIR PLACES IN OCEANSIDE.
ZONED AS RESIDENTIAL TOURISM OF
THIS BILL WILL NOT APPLY SO I
WOULD ENCOURAGE.
YOU TO TALK TO YOUR CITY COUNCIL
AND IF THE INTENTION IS THAT
ZONE IS RESIDENTIAL TOURISM.
THEN THAT COULD BE AS OWN A CITY
COULD CHOOSE TO DO AND THEN
THERE WOULD NOT BE COVERED BY
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU CHEN OURS.
HI I'M THIRTY WITH THAT YOU AND
I HAVE ALSO HAD SOME
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THIS
PARTICULARLY WITH REGARD TO
ENSURING THAT THE BILL DOES
PRESERVE.
LOCAL ORDINANCES AND SOME LOCAL
CONTROLS.
I'M TO TO QUESTIONS ATTEMPTS
FLIPPING THROUGH THIS IS THERE
LIKE A UNIVERSALLY ACCEPTED
DEFINITION FOR WHAT IS A SHORT
TERM RENTAL.
RENTALS LESS THAN THIRTY DAYS
OKAY SO THAT'S THAT IS WHAT
WE'RE APPLYING TO SO SOMETHING'S
BEEN RENTED FOR MORE THAN THIRTY
THEIR LONG TERM OR NOT RELEVANT.
AND I'M CAN YOU SPEAK A LITTLE
BIT TO HOW WILL MAKE SURE THAT
LOCAL ORDINANCES.
ARE NOT PREEMPTED BY THIS.
SO LOCAL ORDINANCES -- IN THE
COASTAL ZONE HAVE BEEN
NEGOTIATED WITH THE COAST
COMMISSION YEAH THIS IS ONLY
APPLYING TO THE COASTAL ZONE
WHICH IS WHY YOU KNOW WE WERE
GETTING COMMENTS ARE OFFICE
SAYING.
EVERY CITY NEEDS THIS WHEN IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAVE
THIS AND WE'RE ONLY LOOKING AT
THE COASTAL ZONE BECAUSE OF
THESE REGULATIONS SO REGULATIONS
THAT ARE MORE STRICT THAN THIS.
SAY SOME CAT IS CITIES HAVE
NEGOTIATED.
ONLY THIRTY DAYS TOTAL.
THAT S MORE STRICT IN WHAT
WE'RE DOING WE'RE DOING NINETY
DAYS BETWEEN THE THREE PLATFORMS.
SO WHEN IT'S LIKE THIRTY DAYS
TOTAL THAT IS THE GUIDING LAW.
AND OFTEN THE LOCAL ORDINANCES
WILL HAVE -- PROVISIONS THAT ARE
NOT TOUCHED BY THIS BILL THERE
WAS A HOW LONG DOES IRAQ IN THE
STATE WITH THE MINIMUM STAY LIFE.
THEY'LL HAVE WHAT NEIGHBORHOODS
THEIR AFFECTED THE HAVE OTHER
THINGS THAT ARE BEYOND THAT THAT
IS MORE RESTRICTIVE AND
THEREFORE NOT TOUCHED BY THIS
BILL.
AND THEN I APOLOGIZE YOU MAY
HAVE GONE TO THIS IN YOUR
TESTIMONY.
WHAT WHAT IS THE POSITION OF THE
CITIES THE SAN DIEGO COUNTY
CITIES THAT ARE IMPACTED BY THIS
SO WE'VE ONLY RECEIVE ONE LETTER
FROM THE CITY OF OCEANSIDE --
FROM SAN DIEGO I HAVE SPOKEN
WITH THE MAYOR OF OCEANSIDE HIS
CONCERN WAS ABOUT THIS
RESIDENTIAL TOURISM AND I LET
HIM KNOW OUR BILL SPECIFICALLY
SAYS RESIDENTIAL SO RESIDENTIAL
TORE I'M A TOURISM.
AS AS OWN WOULD BE OMITTED FROM
THIS BILL.
IN THE HAVE THE OTHER CITIES EL
ENTITY HAS TIME AND TIME
EXPRESSED SUPPORT BUT LORENA
GONZALEZ ARE MATH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GONZALEZ ALSO REPRESENTS
PART OF THE COST OF SOME OF SAN
DIEGO [inaudible]
OKAY.
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTIONS
COMMENTS.
ALRIGHT SING NONE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THIS IS A VERY
COMPLICATED ISSUE BUT IT'S A
VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE -- WE HAVE
TO WE HAVE A STATEWIDE HOUSING
CRISIS AND EVERY CITY ESPECIALLY
IN THE COASTAL ZONE OF SAN DIEGO
NEEDS TO DO THEIR FAIR SHARE OF
ADDRESSING THAT.
AND IN MY MIND IT'S YOU KNOW WE
NEED TO GROW HOUSING BUT WE ALSO
NEED TO STOP THE BLEEDING AND
WHEN WE HAVE SHORT TERM VACATION
RENTALS THAT PERMANENTLY REMOVE
HOUSING FOR MY HOUSING MARKET.
THEY THAT IS THE BLEEDING THAT
WE HAVE TO STOP THIS BILL
APPROPRIATELY REGULATES -- SHORT
TERM VACATION RENTALS WHEN THE A
PROPERTY OWNER IS NOT ON SITE IS
THIRTY DAYS PER PLATFORM THAT'S
A TOTAL OF NINETY DAYS -- AND IT
DOES NOT BAN ANY VACATION RENTAL
IN ANY FORM IF SOMEBODY IS ON
SITE THEY CAN CONTINUE TO DO IT
YEAR ROUND AFTER PROVIDING LOW
COST ACCOMMODATIONS.
THEY CAN CONTINUE TO DO IT YEAR
ROUND SO THIS IS PROVIDING THIS
BILL IS NARROWLY TAILORED TAYLOR
TO ENSURE ACCESS TO THE COAST.
TO ENSURE LOW COST
ACCOMMODATIONS TO THE SHOW COAST
BUT PREVENT HOUSING STOCK FROM
BEING REMOVED I AM.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND THAT MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO NATURAL
RESOURCES CALL THE ROLL PLEASE
STONE HI STONE AYE GALLAGHER
CHOW.
CHOW I TO GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I HOLDEN KALRA KILEY
MAIENSCHEIN OBERNOLTE
[inaudible]
PETRIE-NORRIS.
NORTH AYE REYES.
REMARKS FOR NEEDS THREE MORE SO
WE'LL PUT THAT BILL ON CALL
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MR SANTIAGO.
TAKES US TO ITEM NUMBER TEN AB --
THIRTEEN EIGHTY FIVE MISTER
CHAIR NOTICING THAT IS IN IRAQ
ON BOTH SIDES FOR FOR BREVITY.
THIS IS YOUR TIME.
WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
AB THIRTEEN EIGHTY FIVE WOULD
PROPOSE A MODEST FEE INCREASE
AND TRANSCRIPTS REPAIRED BY
COURT OFFICIALS -- WE HAVE ONE
WITNESS WILL ALSO A COUPLE
WITNESSES WILL ALSO BE BRIEF
THANK YOU MISTER.
THANK YOU FIRST WITNESS PLEASE --
EVERYTHING NOT ONLY ALLOW THREE
WITNESS.
I JUST INTRODUCED SIGNALS
HERNANDEZ AYE WE HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA CORPORATE OR
ASSOCIATION AND ALL THE FOR MY
TIME -- YOU NOT ALLOWED TO TO
FOR YOUR TIME ALLOW THREE
WITNESSES SO TWO MORE WITNESSES
PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING.
MISTER CHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MY NAME IS SANDY WALTON AND I
HAVE BEEN A REPORTER FOR
NINETEEN YEARS.
I REPRESENT C. C. R. EIGHT THE
CALIFORNIA COURT REPORTERS
ASSOCIATION.
C. C. R. A. AS A PROUD SPONSOR
OF AB.
THIRTEEN EIGHTY FIVE CC ARE A
REPRESENTS OFFICIAL COURT
REPORTERS IN CALIFORNIA AS WELL
AS DEPOSITION REPORTERS.
CART CAM PROVIDERS CAPTION OURS
IN STUDENTS.
WE ARE SPONSORING THIS BILL
BECAUSE THE STATUTORY TRANSCRIPT
FREE HAS NOT BEEN INCREASED IN
THIRTY YEARS.
AND ONLY THE LEGISLATURE CAN
UPDATE THE SPEED.
WE HAVE WAITED THIRTY YEARS FOR
REYES AND THIRTY YEARS IS TOO
LONG.
WE NEED THE LEGISLATURE TO HEAR
US AND JOIN US IN MAKING THIS
HAPPEN.
THE TRIAL IS ONLY AS GOOD AS THE
RECORD OF THE TRIAL.
THE AUTHENTICATED RECORD UP THE
TRIAL IMPORTS VERITY.
REPORTERS PROVIDE VERBATIM
TRANSCRIPTS OF JUDICIAL
PROCEEDINGS AND ASSURE NOTHING
COMPROMISES ACCURACY.
WE HAVE A HIGHLY SPECIALIZED
PROFESSION AND ARE LICENSED BY
THE STATE AND HELP ENSURE THE
INTEGRITY OF COURT PROCEEDINGS.
BY STATUTE COR IMPORTERS ARE
SUBJECT TO TOOL COMPENSATION
STRUCTURE.
THE HOURS WORKED AT THE
COURTHOUSE ARE PAID THROUGH
TRADITIONALLY TRADITIONAL SALARY
MODEL.
HOWEVER WHEN AN OFFICIAL
TRANSCRIPT IS PRODUCED THE P. IS
DICTATED BY STATUTE.
THE MODEL REQUIRES US TO SPEND
EVENINGS AND WEEKENDS COMPLETING
THE WORK.
AND THIS BE STATUTE HAS NOT BEEN
UPDATED IN THIRTY YEARS.
IN ADDITION COURT REPORTERS ARE
REQUIRED TO COMPLY WITH STATUE
IMPOSED DEADLINES.
IF A COURT REPORTER DOES NOT
MEET THE STATUTE IMPOSED
DEADLINE THEY MUST FORFEIT ONE
HALF OF THE FEE FOR THEIR WORK.
AS A RESULT OF THE STATUTORILY
IMPOSED FEE STRUCTURE WE ARE
SELF EMPLOYED.
WHEN WE WORK NIGHTS AND WEEKENDS
THIS MEANS WE ARE REQUIRED TO
PAY SELF EMPLOYMENT TAXES PAY
FOR OUR OWN EQUIPMENT?
COMPENSATE ADDITIONAL HELP IS
NEEDED AND AT THESE ADDITIONAL
HOURS ARE NOT FACTORED INTO
RETIREMENT APPLICATION TIME.
AB THIRTEEN EIGHTY FIVE WHAT
INCREMENTALLY INCREASED THIS
TRANSCRIPT BE BEGINNING JANUARY
ONE OF TWENTY TWENTY AGAIN THE
TRANSCRIPT FEE HAS NOT INCREASED
IN THIRTY YEARS.
THE COURT REPORTER WORKFORCE IS
CRITICAL TO ENSURING ACCESS TO
THE JUDICIAL SYSTEM AND THIS
BILL WOULD SUPPORT EFFORTS TO
RECRUIT MORE CALIFORNIANS TO THE
COURT REPORTER WORKFORCE. FOR
THESE REASONS WE ASK FOR SUPPORT
OF AB.
THIRTEEN EIGHTY FIVE THANK YOU
THE SWISS PLEASE HONORABLE CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS ON
CAROLINE DASHER I'M A COURT
REPORTER FOR LA SUPERIOR COURT
I'M ON THE EXECUTIVE BOARD OF
SEIU LOCAL SEVEN TWO ONE AM A
PAST PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
COURT PORTERS SO CA SHIN -- THIS
IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE IT
CONTINUES TO GIVE ACCESS TO
CALIFORNIA LAID AGAINST
ESPECIALLY IN LIGHT OF JAMESON
VERSUS DESTA AND YOU CAN VERSUS
COMANCHE -- CSR LICENSE FEES
WERE REYES -- JUST RECENTLY AND
THEY HELP FUND THE TRANSCRIPT
REIMBURSEMENT FIND AND WE NEED
THE TRANSCRIPT REIMBURSEMENT
FUND TO CONTINUE ACCESS TO JUDGE
JUSTICE FOR LIVE -- INDIGENT
LIMIT LITIGANTS AND WE'VE BEEN
REALLY PATIENT WE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MICHELLE CAST OF THE
SERVICE EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL
UNION ONLY WANNA MAKE ONE POINT
IN THE THIRTY YEARS AT THE
REPORTERS DID NOT RECEIVE A
TRANSCRIPT INCREASE THE COST OF
LIVING HAS GONE UP. 81% SO WE
THINK IT'S REALLY HIGH TIME THAT --
A MODEST INCREASE BE AFFORDED TO
THESE COURT REPORTERS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE SUPPORT.
IF YOU GO FOR GIVE US YOUR NAME
AND YOUR AFFILIATION PLEASE GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS TAMERA Q.
STAND I'M A COURT REPORTER
CERTIFIED WITH THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THIRTY FOUR YEARS AT
THIS POINT IN TIME I HAVE A FIRM
EMERALD DEPOSITION REPORTERS AND
WE PROVIDE SERVICES WITH.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE ABOUT THE
CIVIL AND CRIMINAL ARENA AND I
AM IN FULL SUPPORT AS WELL AS
OUR REPORTERS THAT I AS A SHEET
WITH.
ADDRESSING CREASE THANK YOU.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE SHANE GUSMAN ON BEHALF
OF THE INTERNATIONAL FEDERATION
OF PROFESSIONAL AND TECHNICAL
ENGINEERS AND THE TEAMSTERS IN
SUPPORT.
THIS IS YOUR MEMBERS MICHAEL
YOUNG WITH CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION WERE ALSO HERE
SUPPORT.
Q. ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
CENA IS THEIR OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE OF BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE [inaudible]
QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE MISTER SANTIAGO YOU
MAY CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
MODEL MISTER.
THANK YOU.
POSTED IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE STONE BY STONE AYE
GALLAGHER CHOW.
CHOW I TO TO AYE GONZALEZ.
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE KALRA.
KILEY MAIENSCHEIN OBERNOLTE.
PETRIE-NORRIS.
PETRIE-NORRIS I REYES.
WE'RE PUTTING THAT BELONG CALL
IT HAS FIVE IT'LL NEED TO MORE.
RIGHT SEEING NO OTHER AUTHORS MR
TO ARE YOU READY PERCENT.
SO WE'LL MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN A. B. [inaudible]
ELEVEN THIRTEEN THE REASON.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
COLLEAGUES.
AB ELEVEN THIRTEEN WHAT
ESTABLISH AN IMMIGRANT AND
REFUGEE AFFAIRS AGENCY WITHIN
CALIFORNIA STATE GOVERNMENT.
THEIR NUMBER OF REASONS WHY THIS
IS CRITICAL.
FIRST OUR STATE HAS THE LARGEST
IMMIGRANT AND REFUGEE POPULATION
IN THE COUNTRY WITH OVER TEN
MILLION INDIVIDUALS IN THOSE
COMMUNITIES.
A FEW YEARS AGO GOVERNOR BROWN
ESTABLISHED ONE POSITION AS A
STATEWIDE DIRECTOR FOR IMMIGRANT
INTEGRATION.
AND IT IS OUR COALITION'S
PERSPECTIVE THAT WE NEED MORE
THAN ONE POSITION TO ADEQUATELY
SERVE OVER TEN MILLION
CALIFORNIANS FOLLOWING THE LEAD
OF THREE OTHER STATES
MASSACHUSETTS NEW YORK IN
MICHIGAN WAS SIMILAR AGENCIES.
SECONDLY OUR STATE CURRENTLY
PROVIDES THROUGH STATE
GOVERNMENT A NUMBER OF SERVICES
TO OUR IMMIGRANT POPULATIONS
BURIED THROUGHOUT OUR STATE
BUREAUCRACIES WE NEED ONE AGENCY
THAT CAN HELP OVERSEE ALL THE
SERVICES.
STREAMLINED DELIVERY -- AND ACT
AS A CLEARINGHOUSE TO IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES.
THIRD AT THIS TIME IN HISTORY
THE CREATION OF A NEW AGENCY
WOULD SEND A STRONG SIGNAL TO
OUR IMMIGRANT AND REFUGEE
COMMUNITIES.
THAT THEY ARE NOT ONLY WELCOME
BUT STATE GOVERNMENT IS READY TO
HELP THEM SUCCEED AT A TIME WHEN
THE CURRENT OCCUPANT OF THE
WHITE HOUSE IS TARGETING
IMMIGRANTS WITH XENOPHOBIC
POLICIES.
TEARING FAMILIES APART AT THE
BORDER KEEPING CHILDREN IN
HUMANELY IN CAGES AND SENDING
THE SIGNAL THAT IMMIGRANTS ARE
NOT VALUED WE NEED TO STAND FOR
VALUES.
THIS AGENCY WOULD COORDINATE
SERVICES ACROSS MULTIPLE
DEPARTMENTS ACT AS A
CLEARINGHOUSE DEVELOP GRANT
PROGRAMS ANDOTHERWISE EVALUATE
PROGRAM EFFECTIVENESS AND AT
THIS TIME I'D LIKE TO TURN OVER.
TO OUR WITNESS FROM THE
COALITION FOR HUMANE IMMIGRANT
RIGHTS CHIRLA.
PLEASE THANK YOU AND GOOD
MORNING THIS TIME.
MY NAME IS JOSEPH JENNA DIRECTOR
POLICY AND ADVOCACY WHICH CHIRLA.
I'M HERE AS A PROP.
PROP COULD SPONSOR OF THIS
PARTICULAR BILL. TWENTY F.
TWENTY YEARS AFTER PROPOSITION
ONE EIGHTY SEVEN WAS ENACTED WE
AS THE STATE HAVE COME A LONG
WAY.
CALIFORNIA WHERE FROM LEADING AN
ANTI IMMIGRANT FROM AT AND
IMMIGRANTS STATE IN SENTIMENT TO
BE A PRO IMMIGRANT STATE THAT
INTEGRATES IMMIGRANTS ARE
RECOGNIZED THEIR HUMANITY.
IN TWENTY EIGHT IN TWO THOUSAND
TWO THE LITTLE HOOVER COMMISSION
RELEASED A STUDY WE THE PEOPLE
HELPING NEW COMERS BECOME
CALIFORNIA.
WHICH WAS A VISIONARY -- IS
STUDY THAT I RECOGNIZE THE
HUMANITY THE BODY OF IMMIGRANTS
BUT MOST IMPORTANT RECOGNIZE
THAT.
THE ROLE OF THE STATE QUOTE THE
STATE CANNOT QUIETLY A STEP OR
SUFFER THE CONSEQUENCES OF
FEDERAL POLICY THAT FELL OUR
FAMILIES AND OUR COMMUNITIES AND
OUR BUSINESSES.
MESSAGE THROUGH IN TWO THOUSAND
TWO THIS CONTINUE TO BE TRUE AND
AND NOW IN THIS ERA IN WHICH THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION IS THAT
THAT CAN MAKE A FAMILIES.
DO THAT AND THAT'S WHY THIS
PARTICULAR BILL BECOMES
IMPORTANT ARE STE OUR STATE MUST
BE AT START TO PREPARE A LONG
TERM PLAN TO ENSURE THAT
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES ARE
INTEGRATED.
INTO OUR STATE AND READY TO TO
FILL THE JOB -- FOR THAT I READY
FOR THEM.
OUR STATE MUST BE MORE EFFICIENT
AND RESPONSIVE TO THE NEEDS OF
THIS POPULATION.
CALIFORNIA'S COME TO TEN MILLION
IMMIGRANTS AND 50% OF CALIFORNIA
CHILDREN'S HAVE A ONE PARENT WAS
SENT AND IMMIGRANT -- 80% OF
THOSE CHILDREN ARE US CITIZENS --
AND ALSO TO HAVE A PARENT WHO
MIGHT BE UNDOCUMENTED IT IS TIME
TO IS TO INSTITUTIONALIZE A
RESPONSE FROM OUR STATE.
DID THIS POPULATION ADD THIS
BILL WOULD EFFECTIVELY ADDRESS
THE NEEDS OF THIS POPULATION.
AGAIN BY CREATING THIS AGENCY
INSTITUTIONALIZING IMMIGRANT
AGGRESSION AND PROTECTION BUT
MOST IMPORTANTLY ALSO MAKING
SURE THAT OUR GOVERNMENT IS
EFFICIENT AND COORDINATING
SERVICES AND THEIR NEEDS.
AND FOR THAT WE THINK THIS DONE
NUMBER FOR INTRODUCED IN THIS
BILL AND WE ARE CHEN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
IF YOU COULD COME FORWARD AND
GIVE US YOUR NAME AND YOUR
AFFILIATION.
JESSICA CENTER ON BEHALF OF
EQUAL RIGHTS ADVOCATES IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION.
SINGER BRING BACK TO COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECONDS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHIU A CLOSE
PROJECT INSPIRATION OF THE
COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE STONE BY STONE AYE
GALLAGHER CHAU.
CHAU AYE CHU.
CHU AYE GONZALEZ HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE KALRA KILEY
MAIENSCHEIN OBERNOLTE
PETRIE-NORRIS.
PETRIE-NORRIS IRIS.
THAT NEEDS TO MORE WITH PUT ON
CALL.
THANK YOU MISTER BONTA ITEM
NUMBER THREE AB.
SIX TWENTY EIGHT MORNING MR
CHAIR ONE MORNING.
COLLEAGUES AND STAFF THANKS FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT AB.
SIX TWENTY EIGHT TODAY AB SIX
TWENTY EIGHT WOULD GIVE
SURVIVORS OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT
THE ABILITY TO ACCESS JOB
PROTECTED LEAVE.
ALREADY MADE AVAILABLE FOR
SURVIVORS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
SEXUAL ASSAULT FOR STOCKING.
SB SIX TWENTY EIGHT WOULD ALSO
ALLOW FAMILY MEMBERS TO ACCESS
ACCESS THE SAME PROTECTIONS.
IF AN IMMEDIATE FAMILY MEMBER
HAS EXPERIENCED SEXUAL ASSAULT
SEXUAL HARASSMENT STALKING.
OR DOMESTIC VIOLENCE THAT THEY
CAN HELP THEIR LOVED ONES ACCESS
CRITICAL RELIEF SERVICES THIS IS
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT. FOR
SURVIVORS WERE MINORS IN MAY NOT
HAVE ACCESS TO TRANSPORTATION.
OR WHO NEED SUPPORT GOING TO A
COURT HEARING FOR EXAMPLE. TO BE
CLEAR THIS BILL DOES NOT CREATE
ADDITIONAL PAID TIME OFF.
IT SIMPLY SAYS THAT SEXUAL
HARASSMENT SURVIVORS AND
IMMEDIATE FAMILY MEMBERS CAN
CLAIM PAID TIME OFF ALREADY
OFFERED TO THEM.
BY THEIR EMPLOYER OR TAKE UNPAID
JOB PROTECTED TIME TO SEEK
RELIEF SERVICES.
THERE ARE ALSO EMPLOYER
SAFEGUARDS AND VERIFICATIONS IN
THE BILL IN WHICH A SURVIVOR AND
THEIR IMMEDIATE FAMILY MEMBER
MUST PROVIDE PROOF. FOR THEIR
ABSENCE IF REQUESTED LIKE A
POLICE REPORT A DOCTOR'S NOTE
COUNSELORS NOTE OR COURT
DOCUMENTS SO.
RECENTLY TALK ABOUT VERY SEVERE
LEVELS OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT IF
IT REQUIRES THE SURVIVOR -- TWO
SEEK SUPPORT FROM AN ASSISTANT
FOR THE POLICE OR DOCTOR OR
COUNSELOR OR TO GO TO COURT.
WE'RE ALSO COMMITTED TO
CLARIFYING -- WHAT?
OR BASED ON OPPOSITION POSITION
HAS BEEN AN AMBIGUITY AND IN THE
BILL AROUND THE TWELVE WEEK
LIMITATION ON THE JOB
PROTECTIONS WE THINK THAT.
IT'S REFERENCED ACCORDINGLY IN
THE BILL BUT WE'RE HAPPY TO MAKE
IT CLEAR -- BUT IF WE'RE ABLE TO
GET OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE BEFORE
WE GO TO THE FLORA BEFORE THE
NEXT COMMITTEE.
I WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE ON A. B. SIX
TWENTY EIGHT I HAVE WITH ME
TODAY JANET JERRY REPRESENTING
LEGAL AID AT WORK AND KRISTA
NAME SICK REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIP TO AND
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
THANK YOU AND MISTER BONTA
YOU'RE ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS
I AM THANK YOU.
YOU FIRST WITNESSED PLEASE.
THE MORNING MEMBER IS MY NAME IS
JENNA GERRY AND I'M A SENIOR
STAFF ATTORNEY WITH LEGAL AID AT
WORK WHERE NONPROFIT THAT
ADVOCATES FOR THE RIGHTS OF LOW
INCOME WORKERS ACROSS THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
SOME HERE IS A PROUD SUPPORTER
OF AB SIX TO EIGHT AND AIRED
YOU'RE EITHER.
AB SIXTY EIGHT IS NECESSARY TO
BREAK THE SILENCE A SO OFTEN
SURROUND -- INDIVIDUALS
EXPERIENCING DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
SEXUAL ASSAULT SEX HARASSMENT
STALKING.
BY EMPOWERING THEM TO SEEK HELP
WHEN THEY NEED IT WITH THE
SUPPORT OF THEIR FAMILY WITHOUT
SHAME OR FEAR OF LOSING THEIR
JOBS.
I LEGAL AID AT WORK WE HAVE A
SURVIVOR HELPLINE WERE HERE FROM
THOUSANDS OF WORKERS ACROSS THE
STATE EXPERIENCE SEEN VIOLENCE
AND ALSO TRYING TO MAINTAIN
THEIR EMPLOYMENT.
AND FAR TOO OFTEN WE HEAR WE
HEAR FROM WORKERS EXPERIENCING
THESE ISSUES RECENTLY WE HEARD
FROM WOMAN WHO WORKED AT A CHAIN
RESTAURANT WAS BEING SEXUALLY
HARASSED BY A CO WORKER.
SHE WAS AFRAID BUT SHE REPORTED
IT AND THE COWORKER WAS TOLD TO
STOP BUT THEN SHE WAS STILL
EXPECTED TO WORK WITH THIS CO
WORKER THE FOLLOWING DAY IN A
SMALL SPACE.
SHE WASN'T READY ISSUE BEEN
DEEPLY IMPACTED ENDED TIME OFF
TO SEEK THERAPY.
AB SIX TO EIGHT WOULD GIVE HER
THAT RIGHT TO DO THAT.
AB SIX TODAY WILL GIVE ALL
SURVIVORS AND VICTIMS OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT THIRD RIGHT TO TAKE
THE STEPS.
THAT THEY NEED WITH FAMILY TO
SUPPORT TO RECOVER RETURN AS
PRODUCTIVE WORKERS THERE FOR I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE BOTH.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME'S KRISTEN I'M SICK WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIP TO AND
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE FOR THE
STATEWIDE ORGANIZATION
REPRESENTING OVER TWO HUNDRED
ORGANIZATIONS WORKING DIRECTLY
WITH SURVIVORS EVERY DAY.
AND WHAT WE SO OFTEN HEAR FROM
SURVIVORS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
AND SEXUAL ASSAULT IS THAT THE
PROCESS OF GOING TO COURT -- AND
ROLLING CHILDREN A NEW SCHOOLS
DEALING WITH RELOCATION AND ALL
OF THOSE STOPS THAT -- ARE A KEY
PART OF THEIR ROAD TO USE SAFETY
HEALING AND STABILITY -- CAN BE
VERY CHALLENGING AND EMOTIONAL
TIMES AND THAT WHAT THEY OFTEN
NEED IS A SUPPORTER OF FAMILY
MEMBERS TO BE THERE WITH THEM --
SO BY EXTENT INCLUDING IN THIS
BILL -- JOB PROTECTED TIME OFF
FOR FAMILY MEMBERS OF SURVIVORS
TO BE ABLE -- TO ATTEND A COURT
HEARING AS AN EMOTIONAL SUPPORT
FOR SURVIVOR BE THERE WITH THEM
DURING SOME OF THE HARDEST TIMES
OF THEIR LIVES WE'RE ABLE TO
PROVIDE THE SUPPORTS THAT
SURVIVORS NEED TO BE ABLE TO
COMPLETE THOSE VERY HARD STOPS --
HAVING THAT SUPPORT ALLOWS
SURVIVORS -- TO HAVE BETTER
OUTCOMES TO BE MORE LIKELY TO
ENGAGE IN PROCESS IS WHEN THEY
KNOW THAT THERE'S A TRUSTED AND
SAFE PERSON THERE WITH THEM IN
ADDITION TO THEIR ADVOCATES
ATTORNEYS AND OTHERS.
AND SO WE'RE REALLY GLAD TO SEE
THIS BILL COME FORWARD REALLY
APPRECIATE THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FOR RECOGNIZING THIS NEED AND
URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE AND
SUPPORTS.
HE GIVES GIVE US YOUR NAME AND
YOUR AFFILIATION PLEASE.
VERY GOOD YES YOU ARE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PLAN MILLERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
JESSICA CENTER ABOUT LEGAL
RIGHTS ADVOCATES IN SUPPORT.
JACKIE STERN ON BEHALF OF THE
CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
SHANE GUSMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
TEAMSTERS AND SUPPORT.
KATHLEEN RESTS ON BEHALF OF THE
CENTER FOR DISEASE DASCHLE
EXCELLENCE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
I'D SAY NINE IS THEIR OPPOSITION
.
HI GOOD MORNING LORD CURTIS ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE THANKYOU SO MUCH.
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TESTIFIED TODAY WE
ARE HERE IN OPPOSITION TO A. B.
SIX TWENTY EIGHT WE APPRECIATE
THE TIME OF THE OTHERS OFFICE
HAS GIVEN US -- ON THIS BILL
HOWEVER WE DO HAVE CONCERNS
OBVIOUSLY WE FULLY SUPPORT
EFFORTS -- TO AND HELP ELIMINATE
HARASSMENT IN THE WORKPLACE BUT
WITH THIS BILL OUR CONCERN IS IS
THAT NOW YOU'RE PLACING THE
DEFINITION OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT
IN THE LABOR CODE.
CURRENTLY THE DEPARTMENT OF FAIR
EMPLOYMENT HOUSING OVERSEAS
SEXUAL HARASSMENT THAT OCCURS IN
THE WORKPLACE THERE'S AN
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCESS THAT
OCCURS DURING OR WHEN COMPLAINTS
ARE FILED.
AND THERE'S MINISTRY TO REMEDY
THAT OCCURS AND OUR CONCERN IS
THAT NOW THEY'RE PLACING THIS IN
THE LABOR CODE AND WITH THAT AND
THE DEFINITION THAT WAS TAKEN IS
ONLY SIMPLY THE EXAMPLES OF WHAT
COULD RISE TO SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
SUCH EXAMPLES AS LEERING SHOWING
CARTOONS THINGS LIKE THAT BUT
NOT ALL OF THIS INAPPROPRIATE
BEHAVIOR ACTUALLY RISES TO
UNLAWFUL SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
IT HAS TO MEET THE SEVERE
PERVASIVE STANDARD OR THE QUID
PRO QUO STANDARD THESE ARE
SIMPLY EXAMPLES ADDITIONALLY THE
WAY THE BILL AS CURRENTLY
DRAFTED -- WHICH I KNOW IS
STAKING AND CURRENT LAW IS THAT
IT'S FOR ANY RELIEF IT'S NOT
JUST LIMITED TO RELIEVE THROUGH
THE COURT PROCESS IT SAYS ANY
RELIEF INCLUDING BUT NOT LIMITED.
TO SO I KNOW THIS MAY SOUND LIKE
AN EXTREME EXAMPLE HOWEVER IF I
WERE TO WALK TO WORK AND GET
CáC CALLED AT WORK AS LONG AS I
GIVE MY EMPLOYER ADVANCE NOTICE
THAT I'M TAKING TIME OFF WORK.
THERE IS NO REQUIREMENT TO KNOW
SORT OF VERIFICATION NEEDS TO
OCCUR AS LONG AS IT'S PRIOR
NOTICE.
AND IT COULD BE FOR SOMETHING AS
SIMPLE AS THIS CAT CALL OR BEAT
LEERING OR ANYTHING LIKE THAT.
SO I COULD INFORM MY EMPLOYER
THAT I'M TAKING TIME OFF WORK I
COULD ALSO LET MY BROTHER KNOWN
SEEN DIEGO THAT HE COULD TAKE
TIME OFF WORK HE COULD TAKE TIME
OFF WORK FOR THE SAME REASONS TO
PROVIDE ME.
SUPPORT IN SEEKING ANY TYPE OF
RELIEF UNDER THIS BILL AND
THAT'S OUR OVERALL CONCERN IS
THAT AND WITH THE NUANCES THAT
ARE OF THE THAT REGARD SEXUAL
HARASSMENT.
THAT AND THE DMV H. OVERSEAS
THAT NOW WE'RE GONNA BE -- TO
GIVE HAVING ADMINISTRATIVE
REMEDY THROUGH THE LABOR COME
SKINNER THROUGH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FAIR EMPLOYMENT HOUSING ON
THINGS THAT MIGHT NOT ACTUALLY
RISE TO UNLAWFUL BEHAVIOR.
AND FOR THESE REASONS WE ARE --
OPPOSED BECAUSE THAT ALSO
EXTENDS TO THE FAMILY MEMBERS AS
WELL.
THANK YOU THAT'S WHAT THIS WAS
CHAIR -- CHRISTMAS KAYLEE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
AMBULANCE ASSOCIATION AND SOME
OTHERS I WANTED TO KNOW A COUPLE
ADDITIONAL POINTS -- TO MISS
CURTIS'S COMMENTS -- THE FIRST
IS ON THE DEFINITION OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT -- WE DID SUGGESTS IN
THE LAST COMMITTEE SOMETHING
NARAL WERE ALONG THE LINES OF
WHAT IS CONTAINED IN THE FAIR
EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING ACT AND
WE DO APPRECIATE THE ONGOING
DISCUSSIONS OF THE AUTHOR AND A
STAFFERS HAD WITH US.
ANOTHER PROVISION IS IS THAT THE
BILL SPECIFICALLY REQUIRES
CONFIDENTIALITY ABOUT THE
EMPLOYEE WHO'S TAKING THE LEAVE.
AND YET OF COURSE WITH A
COMPLAINT OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT
THE FAIR EMPLOYMENT HOUSING ACT
REQUIRES THE EMPLOYER. TO
CONDUCT A THOROUGH INVESTIGATION
INTERVIEW WITNESSES AND IT
CETERA SO HOW DO WE RECONCILE.
THE TENSION THERE BETWEEN THE
CONFIDENTIALITY OF THE
INDIVIDUAL TAKING THE LEAVE
VERSUS OUR DUTY TO INVESTIGATE.
ON THE FAMILY MEMBERS OF THE
VICTIM MIGHT NOTED IN THE
OPENING COMMENTS THAT THE AUTHOR
SAID THIS IS ESPECIALLY
IMPORTANT TO VICTIMS -- WE HAD
SUGGESTED AS WITH LAST YEAR'S
VERSION THAT PERHAPS THE VICTIMS
BE LIMITED -- OR THE FAMILY
MEMBERS OF VICTIMS BE LIMITED TO
THE INSTANCES IN WHICH THE
VICTIM IS.
A MINOR I NOTE THAT YOUR
EXCELLENT COMMITTEE ANALYSIS AS
USUAL NOTES ON PAGE SIX ABOUT
THE A BURDEN TO THE EMPLOYER.
ON THE CERTIFICATION THAT'S
REFERENCE AT THE BOTTOM OF PAGE
FIVE WITHOUT ANALYSIS.
THE COMMITTEE RECOMMENDED
AMENDMENTS THAT THE THE FAMILY
MEMBERS BUT YOU SHOULD NOTE IN
THE LANGUAGE THERE'S A
DISTINCTION MADE BETWEEN THE
UNSCHEDULED ABSENCE AND THE
ADVANCE NOTICE WITH THE
UNSCHEDULED APPS.
THAN A REASONABLE TIME AFTER
THAT CERTIFICATION IS PROVIDED
BUT WHEN -- WITH ADVANCE NOTICE
THE NO CERTIFICATION IS REQUIRED
AT LEAST FOR THE SEXUAL
HARASSMENT COMPLAINT WE BELIEVE
THAT CERTIFICATION SHOULD BE IN
EITHER INSTANCE WHETHER WAS ON
SCHEDULED OR AN ADVANCE NOTICE.
THE AUTHOR ALSO MENTIONED IN TWO
THIRTY POINT ONE WHICH IS IN
SECTION TWO OF THE BILL.
IT DEALS WITH THE TWELVE WEEK
LIMITATION UNDER -- FMLA THERE'S
NO REFERENCE IN SECTION ONE OF
THE BILL IN SECTION TWO THIRTY
AMENDMENTS TO THE LABOR CODE.
THE OTHER POINT IS IS THAT WE
ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
POTENTIAL FOR ABUSES ALTHOUGH
THAT THE DATA IS A LITTLE BIT
OLD FROM DHEA FREE AGENT IS THE
MOST RECENT AVAILABLE.
OUT OF ABOUT TWENTY ONE THOUSAND
HARASSMENT COMPLAINTS THEY
DISMISSED OVER FOUR THOUSAND OF
THEM DUE TO LACK OF EVIDENCE SO
THERE IS SOME CONCERN THERE.
AND THEN LASTLY WE ALWAYS HAVE
TO MAKE THE COMMENT THAT BY
ADDING THESE ADDITIONAL
PROVISIONS IN THE LABOR CODE TWO
THINGS ONE IS.
THERE'S A SUBSTANTIALLY LONGER
STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS THREE
YEARS UNDER THE LABOR CODE
VERSUS SIX MONTHS IN AND THREE
ON THE GOVERNMENT CODE.
AND LASTLY ALL OF THIS IS
ENFORCEABLE -- BY REPRESENTATIVE
ACTION UNDER THE PRIVATE
ATTORNEYS GENERAL ACT AND FOR
THOSE REASONS WE REMAIN OPPOSED
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION.
IF YOU JUST GIVE US YOUR NAME
AND YOUR AFFILIATION PLEASE.
HI SEAN LUIS NATIONAL FEDERATION
OF INDEPENDENT BUSINESS
REPRESENTING SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS ALSO POST THANK YOU.
HEY BORDERS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF JOINT
POWERS A THIRTIES RESPECTFULLY
POST.
KATIE HANSON FOR THE CALIFORNIA
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION WE ARE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED.
GOOD MORNING MATTHEW OUT WITH
WESTERN GROWERS ALSO OPPOSED.
BRENDEL CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION.
RIGHT SIGNAL BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE [inaudible]
QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION IS
THERE A SECOND.
AND A SECOND THANK YOU THIS
PETRIE-NORRIS.
pSHEET WHAT YOU ARE ARE TRYING TO
DO TO PROTECT VICTIMS OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT.
I'M I DO AS I MENTIONED TO YOU
HAVE SOME QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
EXTENSION TO FAMILY MEMBERS SO.
AS NOTED AND IN THAT COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS SO EVEN EXISTING LINE
THE PROTECT VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SEXUAL ASSAULT STALKING.
DOES NOT EXTEND TO IMMEDIATE
FAMILY MEMBERS CAN OF WHAT.
WHAT WAS THE GENESIS SERVE DAY
THE REASONING BEHIND INCLUDING
THIS IN A?
VERY NEW PROVISION AND APPROACH.
GENERALLY SPEAKING THE GENESIS
WAS TO PROVIDE A NETWORK OF
SUPPORT FOR SOMEONE WHO IS GOING
THROUGH SOME INFORMATICA NEEDS
THE SUPPORT OF A LOVE -- ONE A
FAMILY MEMBER TO DO SOMETHING
ACTUALLY DIFFICULT GO TO COURT --
GO TO COUNSELING -- GO TO THE
DOCTOR AND PERSONALLY SPEAKING I
THOUGHT ABOUT MY DAUGHTER.
IF SHE EVER -- WAS THE VICTIM --
AND SURVIVED ANY OF THESE --
YOU'RE ABOUT TO VIOLENCE OR
SEXUAL ASSAULT STALKING OR
SEXUAL HARASSMENT IS A DAD KEY
TAKE ME THE HOSPITAL.
I I'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT
PROTECTED FROM -- LOSING MY JOB
AND I THINK OTHER MOTHERS AND
FATHERS AND SISTERS AND BROTHERS --
AND THE OTHER MEMBERS OF
FAMILIES THAT WE'VE DEFINED IN
THE BILL WOULD LIKE TO THE SAME
AND I THINK THAT'S A GOOD THING
FOR SOCIETY WHEN YOU CAN GET
LOVE AND SUPPORT.
WHEN YOU'RE GOING THROUGH
SOMETHING DIFFICULT?
SO THAT WAS THE GENESIS AND AND
THAT'S WHY WE ADDED THAT TO THE
BILL.
OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
ALL RIGHT SING NONE THIS ABOUT
THE MACROS.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY --
WE AS INDICATED ARE HAPPY TO
TAKE THE AMENDMENTS THAT SPRING
FOR THE BILL HELP CLARIFY IT WE
WANT TO MAKE VERY CLEAR THAT WE
HAVE A TWELVE WEEK LIMITATION.
HERE I WANT NO ONE TO BE UNSURE
ABOUT THAT IN TERMS OF THE
AMOUNT OF LEAVE THAT COULD BE
TAKEN SO WE'RE GONNA BE WERE
INTERESTED IF OUT OF THIS
COMMITTEE AND CLARIFY THAT.
IN IN THE MATTER THE NEXT
COMMITTEE WE THINK THAT A LOT OF
THE ARGUMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN
BROUGHT UP BY THE OPPOSITION.
ARE -- ARE ADDRESSED BY EXISTING
LAW OR OTHER PARTS OF THE BILL
FOR EXAMPLE THIS ISSUE OF OF
CONFIDENTIALITY NOT BEEN ABLE.
TO CONDUCT AN INVESTIGATION.
OUR BILL SAYS IT BY ITS OWN
TERMS THAT THE CONFIDENTIALITY
WILL BE.
HONORED TO THE EXTENT ALLOWED BY
LAW SO IF YOU STILL NEED TO DO
INVESTIGATION YOU'RE REQUIRED TO
DO THAT BY LAW.
THE YOU ALLOWED TO DO THAT BY
LAW AND SO WE THINK THAT THE THE
BILL ADDRESSES THAT ISSUE.
AND YOU KNOW AND AND I AND I I
STARTED CONCERNED A LITTLE BIT
WHEN I HEAR.
THE SUGGESTION THAT THERE'S
EMPLOYEES ALL OVER CALIFORNIA
THAT ARE SORT OF CONSTANTLY
SCHEMING TO GAME THE SYSTEM IN
AND TAKE ADVANTAGE OF IT WE
DON'T WE MUCH OF THIS BILL HAS
ALREADY BEEN IN PLACE -- FOR
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND AND SEXUAL
ASSAULT AND AND AND AND WE
HAVEN'T SEEN THAT THERE'S NO
PROOF THAT THERE'S THIS GAMING
OF THE SYSTEM THAT FOLKS ARE
TRYING TO ABUSE IT -- BUT THERE
IS PROOF OF IS THAT THESE ARE
SURVIVORS WHO NEED SUPPORT AND
HELP -- I THINK THIS IS A
REASONABLE COMMONSENSE BILL THAT
PROVIDES THAT AS FOLKS HEAL AND
RECOVER -- AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK DR.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE STONE AYE
STONE AYE GALLAGHER.
CHOW.
CHOW I CHU.
CHU AYE GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE KALRA.
COLOR ARE KILEY.
KILEY NO MAIENSCHEIN
[inaudible]
OBERNOLTE PETRIE-NORRIS PRESS.
THAT NEEDS ONE MORE SO WE'LL PUT
THE BILL ON CALL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU STAFF.
THAT TAKES US TO MISTER
RODRIGUEZ.
WE ARE ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN AB.
SEVENTEEN OH EIGHT GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL SEVENTY NóI.
AB SEVENTEEN OR IT WILL REQUIRE
BUILDINGS CONSTRUCTED AFTER
TWENTY TWENTY TO INSTALL FIRST
AID KITS THAT WOULD INCLUDE
TOURNIQUETS.
A COMPRESSOR DEVICE THAT STOPS
THE FOR BLOOD PREVENT ARTERY OF
A LAMB.
SIMILAR TO HOW AUTOMATIC
EXTERNAL DEFIBRILLATORS WERE
INTRODUCED TO PUBLIC SETTINGS
THESE FIRST AID KITS WILL BE A
SUPPLEMENTAL TOOL FOR PUBLIC
SAFETY.
A PERSON BLEEDING CAN DIE FROM
BLOOD LOSS WITHIN FIVE MINUTES
IT IS IMPERATIVE THAT THOSE
NEAREST TO SOMEONE.
WITH LIFE THREATENING INJURIES
OUR BEST POSITION TO PROVIDE
FIRST FIRST TAKE CARE.
WITH MASS SHOOTINGS OCCURRING
MORE FREQUENTLY PUBLIC SETTING
SUCH AS SCHOOLS CHURCHES AND
LARGE SCALE PUBLIC EVENTS IT IS
VITAL FOR THE PUBLIC SAFETY.
THAT ALL FIRST AID KITS ARE
EQUIPPED WITH TOURNIQUETS.
MOST IMPORTANT WE MUST PROVIDE
THE PUBLIC WITH ACCESS TO EASY
TO USE LIFESAVING EQUIPMENT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND ARE YOU ACCEPTING
THE AMENDMENTS YES THANK YOU
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT [inaudible]
ANY WITNESSES.
BOXING BUT IS THERE ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE.
TO SPEAK IN FAVOR.
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE OF BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND.
MISTER RODRIGUEZ MY CLOTHES ARE
STRUCK LAST RIVAL THANK YOU
THANK YOU MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS CALL
PLEASE STONE BY STONE AYE
GALLAGHER CHOW.
CHOW I CHIU [inaudible]
GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY.
HIGHLY NO MAIENSCHEIN OBERNOLTE
PETRIE-NORRIS REYES.
THAT NEEDS TO MORE SO WE'LL PUT
THE LONG CALL THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
MR GABRIEL ITEM NUMBER TWO AB
.
THREE THIRTY THE MORNING MORNING
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
I AM PLEASED TODAY TO PRESENT AB
THREE THIRTY WHICH WILL EXPAND
FUNDING FOR THE HIGHLY
SUCCESSFUL SARGENT SHRIVER CIVIL
COUNCIL ACT.
PILOT PROGRAMS.
THESE PILOT PROGRAMS PROVIDE
LIGHT VITAL LEGAL REPRESENTATION
TO LOW INCOME CALIFORNIANS IN
LIFE CHANGING CIVIL LEGAL
MATTERS.
IN MANY CASES HAVING AN ATTORNEY
CAN BE THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
HAVING A HOME OR BEING EVICTED
GAINING OR LOSING CUSTODY OF A
CHILD OR SECURING A GUARDIAN OR
CONSERVATORSHIP FOR A LOVED.
ONE IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL RELEASED AN
EVALUATION WHICH FOUND THAT
THESE PROGRAMS NOT ONLY
DRAMATICALLY IMPROVED OUTCOMES
FOR LITIGANTS.
BUT THAT THEY ALSO INCREASE
SETTLEMENT REDUCE COSTS ON THE
COURT SYSTEM AND PROVIDED
NUMEROUS OTHER EFFICIENCIES.
UNFORTUNATELY LACK OF FUNDING
HAS LIMITED THE REACH OF SHRIVER
ACT PROGRAMS AS CIVIL FILINGS
HAVE DECREASED SO HAS THE
FUNDING FOR PILOT PROGRAMS.
INDEED INSTEAD OF EXPANDING
THEIR SERVICES SHRIVER ACT
PROGRAMS OF HAD TO SCALE BACK
THE NUMBER OF CASES THEY CAN
ACCEPT AND FOREGO CREATING NEW
PROGRAMS IN OTHER AREAS OF THE
STATE.
AB THREE THIRTY RESPONSE OF THIS
CRISIS BY MODESTLY INCREASING
CERTAIN FILING FEES THAT FUND
THE PILOT PROGRAMS BY ALLOWING
PRIVATE PHILANTHROPY TO HELP
FUND THEM.
THESE ADDITIONAL RESOURCES WILL
HELP TO SERVE MORE LANE LOW
INCOME LET AGAINST ALLOW
PROGRAMS TO EXPAND TO OTHER
UNDERSERVED POPULATIONS
INCLUDING VETERANS.
EXPANSE OF ASSIST OTHER CRITICAL
AREAS SUCH AS DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
AND ESTABLISH NEW PILOT PROGRAMS
IN PARTS OF THE STATE THAT HAVE
YET TO RECEIVE SERVICES.
THIS IS A CRITICAL STEP FORWARD
IN ENSURING THAT JUSTICE THROUGH
OUR LEGAL SYSTEM IS AVAILABLE TO
ALL NOT JUST THOSE OF MEANS.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE AND WITH ME TODAY TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OUR GERRY
SMITH WITH LEGAL SERVICES OF
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AND SELENA
COPELAND OF THE LEGAL AID
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU AND YOU ARE ACCEPTING
THE AMENDMENTS AS AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS ON PAGE SIX AND SEVEN
OF THE YES SIR THANK YOU YES
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT FIRST WITNESS PLEASE.
GERMAN STONE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ASSEMBLYMEMBER GABRIEL
MY NAME'S GERRY SMITH -- I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR LEGAL
SERVICES OF NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
WE ARE NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION
THAT PROVIDES FREE CIVIL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE TO POOR AND
DISADVANTAGED INDIVIDUALS
FAMILIES AND COMMUNITIES IN
TWENTY THREE COUNTIES IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
SINCE TWENTY ELEVEN WE'VE BEEN
OPERATING ONE OF THE TEN SHRIVER
CIVIL COUNCIL.
PROJECTS IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
YOLO COUNTY SUPERIOR COURT --
OUT OF OUR OFFICE IN WOODLAND
I'M HERE TODAY NOT ONLY ON
BEHALF OF MY ORGANIZATION BUT
ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE OTHER
RECIPIENTS OF SHRIVER FUNDING.
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS VERY
COMPREHENSIVELY DESCRIBES THE
HISTORY OF THE SHRIVER PROGRAM.
I AM PRIVILEGED TO HAVE BEEN ONE
OF A SMALL GROUP OF ADVOCATES
THAT BEGAN THE QUEST FOR THIS
PROJECT WE BACK IN. TWENTY SEVEN
I THINK IT BEARS EMPHASIZING
THAT THIS HAS BEEN AND CONTINUES
TO BE A BI PARTISAN PROJECT.
GOVERNOR SCHWARZENEGGER PUT
FUNDING IN THIS IN THIS -- OF
BUDGET FOR TWO THOUSAND AND
SEVEN EVEN BEFORE THERE WAS
IMPLEMENTING LEGISLATION FOR IT.
AND TWO YEARS LATER UNDER MIKE
FUEHRER'S LEADERSHIP AND LEADER
AND THE GREAT WORK OF THIS
COMMITTEE AND ITS STAFF -- THE
PROJECT MOVED THROUGH THE
LEGISLATURE AS A. B. FIVE NINETY
AND GOVERNOR SCHWARZENEGGER
SIGNED IT.
AND THE PROJECT IS NAMED AFTER
HIS FATHER IN LAW ROBERT SARGENT
SHRIVER AN ICONIC SOCIAL JUSTICE
FIGURE WHO HEADED THE VERY FIRST
FEDERAL.
LEGAL SERVICES PROGRAM WAY BACK
IN.
NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE THIS PROJECT
HAS RECEIVED NATIONAL ATTENTION
AND RECOGNITION FOR ITS POLICY
VISION -- TOWARDS A
COMPREHENSIVE ACCESS TO JUSTICE
REGIME -- MY PROJECT LEGAL
SERVICES NO THE CALIFORNIA
PARTNERS WITH DEAL COUNTY
SUPERIOR COURT AND THE YOLO
COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH -- WE HAVE
ASSISTED SEVERAL THOUSAND LOW
INCOME TENANTS -- SINCE THE
PROJECT BEGAN WE CONTRACT WITH
THE COUNTY TO PROVIDE HOUSING
INSPECTIONS WHICH ARE USED BY
THE CORE AS AN OBJECTIVE
EVALUATION OF PROPERTY IN
EVICTION CASES THAT INVOLVE
ALLEGATIONS OF SUBSTANDARD
CONDITIONS -- OUR CLIENTS
INCLUDE PEOPLE WITH LIMITED
ENGLISH PROFICIENCY SURVIVORS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE OLDER ADULTS
SOME OF WHOM HAVE LIVED IN THE
SAME HOME FOR MORE THAN THIRTY
YEARS AND PEOPLE WITH
SIGNIFICANT DISABILITIES.
THE OVER ARCHING GOALS OF THE
PROJECT -- TO LEVEL THE PLAYING
FIELD BETWEEN LANDLORDS AND
TENANTS PROVIDE EQUAL ACCESS TO
THE COURT SYSTEM.
ALLOW PEOPLE TO HAVE THEIR DAY
IN COURT TRY AND REACH
SETTLEMENTS THROUGH -- MEDIATION
AND OTHER -- DISPUTE RESOLUTION
SERVICES AND TO PREVENT
HOMELESSNESS IN A VERY VERY
LIMITED HOUSING MARKET.
YOLO COUNTY PRESIDING JUDGE AND
THE COURT EXECUTIVE -- HAVE
PROVIDED THIS DESCRIPTION OF THE
PROJECT QUOTE.
THE PROJECT IMPROVES ACCESS TO
JUSTICE FOR EVICTION LITIGANTS
BY REDUCING THE DISPARITY THAT
EXISTS IN REPRESENTATION.
PROVIDING LANGUAGE ACCESS FOR
LIMITED ENGLISH PROFICIENT --
LITIGANTS ENCOURAGES SETTLEMENT
THROUGH MEDIATION AND OFFERS
NEUTRAL EXPERT WITNESS TESTIMONY
IN CASES INVOLVING SUBSTANDARD
HOUSING SO I DO NEED TO WRAP UP
PLEASE.
I I JUST WANNA SAY THAT THE
PROGRAM HAS BEEN SCRUPULOUSLY AT
IT MINISTERED BY THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL RIGOROUSLY EVALUATED --
WITH EMPIRICALLY SUPPORTED
POSITIVE RESULTS AND WE WOULD
URGE SUPPORT OF THIS ENHANCEMENT
TO ITS FUNDING BASE.
THANK YOU THAT'S WHEN THIS PLACE.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN STERN AND
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I
KEEP MY COMMENTS BRIEF -- I'M
STILL IN A COUPLE IN THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF LEGAL AID
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA AND WE
WORK WITH ROUGHLY ONE HUNDRED
LEGAL RIGHTS OF ILLEGALLY
PROGRAMS HERE IN CALIFORNIA
INCLUDING THE DOESN'T RECEIVE
SERGEANT TRAVERSABLE COUNCIL ACT
FUNDING.
AMERICANIZATION WAS VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THIS OF THIS
COUNTIES EFFORTS TO PASS
ORIGINAL AB FIVE NINETY WE
CONTINUE TO BE INVOLVED IN
BEGINNING IN TIPS ARE BEGINNING
IN TWENTY ELEVEN WE CAN BE IN
THE LEADERS OF THE ORGANIZATIONS
RECEIVING THIS FUNDING. TO
COLLABORATE AND TO TALK ABOUT
IMPLEMENTATION AND WE ALSO
CONVENE THE ATTORNEYS HIRED
PROVIDED AND A LOT OF TRAINING
AND SUPPORTS THAT WE HAD A CORE
OF SCHREIBER ATTORNEYS.
PROVIDING EXCELLENT SERVICES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
I NOW SERVE ON THE SHRIVER'S
SELECTION COMMITTEE AND ON OUR
LAST OPEN PROCESS FOR PROPOSALS
WE HAD OVER TWELVE MILLION
DOLLARS IN APPLICATIONS FOR THIS
FUNDING ALMOST DOUBLE THE ACTUAL
AMOUNT OF AVAILABLE FUNDS.
AND THE BEAUTY OF SHRIVER WHICH
ADMITTEDLY REQUIRES EXTRA WORK
FOR THE ORGANIZATIONS IS IN THE
EVALUATIONS -- I DOUBT THAT ANY --
OUTSIDE ECONOMIC ADULT ANYONE
OTHER THAN ACADEMIC RESEARCHERS
READ THE FULL SIX HUNDRED PAGE --
EVALUATION BUT THERE'S A LOT OF
REALLY GREAT INFORMATION THERE
FOR THOSE WHO ARE INTERESTED IN
LOOKING AT THE WAYS THAT AND THE
INTERVENTION OF A LEGAL AID
ATTORNEY CAN MAKE A POSITIVE
DIFFERENCE IN PEOPLE'S LIVES --
WE LIVE IN A DATA DRIVEN SOCIETY
BUT BECAUSE OF ILLEGALLY DOES
NOT THE MEDICAL PROFESSION WHERE
PEOPLE RETURN TO THEIR DOCTOR OR
TO THE HOSPITAL FOR ANNUAL
CHECKUPS WE DON'T KNOW WHAT
HAPPENS AFTER SOMEONE RECEIVES
OUR SERVICES.
BUT WISH DRIVER WE DO THE
EVALUATION WENT AND FOLLOWED UP
CLIENTS A YEAR AFTER THE FACT TO
COMPARE -- WHAT HAPPENED AFTER
REPRESENTATION HOW ARE THEIR
LIVES IMPROVED OR NOT AND WHAT
SHOULD WAS COMMONSENSE IS A
PEOPLE'S LIVES ARE ACTUALLY
IMPROVED AND HOUSING CASES MORE
PEOPLE WERE HOUSED AFTER
REPRESENTATION IN THE CONTROL
GROUP AND IN CUSTODY CASES?
AND PARENTS ABOUT SUPPORTED
THROUGH THE PROCESS AND THERE IF
YOUR CHILD CUSTODY MODIFICATION
ORDERS WHICH MEANS MORE STABLE
FAMILIES.
SO WE ASK YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL WE THINK THE INCREASE
FUNDING WILL.
BE ABLE TO EXPAND THE PROJECTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND TO MORE
SUBSTANTIVE AREAS OF LAW
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
AND ONE IN SUPPORT SEEING NONE
IS THERE OPPOSITE OF SUPPORT OUT
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ANDREW
ANTS WE HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF
LOS ANGELES CITY ATTORNEY MIKE
FEAR.
WE SUPPORT THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT.
MIKE HERALD OF WESTERN CENTER
ASKED THAT I STATE SUPPORT
WESTERN CENTER.
THANK YOU JUST ABOUT.
RIGHT IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION.
RIGHT SIGNAL BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE.
QUESTIONS COMMENTS MISTER KALRA
THINK THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR YOU
KNOW WHEN I WORKED AS DEBBIE
PUBLIC DEFENDER -- OFTENTIMES IN
YOUR CERTAINLY IN ST CLAIR
COUNTY -- THE THE BEST LAWYERS
MORE OFTEN NOT NOT ROOM WHERE
THE PUBLIC DEFENDERS AND
OFTENTIMES REPRESENTED.
CLIENTS THAT HAD LITERALLY NEXT
TO NOTHING -- THE FACT THAT IN
THE CIVIL.
JUSTICE SYSTEM THAT WE
DEFINITELY HAVE OF A TALE OF TWO
COURT SYSTEMS -- I THINK IS
SOMETHING THAT WE REALLY NEED TO
LOOK AT AS A SOCIETY CERTAINLY
AS A STATE.
THAT I KNOW IS SOMETHING OF
INTEREST TO MANY.
OF THE THAT ARE -- THAT SERVE ON
THIS COMMITTEE BUT IN THE
MEANTIME BUT WE DOING TO TRY OUR
BEST TO PROVIDE SOME EQUITY
PROVIDES IS A REPRESENTATION AND
SO I'M VERY GRATEFUL -- THIS AS
SOME OF THE BILL THAT YOU'RE
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD THE
SERVICE BEING PROVIDED CLEARLY
ARE HELPING TO PROVIDE JUSTICE
OF TO THOSE THAT CAN.
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THESE PROGRAMS
AND AND THE LEGAL AID
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE PROVIDING
THEM -- UNTIL WE HAVE -- UNTIL
WE HAVE THAT EQUITY IS SOMEDAY
HOPEFULLY IN THE MEANTIME LET'S
MAKE SURE TAKE CARE AS MANY
PEOPLE AS WE CAN AND I WORKED IN
PROGRAMS LIKE THIS WHEN I WAS IN
DC REPRESENTING -- SLUMLORDS --
ATTENDED TENANTS AGAINST
SOMEONE'S IN DC AND WITHOUT US
AND I WAS A LAW STUDENT ATTORNEY
WITHOUT A AS I MEAN THEY
LITERALLY HAD NO ONE TO SPEAK UP
FOR THEM SO.
VERY GRATEFUL FOR THIS ON HOW TO
MAKE A MOTION. TO MOVE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU YOU HAVE A MOTION IS
THERE A SECOND.
AND THE SECOND.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER COMMENTS
QUESTIONS.
SEEING NONE MISTER GAVE REALLY
MAKE CLOTHES YEAH I JUST WANTED
TO I THINK THANK YOU TO MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SANTA CLARA FOR
THOSE VERY KIND COMMENTS ON AND
FOR ALL OF THE WORK THAT YOU'VE
DONE THANK YOU TO THE THE CHAIR
AND THE STAFF FOR THE EXCELLENT
SUGGESTIONS AND FEEDBACK -- JUST
WANT TO SAY I THINK THAT THIS
BILL AND THIS PROCESS REPRESENTS
THE BEST OF POLICY MAKING BI
PARTISANSHIP IN ACTION TO CREATE
A PROGRAM -- TO FULFILL A
FUNDAMENTAL PROMISE OF OUR
JUSTICE SYSTEM WHICH IS JUSTICE
FOR ALL WHICH WE HAVE YET TO
ACHIEVE -- RIGOROUS ANALYSIS AND
EVALUATION EVALUATION THAT
DEMONSTRATES THAT DOLLARS ARE
BEING WISELY SPENT THERE WERE
ACTUALLY SAVING MONEY WERE
CREATING EFFICIENCY IN THE COURT
SYSTEMS AND CREATING BETTER
OUTCOMES FOR FOLKS.
AND HOPE THAT WE CAN CONTINUE
THAT AND GROW THAT SO WE CAN
EXPAND IT TO OTHER PARTS OF THE
STATE AND HELP MORE FOLKS.
AND RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU.
WE DO HAVE A MOTION A SECOND THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS KALRA PLEASE
STONE BY STONE AYE GALLAGHER.
CHAO.
CHAU AYE CHIU [inaudible]
GONZALEZ.
INSULTS AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY.
KILEY NO MAIENSCHEIN OBERNOLTE
[inaudible]
PETRIE-NORRIS.
PETRIE-NORRIS AYE RADIUS.
REYES I THAT BILL IS OUT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
SO THIS TAKES US.
TO ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB SEVEN
EIGHTY FIVE MISTER BLOOM.
WARNING GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR NUMBERS AB SEVEN EIGHTY
FIVE UPDATES THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY CODE THAT REGULATE CAMMY
BANKS.
GAMETE BANKS ARE TISSUE BANKS
THAT COLLECT PROCESSOR STORE
SPERM.
EGGS AND EMBRYOS SAID THESE
FACILITIES ALSO PROVIDE
PROFESSIONAL REPRODUCTIVE
SERVICES FOR PEOPLE WHO WISH TO
CREATE A FAMILY.
LAST YEAR I AUTHORED TWENTY AB
TWENTY SIX EIGHTY FOUR TO UPDATE
THE UNIFORMED PARENTAGE ACT AND
MAKE IT GENDER OR GENDER NEUTRAL
AS PART OF THE UPDATE.
WE CHANGE CODES THAT REGULATE
GAMETE BANKS AND UPDATED THE
CURRENT LAWS TO PROVIDE FAMILIES
WITH IMPORTANT DONOR MEDICAL
HISTORY.
THIS BILL IS A FOLLOW UP TO
THOSE UPDATES AND TIES UP A FEW
LOOSE ENDS FROM LAST YEAR.
AB SEVENTY FIVE WILL BETTER
STREAMLINED THE TRANSFER OF
IMPORTANT DONOR MEDICAL HISTORY
INFORMATION FROM ONE BANK TO
ANOTHER.
AN ALLIANCE THE EXISTING STATE
CODES TO HARMONIZE WITH THE
FDA'S REGULATIONS FOR DONOR
IDENTITY REQUIREMENTS AND TISSUE
TRANSFERS.
AB SEVEN EIGHTY FIVE WILL
REQUIRE.
BANKS THAT RECEIVED ON AGAIN
MEETS TO MAINTAIN THE CONTACT
INFORMATION THE BANK FROM WHICH
THE SAMPLES WERE RECEIVED.
THE ORIGINAL BANK WILL MAINTAIN
MORE DETAILED DONOR INFORMATION
AS WELL.
AND THIS WILL ENSURE THAT THE
TRANSFER OF GAMETE FROM ONE BANK
TO ANOTHER WILL NOT AFFECT THE
FAMILY'S ABILITY TO HAVE ACCESS
TO PROPER DONOR MEDICAL
INFORMATION.
IF AND WHEN THEY NEED IT.
ADDITIONALLY THE LEGISLATION
UPDATES THE DEFINITION OF DAMAGE
TO INCLUDE BOTH -- SITES AND
EMBRYOS TO BETTER ALIGN STATE
LAWS WITH FEDERAL LAWS.
ULTIMATELY THE UPDATES ARE
IMPORTANT IN COMPLYING WITH THE
FDA'S REGULATIONS.
WE'RE CONTINUING -- IN THIS BILL
OUR EFFORTS TO BETTER REGULATE
GAMETE BANKS AND PROVIDE ALL
FAMILIES AND CHILDREN CONCEIVED
FROM DONOR TISSUE WITH THE
NECESSARY INFORMATION TO MAKE
INFORMED.
HEALTH DECISIONS IN THE FUTURE
TO SPEAK MORE ON THAT TECHNICAL
CHANGES THE NEED FOR THE BILL WE
HAVE REPRESENTATIVES HERE FROM
THE QUALITY CALIFORNIA AND THE
AMERICAN SOCIETY FOR
REPRODUCTIVE MEDICINE.
THANK YOU FIRST WITNESS PLEASE
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
ALICE KESSLER IN HER BEHALF OF
THE QUALITY CALIFORNIA AND WE'D
LIKE TO THINK MISTER BLOOM FOR
ALL OF HIS WORK IN THIS AREA
IT'S A VERY IMPORTANT FOR
FAMILIES -- IN OUR COMMUNITY WHO
WERE -- YOU KNOW WANT TO ENSURE
THAT THEY HAVE THE PROTECTIONS
IN PLACE THAT THEIR CHILDREN
HAVE ACCESS TO MEDICAL HISTORY
DONOR INFORMATION AS THEY GROW
OLDER -- AND SO WE APPRECIATE.
CALIFORNIA STAYING ON TOP OF
THESE CHANGES THAT NEED TO BE
MADE AND ENSURING WE HAVE
MAXIMUM PROTECTIONS IN PLACE SO
WE WOULD URGE YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE
THANK CHAIRMAN SMITH CURRENTLY
REVERSING THE AMERICAN SOCIETY
FOR REPRODUCTIVE MEDICINE THERE
THE PROVIDERS AND THE BANKS THAT
ARE ARE AT ISSUE.
THERE'S A LOT OF DIFFERENT
REQUIREMENTS THIS IS AN AREA
THAT IS VERY HEAVILY REGULATED
SO WE NEED TO LOOK.
AT ALL OF THE DIFFERENT
REGULATORY BODIES ON MAKE SURE
THAT THAT THE CALIFORNIA LAWS
CONSISTENT SO WE APPRECIATE --
THE UPDATE IN MAKING THIS SO
THAT IT IS A FUNCTIONAL BILL FOR
US.
AND FOR THE THE PRESENCE OF
CALIFORNIA.
WELL SCRIPTED VOTE THANK YOU
ANYONE ELSE WE CAN SUPPORT.
CNN IS THEIR OPPOSITION.
SAY NONE BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE.
QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
IF YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND.
THE COMMENTS QUESTIONS SEEING
NONE MISTER BLOOM YOU MAY CLOSE
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR ARRIVAL
THANK YOU THANK YOU MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS CALL THE
ROLL PLEASE STONE BY STONE AYE
GALLAGHER.
CHOW.
CHOW I CHIU.
GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I HOLDEN [inaudible]
KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE MAIENSCHEIN
[inaudible]
OBERNOLTE PETRIE-NORRIS.
PETRIE-NORRIS AYE RADIUS.
REYES I THAT BILL IS OUT THANK
YOU THANK YOU MISTER BLOOM.
ALRIGHT MS BAUER QUE HAN ITEM
NUMBER.
EIGHT AB
.
ELEVEN SIXTY FIVE GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS TODAY
I'M HERE TO PRESENT ON AB ELEVEN
SIXTY FIVE THE BILL WHICH WILL
HELP PROTECT CHILDREN IN CUSTODY
MATTERS BY ENSURING.
THE DURING COURT ORDERED
VISITATION MONITORS TASKED WITH
SUPERVISING THESE VISITS HAVE
PASSED APPROPRIATE BACKGROUND
AND TRAINING REQUIREMENTS.
IN CHILD CUSTODY MATTERS FAMILY
COURTS GENERALLY REQUIRE
SUPERVISED VISITATIONS WHEN
THEIR ALLEGATIONS ARE HISTORY OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE CHILD ABUSE
NEGLECT SUBSTANCE ABUSE MENTAL
ILLNESS AND THREATS OF ADOPTION.
WHEN SUPERVISED VISITATION IS
REQUIRED ISITATION IT MONITOR
IS RESPONSIBLE FOR SUPERVISING
HAS THAT THAT'S?
THE MONITORS CAN BE MUTUALLY
AGREED UPON FAMILY MEMBERS OR IF
REQUIRED THE COURT MAY ORDER
THAT THE FAMILIES PAY. FOR
VISITATION MINOR.
CURRENT STATUTES REQUIRE THE
PROFESSIONAL PROVIDERS MEET
CERTAIN STANDARDS FOR EXAMPLE
THE PROVIDER MUST BE AT LEAST
TWENTY ONE YEARS OLD.
NOT BE CONVICTED OF A DO YOU AYE
WITHIN THE LAST FIVE YEARS HAVE
NO RECORD OF CONVICTION FOR
CHILD MOLESTATION CHILD ABUSE OR
OTHER CRIMES.
AGAINST A PERSON AND HAVE TWENTY
FOUR HOURS OF TRAINING.
THE TRAINING MUST INCLUDE
SUBJECTS REGARDING CHILD ABUSE
REPORTING LAWS DEVELOPMENTAL
NEEDS OF CHILDREN.
AND KNOWLEDGE OF FAMILY LAW
BECAUSE OF A LACK OF SUPERVISION
THOUGH THERE'S NO OVERSIGHT OF
THIS.
AND WHILE THE ABOVE MENTIONED
STATUTORY TRAINING AND
QUALIFICATION REQUIREMENTS EXIST
THERE IS NO WAY FOR PARENTS TO
VERIFY WHETHER THE TRAINING'S
BEEN MATT OR THE QUALIFICATIONS
HAVE BEEN MAD.
THERE IS NO WHAT CRIMINAL
BACKGROUND CHECK REQUIRED.
THE ONLY CURRENTLY REQUIRED
VERIFICATION IS FOR THE MONITOR
FILL OUT A DECLARATION UNDER
PENALTY OF PERJURY STATING THEY
HAVE UNDERGONE TRAINING AND
HAVEN'T BEEN CONVICTED OF
CERTAIN CRIMES CHILDLESS
MOLESTATION AND CHILD ABUSE
AMONGST THEM.
THIS IS STRICTLY SELF
ATTESTATION AND THERE'S NO
STANDARD AS TO WHETHER THE FORM
SB SUBMITTED TO THE PARENTS OR
OF THE COURTS.
IN SOME CASES THE FORM IS AN
ACTUALLY SUBMITTED TO ANYONE.
IN OTHER WORDS THERE'S NO WAY
FOR PARENT WHO'S BEING ORDERED
TO HAVE THIS PERSON IN THE
PRESENCE OF THEIR CHILD TO MAKE
SURE THAT THIS PERSON IS SAFE TO
BE AROUND THEIR CHILD AND THEY
HAVEN'T BEEN CONVICTED OF A
SEXUAL FELONY.
AB ELEVEN SIXTY FIVE WILL PUT
INTO PLACE REQUIREMENTS SUCH AS
BACKGROUND CHECKS IN IN PERSON
TRAINING THE MUST BE COMPLETED
AND PASSED BY THE PROFESSIONAL
VISITATION MONITORS. TO BETTER
ENSURE THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF
CHILDREN UNDER THEIR CARE.
AS A MOTHER WHO VOLUNTEERS IN
PUBLIC SCHOOL I MUST DO MORE OF
A BACKGROUND CHECK THAN THESE
VISITATION MONITORS.
AND THAT IS NOT THE WAY THE LAW
SHOULD BE.
SO TODAY I HAVE PEOPLE HERE TO
TESTIFY WITH ME I HAVE LYNNE
STEWART FROM CHANGE FOR JUSTICE
AND MICHELLE BROWN WITH THE
FAMILY LAW SECTION OF THE STATE
BAR.
AND THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF CERTIFIED FAMILY LAW
SPECIALIST.
THANK YOU.
WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
FIRST WITNESS PLEASE.
RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO HELP MAKE OUR
CHILDREN SAFER WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THIS OPPORTUNITY
BEFORE YOU AYE WINCER WITH
CHANGE FOR JUSTICE.
AND I THINK THE BEST WAY FOR YOU
TO UNDERSTAND HOW IMPORTANT THIS
BILL IS IS DELIVERED TO THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE ACTUALLY IN THE
TRENCHES SO MICHELLE WHO IS A
FAMILY LAW ATTORNEY AND HE'S
BEEN.
IN THIS BUSINESS ARE MORE THAN
TWO DECADES AND RACHEL GAMMA
WHO'S A PROFESSIONAL MONITOR AS
A NUMBER OF MONITORS WORKING
UNDERNEATH THEM I THINK THEY
HAVE THE MOST -- VALID
TESTIMONIES ALL DIFFER MY TIME
TO THEM.
THANK YOU WELL EVERYONE HAS AN
INDIVIDUAL TIME THERE'S NO
DIFFERENCE OF TIME OF HIS BAR
CAM THERE'S AN AMENDMENT THAT'S
LISTED ON PAGE -- YES LEASES
YOU'RE TAKING THAT AMENDMENT YES
THEY DO ACCEPT THEM TWENTY
MINUTES THANK YOU ALRIGHT NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE THANK YOU -- MY
NAME'S MICHELLE BROWN AND I AM A
CERTIFIED FAMILY LAW SPECIALIST
WHO HAS BEEN PRACTICING ABOUT
TWENTY FIVE YEARS ON THE
PRESIDENT OF A A CC CALIFORNIA
THE VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CERTIFIED FAMILY
LAW SPECIALIST.
AN ADVISER FOR THE FAMILY LAW
SECTION FOR THE CALIFORNIA
LAWYERS ASSOCIATION -- AND BOTH
OF THOSE ORGANIZATIONS HAVE
PROVIDE OF LETTERS AND SUPPORT
SO I'VE BEEN IN THE TRENCHES AND
INVOLVED FOR A VERY LONG TIME
AND I CAN TELL YOU WITHOUT
HESITATION.
AB ELEVEN SIXTY FIVE IS VERY
GOOD AND IT IS INSTRUMENTAL AND
IMPORTANT PROTECTION OF CHILDREN.
RIGHT NOW THERE IS NO OVERSIGHT
FOR SUPERVISED VISITATION
MONITORS YOU HAVE A SITUATION
WHERE A JUDICIAL OFFICER HAS
FELT.
THAT THIS PARENT IS SUCH A
DANGER TO THIS CHILD THAT THE
PARENT CANNOT HAVE CONTACT
WITHOUT A SUPERVISOR.
AND IF IT'S A PROFESSIONAL
SUPERVISOR THE JUDICIAL OFFICER
HAS FELT THAT THAT SAFETY IS
SUCH A CONCERN THAT WE CAN'T
EVEN HAVE A FAMILY MEMBER.
YET THERE'S NO OVERSIGHT SO IN
STEPS A SUPERVISED VISITATION
MONITOR.
THE ONLY BUFFER BETWEEN THIS
CHILD AND POTENTIALLY A PARENT
WHO HAS PHYSICALLY OR SEXUALLY
MOLESTED THAT CHILD.
AND THERE'S NO.
OVERSIGHT THERE'S NO BACKGROUND
CHECK THERE'S NO FINGERPRINTING.
HOW DO YOU GIVE THIS PARENT
COMFORT TO KNOW THAT THAT SHALL
BE PROTECTED?
GIVE THEM FINGERPRINTING.
GIVE THEM THE BACKGROUND CHECK.
MAKE SURE THAT THIS PERSON IS
TRAINS THERE'S NO BALLING NO
INTIMIDATION LET ME PROVIDE THAT
CUSTODIAL PARENT THE COMFORT OF
KNOWING YOUR CHILD IS GOING TO
BE SAFE.
THAT THAT MONITOR KNOWS HOW TO
STOP THE VISITATION IF THERE IS
AN UNDERCURRENT.
AND SURPRISINGLY KNOWING THAT
THEY CANNOT ACCEPT GIFTS OR
BRIBES.
COUNTRY CLUB MEMBERSHIPS GOLF
MEMBERSHIPS ALSO THEY CAN GET A
GOOD REPORT FROM THE SUPERVISOR
THE TATIAN MONITOR YES THAT DOES
HAPPEN.
I AM ASKING YOU AS A
PRACTITIONER IN THE TRENCHES TO
GIVE US YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU.
THE FIRST PLACE HI MY NAME IS
RACHEL GAMMA I OWN A HAPPY VISIT
DOING MONITORING SERVICES IN SAN
DIEGO COUNTY -- PRIOR AYE A
WORKED FOR CHILD WELFARE
SERVICES IN SAN DIEGO.
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY.
AM I A SUPPORT AB AT ELEVEN
SIXTY FIVE BECAUSE IN ANY ASPECT
WORKING WITH CHILDREN.
THERE SHOULD BE A LAW THAT
REQUIRES A BACKGROUND CHECK.
I AM A SOCCER COACH I AM
REQUIRED TO HAVE A BACKGROUND
CHECK ALSO AS A TEEN PARENT ON
LITTLE LEAGUE BASEBALL I AM
REQUIRED TO HAVE A BACKGROUND
CHECK.
I AM ALSO A SUBSTITUTE TEACHER
I'M REQUIRED TO HAVE A
BACKGROUND CHECK.
THE FAMILY COURTS THE JUDGE THE
COMMISSIONERS ARE ORDERING
PARENTS AND CHILDREN.
SUPERVISE MONITORS WE ARE NOT
REQUIRED TO HAVE A BACKGROUND
CHECK AND FOR ANYBODY THAT I
WORK WITH IN MY COMPANY.
I REQUIRE THEM TO HAVE A
BACKGROUND CHECK I REQUIRE THEM
TO NOT ONLY HAVE THE TWENTY FOUR
HOUR TRAINING BUT TO BE SHADOWED.
WITH MONITORS WORKING FOR THE
COUNTY AND COMING INTO THIS.
THERE NEEDS TO BE MORE RULES AND
REGULATIONS ON MONITORS. TO
PROTECT THE CHILDREN WE ARE HERE
TO PROTECT AND KEEP CHILDREN
SAFE AND PERRANCE SAFE IN THIS
TRYING TIME A FAMILY LAW.
AND I ASK THAT YOU SUPPORT THIS
BILL AS WELL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
IF YOU GIVE US YOUR NAME AND
YOUR AFFILIATION PLEASE.
I AM CATIONS AB WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CHILDCARE RESOURCE
AND REFERRAL NETWORK AND FOR
JUST OVER THIRTY YEARS WE IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH DSS HAVE.
OPERATED THAT TRUSTS LINE
PROGRAM -- WHICH IS THE MOST
COMPREHENSIVE BACKGROUND CHECK
FOR CHILD CARE WERE DELIVERED TO
CONNECTING IN TESTIMONY BUT JUST
THAT YOU SUPPORT THE BILL AND WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT.
ALRIGHT CNN IS THEIR OPPOSITION.
WHEN I SING NONE BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS [inaudible]
COMMENTS.
RIGHT SIGNAL THE STOCKADE YOU
MAY CLOSE QUESTION I THINK THE
COMMITTEE AND THE CHAIR FOR
WORKING WITH US ON THIS BILL AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR EITHER.
THANK YOU YOU HAVE A MOTION AND
A SECOND THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE STONE BY
STONE AYE GALLAGHER.
CHOW.
CHOW I CHIU.
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE KALRA.
KILEY KILEY AYE MAIENSCHEIN
OBERNOLTE PETRIE-NORRIS.
PETRIE-NORRIS I REYES.
REYES AYE.
THAT BILL IS OUT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
RIGHT THIS RACE.
TAKES US TO ITEM NUMBER TWELVE
A. B. FIFTEEN TED
.
MORNING THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS.
I WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN BY
THANKING THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
FOR WORKING WITH MY OFFICE ON
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND.
AB FIFTEEN TEN ALLOWS VICTIMS OF
SEXUAL ASSAULT AND THEIR DAY IN
COURT BY EXEMPTING FROM THE
CURRENT STATUTE LIMITATIONS.
CLAIMS OF SEXUAL ASSAULT AT
STUDENT HEALTH CENTERS THAT
OTHERWISE WOULD HAVE BEEN BARRED
PRIOR TO JANUARY FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY ALTHOUGH
LEGISLATION WAS PASSED LAST YEAR
THAT EXTENDS A STATUE
LIMITATIONS FOR DAMAGES OF
SEXUAL ASSAULT TO TEN YEARS.
THAT LEGISLATION IS NOT
RETROACTIVE.
LEAVING COUNTLESS VICTIMS
WITHOUT RECOURSE INCLUDING
CURRENT.
AND FORMER U. S. C. STUDENTS
VICTIMIZED BY DOCTOR TEN DAHLE.
IN MAY OF TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
THE LA TIMES BROKE THE STORY OF
A COVER UP BY U. S. C. REGARDING
SEXUAL MISCONDUCT OF STUDENT
PATIENTS.
BY TEN DOWN THE SOUL FULL TIME
GYNECOLOGIST EMPLOYED BY.
THE UNIVERSITY ADDED STUDENT
HEALTH CENTER.
AFTER THE UNIVERSITIES
INVESTIGATION USC QUIETLY PAID.
DOCTOR TYNDALL TO GO AWAY AND
FAILED TO DISCLOSE INFORMATION
ABOUT THE FINDING OF THE
INVESTIGATION. TO STUDENTS.
THE MEDICAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA
OR LAW ENFORCEMENT.
DOCTOR TEN DAHLE STARTED A U. S.
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE IN OVER
THE YEARS IT IS ESTIMATED THAT
OVER FOURTEEN THOUSAND FEMALE
STUDENTS.
WERE IMPACTED BY DOCTOR TYNDALL.
FAILURE TO BRING TO LIGHT
COMPLAINTS OF DOCTOR TEND ALL
SEXUAL ASSAULT ON STUDENTS
ALLOWED HIM TO CONTINUE TO
ASSAULT ASSAULT.
THOUSANDS OF WOMEN FOR YEARS.
IT IS VITAL THAT SURVIVORS ARE
PROVIDED WITH AN OPPORTUNITY TO
HAVE THEIR DAY IN COURT.
AND THIS BILL WILL PROVIDE AN
ADDITIONAL YEAR FOR SURVIVORS TO
SEEK JUSTICE.
HERE TO TESTIFY ON BEHALF OF
THIS BILL IS A SURVIVOR NICOLE
HAYNES.
AND HOLLY BOYER FROM THE
CALIFORNIA CONSUMER ATTORNEYS TO
ANSWER ANY LEGAL QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU FIRST WITNESS PLEASE --
SERVICE REYES YOU TECHNIQUES THE
AMENDMENTS YES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
FIRST WITNESS.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS NICOLE HAYNES
AND I'M HERE TO SPEAK.
IN SUPPORT OF AB.
FIFTEEN TEN DURING MY TIME AT
USC I SERVED AS CAPTAIN OF THE
TRACK AND FIELD TEAM.
AND I SPECIALIZED IN THE
HEPTATHLON WHICH IS SEVEN EVENTS
COMPUTE OVER TWO DAY PERIOD.
I WENT TO THE OLYMPIC TRIALS AND
IN THE DECADE AFTER GRADUATING
BECAME A PROFESSIONAL TRACK AND
FIELD ATHLETE.
AND LATER IN LIFE OF BROADCAST
JOURNALISM WHO FOR A TIME
COVERED USC SPORTS.
I AM A TROJAN TO THE CORE.
AND THAT IS WHAT MADE MY COMING
FORWARD.
ABOUT THE ABUSE I SUFFERED AT
THE HANDS OF DOCTOR TYNDALL.
SO INCREDIBLY DIFFICULT.
IN NINETEEN NINETY FIVE DURING
MY JUNIOR YEAR AT USC.
I WENT TO THE STUDENT HEALTH
CENTER WITH THE WORST CASE OF
FOOD POISONING THAT I'VE EVER.
EXPERIENCED.
IT WAS THERE THAT I CAME INTO
THE CARE OF DOCTOR TYNDALL.
AND LIKE SO MANY OTHERS WAS PUT
THROUGH THE ORDEAL OF A FULL
VAGINAL EXAM FOR SOMETHING
TOTALLY UNRELATED TO MY ILLNESS.
THIS WAS ALSO MY FIRST
GYNECOLOGICAL EXAM.
AS I HAD NEVER BEEN SEEN BY AN
OB GM WITH BG WHY AND PRIOR TO
THAT.
DR TYNDALL VIOLATED ME.
I VIVIDLY REMEMBER THAT DAY
BECAUSE I HAD NEVER EXPERIENCED
THAT TYPE OF STOMACH PAIN.
BEFORE IN MY LIFE.
AND I JUST WANT TO THE FIGURE
OUT WHAT WAS GOING ON GET TO THE
BOTTOM OF IT AND GET SOME
TREATMENT.
SO WHEN I WAS ASKED TO DISROBE
AND PUT MY FEET UP IN THE
STIRRUPS TO GET THE VAGINAL EXAM
I COMPLETELY COMPLIED I JUST.
WANTED TO BE OUT OF THIS IMMENSE
PAIN.
AFTER THE EXAM WAS DONE I WAS
TOLD YOU HAVE FOOD POISONING GO
HOME.
AND IT'LL PASS WITHIN SEVERAL
HOURS.
I WAS LAKE.
THAT WAS IT I WENT THROUGH ALL
THAT.
JUST TO GO HOME.
IT NEVER THOUGHT WELL WITHIN MY
SPIRITS.
IT WASN'T UNTIL I STARTED
READING STORIES ABOUT WITH
DOCTOR TYNDALL DID LAST YEAR IN
THE NEWS.
THAT MY CONFUSION ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED BACK IN.
NINETEEN NINETY FIVE BECAME
CRYSTAL CLEAR.
I IMMEDIATELY REACH OUT TO A
DEAR FRIEND OF MINE WHO'S A
PHYSICIAN.
AND ASKED IS IT NORMAL TO GET A
FULL VAGINAL EXAM WHEN YOU GET
FOOD POISONING.
ANY KIND OF CHUCKLED WITH LAKE
NO WOULD YOU TALKING ABOUT.
LIKE HUNDREDS OF MY FELLOW
CHOSEN SISTERS.
I WAS SEXUALLY ASSAULTED BY
SOMEONE WHO IS SUPPOSED TO BE.
MY TRUSTED DOCTOR.
A DOCTOR THAT USC KEPT EMPLOYED
AND ALLOWED TO TREAT YOUNG WOMEN
LIKE ME.
LONG AFTER REPORTS OF HIS ABUSE.
MY MOM WAS ABUSED AS A CHILD AND
SHE CONSTANTLY REMINDED ME HEY
IF ANYBODY TOUCHES YOU IN AN
INAPPROPRIATE WAY.
LET ME KNOW.
I NOW HAVE A FOUR YEAR OLD AND
I'M CONSTANTLY TELLING HER HEY
IF ANYBODY TOUCHES YOU LIKE THIS.
LET ME KNOW.
THESE PREDATORS CAN'T BE STOPPED
UNLESS THE REPORTED.
AND I KIND OF FEEL ROB TO THAT I
WAS AN ABLE TO REPORT THAT
DURING MY TIME BECAUSE I TRUSTED
USC AND ITS EMPLOYEES TO TAKE
THE BEST CARE OF ME.
I HAD TO COME FORWARD TODAY NOT
JUST FOR ME BUT FOR MY MOM.
AND FOR THE HUNDREDS OF OTHER
WOMEN WHO HAVE SAT.
WITH THEIR SHAME FEAR AND
MISTRUST ABOUT THE ABUSE THEY
SUFFER BY SOMEONE WHO'S SUPPOSED.
TO CARE FOR THEM.
THIS SYSTEM IS NOT WORKING WHEN
THIS TYPE OF ABUSE IS ALLOWED TO
OCCUR FOR ALMOST THIRTY YEARS.
THE SYSTEM IS BROKEN WHEN THE
GOOD NURSES.
WHO REPORTED THIS HORRENDOUS
CONDUCT WERE MET WITH INACTION
OR BETTER WORSE?
A COMPLETE COVER UP.
THE SYSTEMIC FAILURE IS
CONTINUING NOW IS WE TRY TO
BRING OUR CASE TO COURT.
THE INSTITUTION THAT ALLOWED THE
ABUSE U. S. C..
IS CLAIMING THAT ARE QUE
DEADLINES AND STATUTES OF
LIMITATIONS SHOULD BE ALLOWED TO
LIMIT OUR RIGHTS AND OUR VOICES.
WE WILL NOT BE SILENCED.
AB FIFTEEN TEN WILL GIVE
SURVIVORS LIKE ME WHO HAVE COME
FORWARD A CHANCE TO HOLD THOSE
WHO HARM DEATH ACCOUNTABLE.
I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THIS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT BILL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND APPRECIATE YOUR
TESTIMONY I KNOW HOW HARD IT IS
TO COME FORWARD.
ON A SUBJECT LIKE THIS IN A VERY
PUBLIC PLACE.
THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. FOR NEARLY
THIRTY YEARS DOCTOR GEORGE TEND
ALL THE ONLY FULL TIME
GYNECOLOGIST A USC STUDENT
HEALTH CARE CENTER.
USES POSITION OF TRUST AND
AUTHORITY TO MOLEST ABUSE AND
HIM HUMILIATE STUDENTS MANY OF
WHOM WERE TEENAGERS SEEKING A
GYNECOLOGIST FOR THE VERY FIRST
TIME.
TINDALL WOULD INSTRUCT STUDENTS
TO LIE NAKED ON THE EXAM TABLE
WHILE HE SLOWLY INSPECTED EVERY
PART OF THEIR BODY WHILE AT THE
SAME TIME MAKING SEXUALLY
INAPPROPRIATE COMMENTS AND
PHOTOGRAPHING THEIR GENITALIA.
HE WOULD INSERT HIS UNCLE OF TWO
FINGERS INSIDE A PATIENT UNDER
THE GUISE OF A MEDICAL EXAM
DESPITE BEING COMPLETELY
UNNECESSARY AND EXTREMELY
IMPROPER.
WHILE TYNDALE'S RAMPANT SEXUAL
ABUSE IS DEEPLY DISTURBING WHAT
IS PERHAPS MORE DISTURBING IS
THAT U. S. C. KNEW THAT TEN
DAHLE HAD BEEN SEXUALLY ABUSING
STUDENTS FOR DECADES.
AND DID NOTHING TO STOP IT.
AFTER THE VIEWS AND COVER UP WAS
FINALLY MADE PUBLIC IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN A BRAVE SIX
HUNDRED AND FIFTY FEMALE VICTIMS
HAVE COME FORWARD AND INITIATED
ACTIONS AGAINST USC IN
CALIFORNIA STATE COURT.
MANY OF THESE VICTIMS HOWEVER
NOW FACE YET ANOTHER OBSTACLE.
AN EXPIRED STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS.
AB FIFTEEN TEN PROVIDES A NARROW
ONE YEAR REVIVAL PROVISION TO
THE STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS TO
GIVE THESE VICTIMS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE THEIR CASE.
HEARD IN COURT.
THE ONLY OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
IS U. S. C..
USC ARGUES THAT THE THE BILL
DESTROYS A PROPOSED FEDERAL
CLASS ACTION SETTLEMENT REACHED
WITHIN ONLY A FEW SHORT WEEKS
AFTER THE ABUSE WAS CLOSED.
THIS IS SIMPLY NOT TRUE.
AB FIFTEEN TEN DOES NOT REVIVED
CLEANS WHERE THERE HAS BEEN A
FINAL SETTLEMENT.
THAT HAS BEEN REACHED.
USC ARGUES THAT AB FIFTEEN TEN
DEPRIVES WOMEN OF THE CHOICE TO
RESOLVE THEIR CLAIMS IN A MANNER
THAT THEY FEEL APPROPRIATE.
BUT THE EXACT OPPOSITE IS TRUE.
AB FIFTEEN TEN PROVIDES WOMEN
THE CHOICE OF WHETHER TO SEEK
REDRESS THROUGH THE CLASS ACTION
SETTLEMENT OR PURSUE AN
INDIVIDUAL CLAIM IN STATE COURT.
THESE VICTIMS SHOULD NOT BE
HANDCUFFED TO A SETTLEMENT THAT
THEY MAY BELIEVE IS UNDRESSED.
IT IS ONLY WITH THE PASSAGE OF
AB FIFTEEN TEN THAT THESE
VICTIMS HAVE A MEANINGFUL CHOICE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU HELLO WOULD ANYONE
ELSE LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
YOU GIVE US YOUR NAME AND YOUR
AFFILIATION MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE SHANE GUSMAN ON
BEHALF OF THE TEAMSTERS AND THE
SEVERAL THOUSAND HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONALS THEY WERE PRESENT
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT.
JESSICA CENTER ABOUT EQUAL
RIGHTS ADVOCATES IN SUPPORT.
YOUNG CANGO A CONSUMER
FEDERATION OF CALIFORNIANS PART.
I'LL HANDLE THAT I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF CHANGE FOR JUSTICE AND
SUPPORT.
SAID ALI KING WITH THE FACULTY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS OPPOSITION
.
GOOD MORNING MR TURN MEMBERS
MUCH AUDIBLE GOV ON BEHALF OF
THE UNIVERSITY OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA I TOO WOULD ALSO LIKE
TO THANK YOUR COMMITTEE STAFF
AND ALL THE HARD WORK ON THE
ANALYSIS.
I APPRECIATE THE TIME AND EFFORT
THAT HE PUT INTO THAT.
AB FIFTEEN TEN IS UNNECESSARY
LEGISLATION THAT SEEKS TO
INVALIDATE AND ESTABLISH LEGAL
PRINCIPLE THAT IS THE BEDROCK OF
OUR CIVIL JUSTICE PROCESS.
THE SOLE PURPOSE OF AB FIFTEEN
TEN IS TO ENSURE THAT NONE OF DR
TYNDALE'S FORMER U. S. C.
PATIENTS.
ARE PREVENTED BY STATUTE OF
LIMITATION RESTRICTIONS FROM
RECEIVING A DAMAGE AWARD.
BUT THAT PROBLEM HAS ALREADY
BEEN CONSIDERED AND ADDRESSED.
MONTHS BEFORE THIS BILL WAS
INTRODUCED US HE AGREED TO A
FEDERAL CLASS ACTION SETTLEMENT
THAT OFFERS MEANINGFUL
COMPENSATION. FOR ALL WOMEN THAT
SAW DOCTOR TYNDALL FOR WOMEN'S
HEALTH SERVICES.
UNLESS THEY CHOOSE TO OPT OUT OF
THE SETTLEMENT.
THE FEDERAL CLASS ACTION
SETTLEMENT WAS EXPRESSLY
DESIGNED TO INCLUDE.
ALL WOMEN WITH TIME BARRED
CLAIMS.
THE SETTLEMENT WHICH WAS REACHED
IN COLLABORATION WITH IT
NUMEROUS PLAINTIFFS ATTORNEYS
AND ENDORSED BY A FEDERAL
MEDIATOR OFFERS WOMEN CERTAINTY
AND PRIVACY.
WITH THE UNPREDICTABILITY OF A
JURY TRIAL THERE IS NO GUARANTEE
THAT A PLAINTIFF THE WILL
PREVAIL IN AN INDIVIDUAL LAWSUIT.
FOR THE MORE LITIGATION FORCES
WOMEN TO RELIVE THEIR ORDEALS
PUBLICLY.
WHEREAS THE SETTLEMENT RESPECTS
THE PRIVACY OF THOSE WHO DO NOT
WISH TO X..
EXPOSE THEIR EXPERIENCES AND PUT
THEM ON DISPLAY FOR ALL THE
WORLD TO HEAR.
IN ADDITION TO THE MONETARY
RELIEF FOR PATIENTS THE SADDAM
INCLUDES TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS.
IN ATTORNEY'S FEES AND A BROAD
RANGE OF OPERATIONAL REFORMS
THAT IN CONCERT WITH CHANGES IN
MEDICATIONS.
ALREADY IMPLEMENTED BY U. S. C.
WILL PREVENT SUCH CONDUCT FROM
HAPPENING AGAIN TO ANOTHER
MEMBER OF THE TROJAN COMMUNITY.
THIS IS A JUST AND COMPREHENSIVE
SETTLEMENT THAT ELIMINATES THE
NEED FOR LEGISLATION LIKE AB.
FIFTEEN TEN NOT ONLY IS THIS
BILL UNNECESSARY BUT IT ALSO
THREATENS TO SET A DANGEROUS
PRECEDENT.
BY INVALIDATING STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS WHICH EXIST RESERVE
BOTH THE INTEGRITY OF OUR LEGAL
SYSTEM.
AND THE DUE PROCESS RIGHTS OF
INDIVIDUALS.
EXTENSIONS OF STATURE
LIMITATIONS ONLY SERVE TO REVIVE
A CLAIM.
NOT THE RECORDS OR MEMORIES OR
EVIDENCE REQUIRED TO LITIGATE.
SO WHERE THE CLASS ACTION
SETTLEMENT PROVIDES WOMEN A
GUARANTEED OUTCOME.
DECADES OLD CASES.
LITIGATED INDIVIDUALLY MAY YIELD
ON CERTAIN RESULTS AND HOLD THE
POSSIBILITY OF NO RECOURSE
WHATSOEVER.
IT WOULD BE TRULY UNFORTUNATE IF
ONE OF THE MANY UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES OF AB FIFTEEN TEN
WAS TO EMBOLDEN WOMEN.
WHO OTHERWISE WOULD BENEFIT FROM
THE CLASS ACTION SETTLEMENT TO
PURSUE AN UNWINNABLE CASE IN
STATE COURT AND WIND UP WITH
NOTHING?
FURTHER ATTORNEYS WHO SOLICIT
PLAINTIFFS HAVE AN EHICAL
OBLIGATION TO HONESTLY EXPLAIN
THE RISKS AND BENEFITS OF I'M
SORRY OF OPTING OUT OF THE
FEDERAL CLASS SETTLEMENT.
EVEN WITH THE STATUTE OF
LIMITATION EXTENSIONS THERE ARE
MANY RISK FOR PLAINTIFFS WHO
CHOOSE TO PURSUE INDIVIDUAL
CLAIMS.
PERHAPS WORSE THERE IS A CLEAR
CONFLICT OF INTEREST ON THE PART
OF THE ATTORNEYS.
ACTIVELY SOLICITING PLAINTIFFS
USING THIS BILL.
AS A MEANS TO PERSUADE.
PLAINTIFFS THAT MIGHT HAVE
DIFFICULT ODDS IN STATE COURT TO
TAKE A SIGNIFICANT GAMBLE ON
JUSTICE.
AS YOUR COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
STATES EVEN IF THE PLAINTIFFS
CLAIM HAS NOT LAPSED.
AND THE PLAINTIFF IS ENTITLED TO
AN AWARD IN THE SETTLEMENT IT IS
NOT CERTAIN THAT THE PLAINTIFF
WILL HAVE SUFFICIENT EVIDENCE TO
PROVE ALL THE ELEMENTS OF THE
CAUSE OF ACTION IN COURT.
WELL THE SPONSOR MADE IT CLEAR
THAT AB FIFTEEN TEN IS DIRECTLY
AIMED AT USC THIS BILL HAS FAR
REACHING CONSEQUENCES FOR
CALIFORNIA'S MANY DISTINGUISHED
LIBERAL ARTS COLLEGES.
AND SMALL INDEPENDENT
UNIVERSITIES AS IT WOULD ALSO
REVIVED CLAIMS FOR THEM AND NOT
JUST FOR U. S. C..
JUSTICE SHOULD RIGHTFULLY BE
SERVED FOR VICTIMS BUT THIS KIND
OF RETROACTIVE LIABILITY COULD
BANKRUPT SMALL AND LIBERAL ARTS
COLLEGES IN YOUR DISTRICTS IN
AROUND CALIFORNIA.
GIVEN THE SIZE OF SOME OF THE
SCHOOLS IN DOWN MEN'S ONE BAD
DOCTOR WHO SAW PATIENTS DECADES
AGO COULD SPELL THE END OF THE
INSTITUTIONS THEMSELVES.
THE BILL MAY ALSO HAVE A
CHILLING EFFECT ON PHYSICIANS.
WHO WILL FACE MORE OCCUPATIONAL
RISK AND SKYROCKETING INSURANCE
PREMIUMS?
AB FIFTEEN TEN WILL UNDOUBTEDLY
INCREASE INSURANCE MALPRACTICE
PREMIUMS FOR PRIMARY CARE
PHYSICIANS AND PARTICULARLY FOR
OBGYN.
WHICH COULD HAVE SERIOUS
CONSEQUENCES FOR WOMEN AND THEIR
HEALTH CARE.
SIMPLY PUT AB FIFTEEN TEN IS BAD
POLICY AND WILL CREATE A
MULTITUDE OF UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES AND LEGAL
CHALLENGES.
WHILE DOING VERY LITTLE TO
PROTECT PATIENTS OF STUDENT
HEALTH CARE CENTERS FOR THESE
REASONS WE URGE YOUR NOBLE ON A.
B..
FIFTEEN TEN THANK YOU ANYONE
ELSE IN OPPOSITION.
RIGHT SIGNAL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS
COMMENTS [inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
THIS RACE TO MAKE CLOTHES.
I THINK WITH THE TESTIMONY
PROVIDED BY MS HAINES IT'S CLEAR
THAT JUSTICE HAS NOT BEEN SERVED
[inaudible]
IF A CLASS ACTION -- SETTLEMENT.
IS BEING PROPOSED.
IT IS NOT NECESSARILY FOR THE
BENEFIT OF THE VICTIMS.
THIS IS THE ONLY WAY THAT THE
VICTIMS WILL BE ABLE TO SEEK
THEIR JUSTICE AND TO CHOOSE
EITHER TO GO WITH A CLASS ACTION
LAWSUIT OR TO SUE INDIVIDUALLY.
AND FOR THAT REASON I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO PUBLIC SAFETY CALL
THE ROLL PLEASE STONE BY STONE
AYE GALLAGHER CHOW.
CHOW I CHIU GONZALEZ.
CONSULT AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE KALRA.
KILEY MAIENSCHEIN OBERNOLTE
PETRIE-NORRIS REYES.
HI RES I NEEDS O MORE SO WE'LL
PUT THE BILL ON CALL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER CHAU.
SIX IS TO ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN AB.
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU
WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND I WILL
SECOND THAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS SO I LIKE
TO START OFF BY ACCEPTING.
OF THE AMENDMENTS ARE LISTED IN
THE ANALYSIS -- WHICH
ESSENTIALLY MOVE REMOVE SO
SECTION TWO OF THE BILL RELATED
TO CRITICAL.
INCIDENTS AND ALSO THE PUBLIC
RECORDS ACT.
ALL THIS BILL AB SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY TWO WOULD ESTABLISH A
BALANCE BETWEEN.
PERSONAL PRIVACY AND PUBLIC
SAFETY BY CREATING SPECIFIC
PROCEDURES AROUND THE RETENTION.
AND SHARING OF DATA COLLECTED BY
AUTOMATED DONE LICENSE PLATE
READERS OR A. L. P. R.'S.
THE OPR IS A HIGH SPEED CAMERA
SYSTEMS THAT PHOTOGRAPH LICENSE
PLATES CONVERT THE NUMBERS AND
LETTERS INTO MACHINE READABLE
TEXT.
TACK THEM WITH THE TIME AND
LOCATION AND THEN UPLOAD DOT
DATA INTO A DATABASE FOR
RETRIEVAL.
OUR WITH THE ALLOWED THIS
INFORMATION CAN HAVE AND HAS HAD
A POSITIVE PUBLIC SAFETY
OUTCOMES.
WITHOUT PROPER GUIDELINES -- THE
TECHNOLOGY POSES ALSO A THREAT
TO THE PRIVACY OF INDIVIDUALS
WHO HAVE DONE NOTHING WRONG.
CURRENT LAW REQUIRES SAID L. P.
R. IN USERS PROVIDE USE USE AND
PRIVACY POLICIES.
ARE FOR SECURITY OF ANY DATA
THAT IS COLLECTED ABOVE IN TERMS
OF STORAGE AND ACCESS DESTROY
ANY NON INVESTIGATIVE DATA AND
ALSO MAKE THE POLICIES ARE
EASILY ACCESSIBLE TO THE PUBLIC.
HOWEVER CURRENT LAW IS OF ACHE
IN SILENT AWE AND IT DOES NOT
PROVIDE THE PUBLIC WITH THE
ASSURANCE OF KNOWING.
ALL WHETHER OR NOT THEIR
INFORMATION IS SO INDEED SAFE.
THIS BILL EIGHTEEN SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY TWO WITH SAY KERR THIS
INFORMATION BY PLACING
LIMITATIONS ON HOW LONG A PR
DATA IS KEPT.
AND ALSO HOW IT IS -- BEING
SHARE MAKING SURE THAT END USERS
MISS TREAT THIS INFORMATION IN
THE SAME WAY AS THE OPERATOR.
SO I RESPECTFULLY ASKS FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THEY HAVE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WHEN I WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT?
SEEING NONE IS THERE OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING WOULD BE PROUD
CALIFORNIA NEWS PUBLISHERS WE DO
NOT HAVE A FORMAL POSITION ON
THE BILL.
LIKE TO THINK THE AUTHOR AND
STAFF FOR THE AMENDMENTS ARE
PROPOSED THE BILL THEY GO A LONG
WAY TOWARDS ADDRESSING OUR
CONCERNS WE DO HAVE SOME
CONTINUING CONCERNS AND LOOK
FORWARD.
TO CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR AND STAFF THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION OR
OTHERWISE.
RIGHT SEEING NONE OF BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
COMMENTS.
SEARCH ARE YOU MAY CLOSE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I UNDERSTAND THAT
THE ANALYSIS OF THE RACE CERTAIN
CERTAIN -- CONCERNS.
AND I I WANT TO SHOW MY
APPRECIATION TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR A REASON THIS CONCERNS AND
THE INTENT IS TO FORCE TO REACH
OUT -- CONTINUE TO REACH OUT TO
THE LAW ENFORCEMENT FOLKS TO
BASICALLY BUILD CONSENSUS ON
WHAT IS WORKABLE AND A WHETHER
OR NOT WE NEED.
TO REFINE THE DEFINITION OF A
ANIMALS ASIAN AND ALSO THE THE
DIFFERENCES BETWEEN AND USER AND
THE OPERATOR SO -- WE WILL
CONTINUE TO DO THAT AND THE
INTENT IS TO MAKE THOSE CHANGES
IN THE NEXT COMMITTEE WHICH IS
THE PRIVACY COMMITTEE SO WITHOUT
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO PRIVACY CALL
THE ROLL PLEASE STONE BY STONE
AYE GALLAGHER CHAU I CHARGE YOU.
GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I HOLDEN KALRA
[inaudible]
KILEY.
MAIENSCHEIN OBERNOLTE
PETRIE-NORRIS RACE.
THE NEED FOR MORE SCHOOL FOR THE
BILL ON CALL.
I THINK SINCE MR OBERNOLTE START
HERE I WOULD TAKE UP MY ITEMS MS
GONZALEZ WOULD YOU CHAIR THE
COMMITTEE FOR ME [inaudible]
YEAH MANY OF YOU HAVE -- USE IT
SPARINGLY.
THOSE ARE NOT REAL MEETINGS.
NOW I I WANT THIS BILL
PRESENTATION BE LIKE
APPROPRIATIONS.
ALL RIGHTS STONE THAT START WITH
AB.
SEVEN FORTY NINE THAT WORKS FOR
ME PLEASE YOU MADAM CHAIR.
RIGHT AB SEVEN FORTY NINE IS TO
ADDRESS.
NO RE HIGHER PROVISIONS AS THEY
EXIST [inaudible]
THE HEAD.
RECENT COVERAGE OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT HAS REALLY SHOWED A
LOT OF ATTENTION APPROPRIATELY.
ON THE FACT THAT COMPANIES AND
EVEN LEGISLATIVE BODIES AND
PUBLIC AGENCIES TEND TO LIKE TO
PUT IN A NO REHIRE PROVISIONS
NEVER HIRE PROVISIONS HAVE THE
VERY DIRECT EFFECT THAN.
OF PUNISHING.
THE INDIVIDUAL WHO HAS COME
FORWARD WITH A CLAIM.
AND THEN THROUGH THE SETTLEMENT
OF THAT CLAIM ENDS UP SIGNING IN
A NO REHIRE AGREEMENT AND WHAT'S
ASTONISHING TO ME AS I LOOK
THROUGH EXAMPLES OF THESE.
THIS IS A VICTIM OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT OR VICTIM OF AN ABUSE
WITHIN AN ORGANIZATION WHO THEN
IS RE VICTIMIZED BY LOSING
ACCESS TO A CAREER.
A CAREER PATH OR EVEN IN THE
ORGANIZATION THAT THEY CAME FROM.
AND ADDING INSULT TO INJURY
OFTENTIMES PERPETRATOR THAT.
STAYS ON THE JOB MAY HAVE SOME
HAVE HAD SOME.
ACCOUNTABILITY NOT ALWAYS BUT IS
USUALLY THERE AND THEN IT'S THE
VICTIM WHO IS THEN MOVED ON THIS
SEEMS TO BE VERY UNFAIR AND
INAPPROPRIATE WAY OF UTILIZING
THE LAW.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE I DO HAVE A NUMBER OF
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT WHO HAVE.
DIRECT EXPERIENCE WITH HAVING
BEEN THROUGH THESE PROCESSES AND
HAVE BEEN.
DENIED.
ACCESS TO JOBS THROUGH NEW HIRE
NO HIGHER PROVISIONS AND SO AT
MY WITS IS SPEAKING WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR IBM
THANK YOU FIRST WITH AS
GOOD
NAME IS CARMEN FIELDS.
AND I'M HERE TO TELL YOU MY
STORY ABOUT HOW I LOST MY CAREER.
BECAUSE I WAS FORCED TO RESIGN
AND AGREE TO A NO REHIRE CLAUSE
AS A CONDITION OF SETTLING A
SEXUAL HARASSMENT CLAIM.
I STARTED WORKING FOR THE
CALIFORNIA OUR PATROL IN APRIL
OF TWO THOUSAND AND TEN IN
DECEMBER OF TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN
SHORTLY AFTER LETTER JOHNSON WAS
HIRED BY CHP.
HE BEGAN SOCIALLY HARASSING ME
AND OTHER FEMALE CO WORKERS.
IT STARTED WITH HIM INSISTING
THAT I HIGH FIVE HIM.
THEN GRABBING MY HAND WHEN I
DECLINED.
I ASKED HIM TO STOP BUT HE WOULD
NOT.
IT QUICKLY PROGRESSED TO HIM
RUNNING HIS FINGERS THROUGH MY
HAIR I'M DOING MY HAIR WHEN I
PUT IT IN A BUN.
AND FORCING HIS WAY INTO SITTING
ON MY LAP.
THESE ACTIONS WERE WITNESSED BY
SEVERAL OTHER EMPLOYEES
INCLUDING SUPERVISORS.
I DEMANDED THAT HE LEAVE ME
ALONE.
I FREQUENTLY COMPLAIN TO MY
COMMANDER WHO SAID SHE DIDN'T
KNOW WHAT TO DO.
ABOUT THE HARASSMENT.
ON MARCH THIRTIETH.
TWENTY TWELVE JOHNSON ATTACKED
ME.
DRAGGING ME INTO A PRIVATE
OFFICE.
BY MY WRIST.
ATTEMPTING TO KILL SPEAK.
AND PUSHING HIS BODY AGAINST
MINE YES I'VE FOUGHT HIM OFF.
I REPORTED THIS CRIME TO THE
CITY TREE MANAGER OF INCLUDING
MY DIVISION CHIEF.
OUR UNIFORMED POLICE OFFICER.
I DEMANDED THE CHIEF PROTECT ME
FROM JOHNSON AND TO INVESTIGATE
THE INCIDENT.
THE CHIEFS RESPONSE WAS TO LEAVE
LANDING.
IN ITS MANAGERIAL POSITION.
AND ADMINISTRATIVELY TRANSFER ME
TO A LESS DESIRABLE POSITION. TO
SEE IF YOUR VIRTUALLY ASSIGNED
AN INVESTIGATOR.
BUT THE CHP REFUSED TO COMPLETE
THEIR INVESTIGATION AND I WAS
LEFT WITH NO CHOICE.
BUT TO FILE A COMPLAINT WITH THE
EEOC.
ALTHOUGH JOHNSON ADMITTED LEAD
ADMITTED TO SEVERAL ARRESTING
SEVERAL FEMALE OF CO WORKERS
UNDER HIS COMMAND WHILE HE WAS A
PROBATIONARY EMPLOYEE.
THE CHP GRANTED HIM PERMANENT
CIVIL SERVICE STATUS INFORMING
HIM THAT HIS BEHAVIOR MET THE
STANDARDS.
THAT C. H. P. EXPECTED OF ITS
MANAGERS.
ACCORDING TO THE PUBLIC RECORDS
ACT.
JOHNSON CONTINUES TO WORK FOR
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND MAKES 40% MORE TODAY THAN HE
DID THEN THE DAY WHEN HE
ATTACKED ME.
THE RETALIATION AGAINST ME
HOWEVER CONTINUED.
I WAS DENIED PROMOTIONS BECAUSE
I FILED A SEXUAL HARASSMENT
COMPLAINT.
MY DAUGHTER WORKS FOR THE CHP.
AND HER SUPERVISOR BRAG ABOUT
NOT PROMOTING ME BECAUSE I HAD
FILED.
THE COMPLAINT.
THE SIEGE HE PRESSURED ME TO
SETTLE THE CASE.
AND WERE ADAMANT THAT I BE
FORCED TO RESIGN.
I DID NOT WANT TO RESIGN.
I LOVE THE JOB.
AND I LOVE THE FRIENDS THAT I
HAVE. TO SPEAK.
THE MORE I PUSH BACK AGAINST A
AGAINST SUBTLY BY RESIGNING THE
MORE SPEECH THE MORE AGGRESSIVE
THE SPEECH HE GOT WITH MY FAMILY
AND MY FRIENDS.
I WAS INFORMED THAT THE CHP
INTENDED TO DISPOSE MY FAMILY
AND MY FRIENDS GOING BACK INTO
MY CHILD.
ALL I EVER WANTED WAS TO BE
PROTECTED FROM JOHNSON I'M SO
USED TO TELL ME THAT WAS NOT AN
OPTION.
AS PART OF THE SETTLEMENT I WAS
FORCED TO AGREE TO A NO REHIRE
PROVISION.
MEANING I COULD NO LONGER WORK
FOR THE STAGE BE OR ANY OF ITS
DEPARTMENTS.
AREAS OR DIVISION.
THANK OR VOLUNTEER [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THIS DESPITE HAVING OVER TWELVE
YEARS OF JOB EXPERIENCE SIX
YEARS OF EXEMPLARY PERFORMANCE
EVALUATIONS FROM STAGE BIG IN
OTHER REGIONS.
AND I HAVE A MASTER'S DEGREE IN
PUBLIC ADMINISTRATION.
I HAVE BEEN CONTACTED BY OTHER
QUEUE TO BE EMPLOYEES.
WHO HAVE BEEN VICTIMS OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT?
AND THEY TOLD ME THEY WILL NOT
REPORT BECAUSE THEY FEAR COMING
FORWARD TO LOSING THEIR JOBS I
DID.
IT IS UNFAIR THAT IN A MINUTE
SEXUAL ROUNDER CONTINUES TO WORK
FOR THE STATE.
RECEIVING PROMOTIONS AND RAISES.
WELL I AM PREVENTED FROM FOR
THIRD PLACE.
SIMPLY BECAUSE LIKE US TO BE
PROTECTED FROM ROOMS.
THIS IS NOT A HE SAID SHE SAID
SITUATION.
HE FREELY AND WAS ACTIONS
AGAINST ME.
AND DOESN'T SEEM TO BE
EMBARRASSED OR ASHAMED OF WHAT
HE DID.
REQUIRING VICTIMS OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT.
AND NEVER REALLY BE REHIRED
WHICH IS THE ULTIMATE FORM OF
INSTITUTIONAL RETALIATION
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
JESSICA CENTER AND I'M AN
ATTORNEY EQUAL RIGHTS ADVOCATES
OUR PRACTICAL SPONSOR THIS BILL
WE REGULAR REGULARLY REPRESENT
WOMEN OF EXPERIENCE SEXUAL
HARASSMENT AND OTHER FORMS OF
WORKPLACE -- HARM AND ONE OF THE
BIGGEST BARRIERS FOR WORKERS TO
SPEAK OUT ABOUT HARASSMENT
ANOTHER WORKPLACE VIOLATIONS IS
FEAR RETALIATION BEING FIRED
HAVING THEIR WAGES REDUCED AND
IS PARTICULARLY PRONOUNCED FOR
LOW WAGE WORKERS FOR HIM THERE
IS NO.
OFTEN NO SAFETY NET WORKERS
OFTEN DON'T UNDERSTAND THE
BREADTH OF THESE NO RE HIRE
CLAUSES AND ARE REALLY JUST
READY TO ACCEPT WHATEVER IS IN
THE AGREEMENT TO PUT THE MATTER
BEHIND THEM.
AND BECAUSE AS WE'LL HEAR ABOUT
IT'S BECOME PRETTY BOILERPLATE
FOR THESE PROVISIONS TO BE IN
THE AGREEMENTS WORKERS OFTEN
FEEL THAT THEY HAVE TO JUST
SETTLE IT EXCEPT THAT PROVISION
IN ORDER TO MOVE ON WITH THEIR
LIVES.
I'LL GIVE YOU REALLY QUICK
EXAMPLE LOW WAGE IMMIGRANT
WORKER THAT WE REPRESENT AID SHE
THE PLAYER HAS BOILERPLATE
LANGUAGE IN THE AGREEMENT
REQUIRED HER TO SIGN THE
AGREEMENT SAYING SHE WOULD NOT
BE.
REHIRED SHE SAID SHE DIDN'T MIND
BECAUSE SHE DIDN'T WANT TO GO
BACK TO THAT SPECIFIC EMPLOYER
BECAUSE THIS THE HARASSER WAS
STILL THERE -- SHE CALLED US
ABOUT FOUR MONTHS LATER AND SAID
SHE BEEN DIED A JOB AT A
DIFFERENT RESTAURANT CHOOSE A
DISHWASHER BECAUSE THEY SAID IT
WAS OWNED BY THE SAME COMPANY.
AND THAT THIS IS NO REHIRE
CLAUSE APPLIED ALL THEIR SIX NOW
THERE'S MORE RESTAURANTS IN SAN
FRANCISCO I'M SUCH AN EXAMPLE OF
HOW WORKERS OFTEN DON'T EVEN
UNDERSTAND.
THAT SIGNING THESE AGREEMENTS
WILL PRECLUDE THEM FROM MANY
DIFFERENT JOBS IN THE FUTURE --
FOR MANY WOMEN THESE CLAUSES CAN
BE SO BROAD THAT IT FORCES THEM
TO ACTUALLY CHANGE THEIR CAREERS
AND FOR THESE REASONS VERMONT
RECENTLY BANNED NO REAL HIGHER
CLAUSES IN THESE KINDS OF
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENTS.
I THINK WE'VE SEEN WITH THE ME
TOO MOVEMENT AN EXPLOSION OF
PEOPLE COMING OUT TO SPEAK ABOUT
SEXUAL HARASSMENT OTHER HARMS
AND WE REALLY WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE SUPPORTING VICTIMS
AND SURVIVORS OF OUR ASPEN AND
OTHER ABUSES.
SO THEY CAN SPEAK OUT WITHOUT
FEAR OF RETALIATION AND WITHOUT
FEAR OF BEING BANNED FROM
WORKING FOR THAT EMPLOYER OR
OTHERS.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
MARIE GO YOSHIHARU WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PLUMMET LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION WANT TO THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE FOR
BRINGING THIS.
BILL FORWARD AND CARMEN FOR
TELLING YOUR STORY AND AS YOU'VE
HEARD OVER THE PAST DECADE OR SO
THESE NO REHIRE CLAUSES OF SORT
OF SURREPTITIOUSLY BECOME
STANDARD IN ALL SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENTS WITHOUT ANY REAL
SCRUTINY FROM A POLICY
PERSPECTIVE.
AROUND WHY THEY'RE IMPOSED ON
WORKERS IN THE FIRST PLACE AND
WHAT KIND OF IMPACT THEY HAVE ON
THOSE WORKERS AND THEIR JOB
OPPORTUNITIES AND AND CAREER
PATH.
SO WHY DO YOU EMPLOYERS USE
THESE ARE REQUIRE THESE NO
REHIRE CLAUSES AND ALL
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENTS.
THEY SAY IT'S TO PROHIBIT
EMPLOYEES WHO HAVE ENGAGED IN
UNLAWFUL OR AGREE JUST CONDUCT
FROM SEEKING RE EMPLOYMENT FROM
THE SAME EMPLOYER.
BUT THEN WHY ARE THEY REQUIRED
IN ALL SETTLEMENT AGREEMENTS IF
THE WORKER ENGAGED IN AGREE JUST
ARE UNLAWFUL CONDUCT IN THERE
ARE VALID REASONS JUST NOT TO
REHIRE THE PERSON. TO THE REASON
WHY IS BECAUSE IT ALLOWS
EMPLOYERS TO GET AROUND A
RETALIATION LAWS AND NOT RE HIRE
SOMEONE JUST BECAUSE THEY FILED
THE COMPLAINT.
WE KNOW THAT EMPLOYERS MAY NOT
WANT TO RE HIRE SOMEONE. TO SUE
THEM IN SAY A SEXUAL HARASSMENT
LAWSUIT BUT THAT IS RETALIATION.
AND WHY ARE WE ALLOWING
EMPLOYERS TO INSULATE THEMSELVES
FROM ANY SORT OF RETALIATION
CLAIM WHEN ONE WORKERS MAY HAVE
A VALID RETALIATION CLAIM IF
THEY'RE NOT RE HIRED
JUST BECAUSE THEY FILE THE
COMPLAINT AND SETTLED THEIR
CLAIM WHICH IS THE POSITION OF
THE EOC AND TO WIN THESE CAUSES
ARE SO OVER BRIAN AND
UNNECESSARY IF AGAIN THERE ARE
VALID REASONS TO NOT RE HIRE THE
PERSON.
SO WE THINK THESE NO REHIRE
CLAUSES.
REALLY SERVE NO PURPOSE BUT TO
INSULATE EMPLOYERS FROM
LIABILITY.
AT THE AT THE EXPENSE OF BROADLY
PUNISHING VICTIMS WHO ARE SIMPLY
TRYING TO ENFORCE THEIR RIGHTS.
I DON'T KNOW HOW WE CAN EXPECT
VICTIMS AND LOOK TO COME FORWARD
WHEN THIS IS THE PRICE THAT THEY
HAVE TO PAY SO WE STRONGLY URGE
YOUR SUPPORT.
STE CHALLENGES YOUR SECOND HAND
YEAH THAT'S RIGHT.
OKAY I DON'T KNOW YOUR ROLES MR
STONE SO IS IT THREE WITNESS
SAYS.
I TYPICALLY ALLOW THREE BUT WITH
OKAY.
AND THEN I'M SORRY.
TRACK.
GET THIS WHAT TO TALK AND GOING
ON THANK YOU FOR YOUR STORY.
I'M SUGGESTS YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION AND SUPPORT FOR THE
BILL GOOD MORNING ABBE AT C.
PEPPERING ON BEHALF OF THE
CONSUMER TRAINS CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT.
GEN GARY AND WE HAVE A LEGALLY
THAT WORK IN SUPPORT.
SIR ANY OPPOSITION
.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE JENNIFER BROWN
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE AND WE ARE OPPOSED I'M
I THINK THE ISSUE WITH REGARDS
TO SEXUAL HARASSMENT VICTIM AND
RETALIATION IS A PRETTY
STRAIGHTFORWARD ISSUE IN THE
EEOC GUIDANCE.
OR THE SUGGEST -- THAT THAT'S
UNLAWFUL IN COULD BE A THE
SITUATION OF RETALIATION IF YOU
HAVE A VICTIM WHO HAS FILED A
COMPLAINT OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT
AND THEN YOU HAVE A SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENT IN WHICH THERE IS A NO
REHIRE.
OUR CONCERNS WITH THE BILL IS
NOT FOCUSED ON THAT OUR CONCERNS
WITH THE BILL IS THAT IT'S MUCH
BROADER AND ACTUALLY COULD
PROTECT THE HARASSER THAT WE
JUST HEARD DESCRIBED IF THEY
FILE A COMPLAINT.
AGAINST THE EMPLOYER FOR
DEFAMATION WHICH IS ACTUALLY NOT
UNCOMMON AND I'M HAPPY TO
PROVIDE MULTIPLE EXAMPLES OF
PUBLISHED CASES IN WHICH
HARASSER THEMSELVES.
AFTER BEING INVESTIGATED AND
ALLEGED TO HAVE ENGAGED IN
HARASSMENT HAS AND FATHER
DEFAMATION CLAIM AGAINST THE
EMPLOYER THE WITNESSES WHO
PARTICIPATED IN THE
INVESTIGATION AND THE VICTIM OF
HARASSMENT THEMSELVES.
BECAUSE THE DEFINITION OF
AGGRIEVED PERSON IN THIS BILL
INCLUDES ANYBODY WHO WAS FILED A
COMPLAINT AGAINST THE EMPLOYER
THAT ALSO INCLUDES THE HARASSER
THEMSELVES AND WE DON'T WANT TO
RE HIRE OR EVEN HAVE THEM RE
APPLY. FOR EMPLOYMENT WITH US
AFTER WE'VE ALREADY ENGAGED
INVESTIGATION AND FOUND THAT THE
ENGAGED IN HARASSMENT AS THE
ANALYSIS POINTS OUT.
THERE'S NOTHING IN HERE THAT
SAYS WE HAVE TO RE HIRE THEM
WHICH I AGREE WITH BUT THE
CHALLENGES IF YOU I DON'T HAVE A
NO REHIRE PROVISION IN YOUR
CONTRACT IN THE SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENT.
AND YOU JUST HAVE SOMETHING
LET'S SAY IN THE SYSTEM RIGHT IN
THE SYSTEM INDICATES THIS PERSON
IS NOT ELIGIBLE FOR RE HIGHER
THEY APPLY AND WE DON'T
INTERVIEW THEM OR WE SAY YOU'RE
NOT ELIGIBLE FOR RE HIGHER WITH
THIS COMPANY.
THAT'S THAN A POTENTIAL
RETALIATION COMPLAINT FOR FILING
AGAINST THE DEFAMATION COMPLAINT
THAT THEY FELL BECAUSE THEY WERE
ENGAGED IN HARASSMENT AND WE'VE
HIRED THEM FOR BE ENGAGING IN
HARASSMENT SO IT'S LIKE THE
CYCLE.
THAT WE DON'T WANT TO ENGAGE IN
WITH SOMEBODY WHO'S ALREADY
SHOWN A PROPENSITY TO FILE A
LAWSUIT AGAINST EMPLOYER EVEN
THOUGH THE ENGAGED IN LAWFUL
CONDUCT THEMSELVES AND WE
BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL IS TOO
BROADLY WORDED AS IT IS RIGHT
NOW. TO INCLUDE THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO I HAVE ACTUALLY
ENGAGED IN UNLAWFUL OFFENSIVE
CONDUCT WERE TERMINATED FOR THAT
AND NOW THEY CAN COME BACK AND
RE APPLY AND THEN AGAIN FILED
ANOTHER LAWSUIT AGAINST THE
EMPLOYER.
IN THIS VICIOUS CYCLE SO FOR
THOSE REASONS WE ARE OPPOSE.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS MIGHT
BELOW FOR THE CALIFORNIA
EMPLOYMENT LAW COUNCIL AND THE
CIVIL JUSTICE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA.
AS PRESENTED THE FACTS FROM THE
CHP EMPLOYER OUTRAGEOUS.
BUT THE BILL IS PLAINLY IN MY
VIEW OVER BROAD IT APPLIES TO
ANY COMPLAINT INTERNALLY FILED
WITH THE COMPANY FOR ANY
EMPLOYMENT TO SPEND.
WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT SEXUAL
HARASSMENT HERE WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT GARDEN VARIETY EMPLOYMENT
DISPUTES WHERE FOR EXAMPLE AT
THAT COHORT OF EMPLOYEES WILL BE
BAKING THE EMPLOYER TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT THIS GUY HE'S
OBNOXIOUS HE'S ABUSIVE.
HE HAS ALL SORTS OF PROBLEMS AND
WE FINALLY MAKE A DEAL.
TO TERM BUT TO SEPARATE FROM THE
EMPLOYEE AND THERE'S NOTHING
WRONG WITH CLARIFYING WE DON'T
WANT YOU BACK.
SO IT IT HAS TO BE POSSIBLE TO
CRAFT THIS BILL MORE NARROWLY TO
RESPOND TO THE OUTRAGEOUS.
OF FACTS THAT WERE PRESENTED
MOST OF WHOM RELATED -- TO
PUBLIC ENTITIES BY THE WAY BUT
THE ADDITIONAL -- THING I WOULD
SAY IS THE USE OF THESE NO RE
HIGHER IS NOT UNIVERSAL AS WHICH
WAS PRESENTED I HAVE LISTENED --
TO HR AND LEGAL EMPLOYMENT
LAWYERS TALK ABOUT HOW TO USE
THEM WHEN TO USE THEM HOW TO
CRAFT THEM NARROWLY TO AVOID THE
EXISTING STATUTE.
CASE LAW PROBLEMS BUT AGAIN WHEN
WE FINALLY GET RID OF A BAD
EMPLOYEE WE DON'T WANT THE
PERSON BACK AND AND YOU I I
SHOULD THINK WE COULD ALL AGREE
ON THAT.
JUST AS WE CAN AGREE THAT THE
CHP OFFICERS -- VICTIMIZATION
WAS OUTRAGEOUS I WOULD LIKE TO
SEE IT MORE NARROWLY CRAFTED.
ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION.
FIFTH FOR JUST ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF JOINT
POWERS AUTHORITY SPEED
RESPECTFULLY ALIGNER COMMENTS
WITH THOSE IN THE SPIRIT MISTER
BELOW OPPOSED.
KATIE HANSON WITH THE CALIFORNIA
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION WE'RE
OPPOSE FOR THE REASONS STATED.
JOSH DUGGAR ON BEHALF OF C. SACK
ACCESS INSURANCE AUTHORITY ALSO
POST.
BRENT LITTLE CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU FOR THE REASONS STATED BY
OUR COLLEAGUES THANK YOU
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT [inaudible]
SEEN QUESTIONS NONE WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU -- ASK YOUR I'VE
[inaudible]
MA'AM SECRETARY.
ACTIONS TO PASS STONE.
HI STONE AYE GALLAGHER CHOW.
CHOW I CHIU.
GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I HOLDEN [inaudible]
KALRA [inaudible]
KILEY.
MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE NO PETRIE-NORRIS RAYS.
RACE I ON CALL.
THAT BILLS ON CALL WE NEED TO
MORE MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE
TO SHOW UP AND VOTE.
FOR NEXT LAST FILM I HAVE THREE
MORE ACTUALLY I'LL TAKE A A. B.
TWELVE SEVENTY I HAVE ONE MORE
BILL AND THEN TO COMMITTEE BILL
SO TAKE UP AB.
TWELVE SEVENTY WHICH IS WITH
RESPECT TO THE FALSE CLAIMS ACT
THAT ON THIS BILL.
THANK YOU WE'VE BEEN WORKING
WITH THE ATTORNEY GENERAL TO
STRENGTHEN THE FALSE CLAIMS ACT
BY PROTECTING WHISTLE BLOWERS
CUT AND CUT BUYING SOME
CONFUSING COURT CASES.
WELL STRENGTHENING SOME
ENFORCEMENT MEASURES.
AND EXPANDING THE ABILITY OF THE
AUTHORITY THE ACT TO INCLUDE TAX
FRAUD CURRENTLY CALIFORNIA
THERE'S A GAP I TAX GAP THEY
CALL IT AND THAT'S ESSENTIALLY.
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN WHAT'S
OWED IN TAXES AND WHAT'S BEING
PAID.
THE GAP IS ABOUT POTENTIALLY
TWENTY BILLION DOLLARS AND THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL IS VERY
INTERESTED IN HELPING US GO
AFTER THAT WE HAVE LOOKED AT A
NUMBER OF VARIOUS AREAS WHERE
WE'RE TRYING TO MAKE SURE.
THAT WE ARE CLEANING UP THE
FALSE CLAIMS ACT PROVIDING
APPROPRIATE PROTECTIONS AND
BEING ABLE TO GO AFTER FRAUD AND
SOME OF THE ABUSES NOW I KNOW
THAT THERE ARE SOME CONCERNS
THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED.
BY THIS -- ESPECIALLY WITH
RESPECT -- TO CHANGES THAT MAY
BE MADE BY CONTRACTORS AND
OTHERS THIS IS CLEARLY FOUR
CASES OF FRAUD WHERE THAT HAS
BEEN ESTABLISHED NOT FOR CASES
OF DISPUTES UNDER NORMAL
CONTRACTING SITUATIONS SO WE'RE
HAPPY TO KIND OF CONTINUE TO
WORK THAT THROUGH ALTHOUGH I
THINK THE BILL IS FAIRLY CLEAR.
THAT WHAT WE'RE ADDRESSING OUR
FRAUDULENT SITUATIONS AND
ENSURING THAT WE HAVE
APPROPRIATE LEVEL OF DAMAGES
ENFORCEMENT WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR EITHER.
THE MOTION A SECOND SO.
HI AM ANTHONY LIVE FROM THE AG'S
OFFICE AND EIGHTY IS PLEASE TO
SPONSOR AB TWELVE SEVENTEEN IS
THE MEASURE THAT.
STRENGTHENS THE CALIFORNIA FALSE
CLAIMS ACT AND THE REALLY
IMPORTANT FOR PROTECTING --
COMBATING FRAUD AGAINST THE
GOVERNMENT AND TAXPAYERS IN WITH
ME OF MARTIN GO YET ALSO FROM
DOJ.
TO TALK ABOUT THE BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON -- MY NAME IS
MARTIN GLAD I HAD THE FALSE
CLAIMS UNIT IN THE TWENTY
GENERAL'S OFFICE.
AND WE SUPPORT THIS LEGISLATION
TO STRENGTHEN OUR ABILITY TO GET
MONEY BACK FROM PEOPLE WHO CHEAT
THE STATE -- AND WE ALSO WANT TO
DETER OTHER PEOPLE FROM DOING
THAT IN THE FUTURE.
ARE THE FALSE CLAIMS ACT HAS
BEEN A VERY EFFECTIVE TOOL FOR
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
MY UNIT IS SO FAR RECOVERED
APPROXIMATELY ONE POINT FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS.
WELL THE LAST NUMBER OF YEARS
UNDER THE FALSE CLAIMS ACT.
I SHOULD ALSO ADD THAT.
THE WORK OF OUR UNIT HAS NOT
COME OUT OF THE STATE BUDGET WE
ARE ENTIRELY SELF FUNDED FROM
OUR RECOVERY -- THAT WILL REMAIN
IN SO IN THE FUTURE AND ANY WORK
WE DO PURSUING TAX FRAUD WILL BE
ENTIRELY SELF FUNDED -- I I KNOW
THAT ISSUE HAS BEEN RAISED ABOUT
THE JURY ALL THE STANDARD -- THE
ISSUE IS ABOUT DEFENDANTS WHO
TRY TO AVOID LIABILITY.
BECAUSE EVEN THOUGH THEY LIED
AND TRIED TO CHEAT THE STATE.
THE STATE PAID THE CLAIM DESPITE
KNOWING IT MIGHT BE FALSE.
THE PROBLEM IS THAT THERE ARE
MANY REASONS WHY THE STATE MIGHT
PAY A CLAIM EVEN IF THEY SUSPECT
IT'S FALSE.
I'LL GIVE YOU ONE REASON ONE
VERY GOOD REASON SOMETIMES IF
WE'RE INVESTIGATING THE CLAIM WE
DON'T WANT TO DO ANYTHING TO TIP
OFF THE DEFENDER.
SO THE GOVERNMENT CONTINUES TO
PAY THE CLIENT ANOTHER REASON
WOULD BE.
AT THEIR PROVIDING A SERVICE
THAT CAN'T BE REPLACED THIS
NEARBY VULNERABLE POPULATION.
THERE MANY MANY KINDS OF REASONS
WHY THE GOVERNMENT WOULDN'T
AUTOMATICALLY CUT OFF PAYMENT.
JUST BECAUSE SOME SAYS THE CLAIM
MIGHT BE FALSE I ALSO WANT TO
NOTE THAT WE DON'T WANT TO
ENCOURAGE.
IT PUT THE GOVERNMENT IN THE
SITUATION.
WHERE IN ORDER TO PRESERVE A
POSSIBLE FALSE CLAIM THEY HAVE
TO IMMEDIATELY CUT OFF PAYMENT?
AS SOON AS SOMEBODY SAYS THERE'S
SOMETHING SUSPICIOUS ABOUT THE
CLAIM.
THAT WOULD BE GOOD FOR THE
GOVERNMENT IT ALSO WOULDN'T BE
GOOD FOR THE CONTRACTORS SO.
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR SUPPORT AND HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU A
CLARIFICATION MISTER STONE I
ASSUME YOU ACCEPT THE IT
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS HI EXCEPT
IN THE COMMITTEES MOMENTS THANK
YOU.
THE NAME THE ENTITLEMENT THE
PEPPERONI ON BEHALF OF THE
CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT SEEN NONE
OPPOSITION.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS PAUL THAT
FILTER REPRESENTING -- THIS IS A
GENERAL CONTRACTORS OF
CALIFORNIA -- CHAIRMAN STONE
ALLUDED TO OUR OPPOSITION LETTER --
FALSE CLAIMS IS ONE OF THOSE
AREAS THAT IS ONE VERY ESOTERIC
AREA THE LAW -- AND SO WE'VE
BEEN WATCHING IT FOR MANY YEARS
AND BEEN INVOLVED WITH WITH --
CHANGES AND THIS AREA WE HAVE
SOME CONCERNS ABOUT THE
MATERIALITY CHANGE -- IN THAT.
RAISES SOME SUBJECTIVE OF
QUESTIONS AS WELL AS THE
INCLUSION OF CONSEQUENCE CHILL
DAMAGES ON TOP OF ALREADY TREBLE
DAMAGES.
AND AS THOSE IN.
THAT ARE LAWYERS KNOW THAT --
AND THEY'RE A CONTRACT LAW THE
REASON YOU SHY AWAY FROM --
CONSEQUENTIAL DAMAGES IS BECAUSE
IT'S DIFFICULT SUBJECT OF TO
PROVE WHAT THE CONSEQUENCE MIGHT
BE WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH CHAIRMAN STONE ON THIS
ISSUE.
A C. WITHOUT WE MIGHT BE ABLE TO
RESOLVE SOME OF THESE OTHER ON
ISSUES THAT WE TALKED ABOUT AND
WITH THAT I JUST WANTED TO RAISE
THOSE CONCERNS.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
I SEE NO QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE WHICH I CLOSE MISTER
STONE I WOULD JUST POINT OUT
THAT FRAUD DAMAGES ESSENTIALLY
ARE CONSEQUENTIAL DAMAGES SO
IT'S A LITTLE TOUGH.
TO DRAW THAT DISTINCTION THERE
BUT I HAVE TO KEEP TALKING TO
THE RIGHT I DON'T THINK THIS
BILL DOES WHAT RAISES THE
CONCERNS THAT THEY'RE TALKING
ABOUT BUT I I RESPECT THE THE
TIME THAT THEY HAVE PUT INTO AND
SO WE'LL SEE IF THERE'S A WAY OF
OF PARSING.
THAT OUT A LITTLE BIT MORE
ACTUALLY BUT WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT IN TERMS OF FRAUD.
BUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
ISLANDS [inaudible]
I'M SECRETARY.
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS STONE.
STONE AYE GALLAGHER CHOW.
CHOW I CHU.
CHU ITEMS AULIS CONSULT AYE
HOLDEN [inaudible]
KALRA [inaudible]
KILEY MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE NO PETRIE-NORRIS.
PETRIE-NORRIS I REYES
[inaudible]
RAY SIGHED.
THE BILL GETS OUT.
THANK YOU WE'LL BE RIGHT
OROVILLE COUPLE OF THAT
COMMITTEE BILLSFIRST OF ALL A.
B..
EIGHTEEN LET'S SEE WHICH WE DO
EIGHTEEN TWENTY ONE THAT'S IN
FRONT OF ME.
WHICH IS A A CHANGE THE BACK IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE SO THIS
BILLS BEEN AROUND IN MOTION A
SECOND.
THAT THEY NEED FOR THIS BILL IS
FAIRLY RECENT THERE'S A HOLDER
RULE WHICH ALLOWS INTO CONSUMER
CONTACTS. TO FOR A CONSUMER TO
GO AFTER NOT ONLY.
A FRAUDULENT.
TRANSACTION BUT ALSO THE LOANER
OF THAT FRAUDULENT TRANSACTION
THERE WAS A RECENT THIRD
DISTRICT COURT OF APPEALS THAT
TURNED THAT AROUND ESPECIALLY
WITH RESPECT TO ATTORNEYS FEES.
WE THINK THAT'S INAPPROPRIATE
AND WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS RE
ESTABLISH A LAW AS IT'D BAND FOR
FORTY YEARS AND WITH THAT.
YOU'RE EITHER OTHER SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
SEEN NONE.
WE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTIONS TO PASS STONE.
BY STONE AYE GALLAGHER CHOW.
CHOW I CHU.
CHU AYE GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I HOLDEN.
KALRA [inaudible]
KILEY MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I OBERNOLTE ABILITY
NO PETRIE-NORRIS PETRIE-NORRIS
AYE RADIUS.
REYES.
OUT JUDGE ONE MORE BILL WHEN
MORE BILL WHICH IS AB EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN AGAIN A COMMITTEE BILL
DEALING WITH THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC RECORDS ACT.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND SECOND
THANK YOU AND WHAT THIS BILL
DOES IS WILL ALLOW SOMEONE
ESSENTIALLY TO GO IN AND COPY
RECORDS WITH A CELL PHONE WHICH
IS NOT NECESSARILY WITH RIGHT
NOW SOMEBODY WHO GOES IN WANTS
TO SEE RECORDS.
HAS TO ASK THE AGENCY TO PROVIDE
COPIES AND THOSE COPIES CAN BE
VERY EXPENSIVE THIS WOULD ALLOW
SOMEBODY TO COME IN.
WITH PRETTY MUCH A CELLPHONE DO
THEIR OWN SCANNING SOME ISSUES
WERE RAISED WITH RESPECT TO
HISTORIC DOCUMENTS OR DOCUMENTS
SUBJECT TO DAMAGE.
THOSE I THINK WE CAN GET AROUND
BECAUSE WE CERTAINLY ABSOLUTELY
WANT TO PROTECT THOSE DOCUMENTS
AND MAKE SURE THAT WHOEVER HAS
WRITTEN.
REQUESTED THOSE DOCUMENTS AND IS
MAKING A COPY OF A RESPECT THOSE.
CAN'T TAKE THEM OFF SITE CAN'T
OTHERWISE DAMAGE THEM BUT SHOULD
BE ABLE TO USE A CELL PHONE TO
MAKE COPIES ON THEIR OWN THAT'S
WHAT THIS CHANGES AND I ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE JIMMY WHAT WITH A
CALIFORNIA NEWS PUBLISHERS
ASSOCIATION WE OPERATE A HELP
LINE IS ONE OF THE SERVICES FOR
OUR MEMBERS AND WHEN JOURNALISTS
CALL TO THE HELP LINE WE'RE
SEEING AN INCREASING NUMBER OF
INCIDENTS WHERE -- STATE AND
LOCAL AGENCIES ARE USING THE
FEES PROVISION OF A PUBLIC
RECORDS ACT AS A BARRIER TO
ACCESS INFORMATION AND THERE'S A
NO BETTER ILLUSTRATION IN THE
CITY OF ANAHEIM OR SKIS YES CITY
OF ANAHEIM.
FOLLOWING THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE NEW -- LAW WITH RESPECT TO
ACCESS TO POLICE MISCONDUCT
RECORDS.
AND THEY'RE A MOTHER WHO WAS
TRYING TO SEEK INFORMATION ABOUT
HER SON AND THE INCIDENT THAT --
BECAUSE HIS SHOOTING -- WAS
GOING TO BE CHARGED OVER THREE
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO OBTAIN THE
FILES THAT SHE'D BEEN SEEKING
PERTAINING TO THE SHOOTING DEATH
OF HER SON -- IT'S GROWING --
THIS IS A BALANCED APPROACH IT
RESPECTS THE INTEGRITY OF THE
RECORD SO THAT A REQUEST --
CANNOT DAMAGE OR MANIPULATE THEM
IN ANY WAY I WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THE MEASURE I AM TAKING THE
THREAT IS JUST AN ASSET THANK
YOU.
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT [inaudible]
ANY OPPOSITION.
BUT CHAIR AND MEMBERS A TAD MORE
HOUSE ROBERT HALF OF SECRETARY
OF STATE DOLLARS VIDEO THE
SECRETARY DOES NOT HAVE A
POSITION ON THE BILL.
WE WANT TO COME FORWARD AND
ACKNOWLEDGE THE WORK DONE BY THE
BY THE CHAIR BY THE COMMITTEE
STAFF MOVING THE BILL IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION KEEPING US
INFORMED SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE SEEN NO
QUESTIONS WOULD YOU LIKE TO CALL.
THE ROLE MADAM SECRETARY.
MOTIONS TO PASS THE MANITOBA
ABRASIONS STONE.
HI STONE I GALLAGHER.
CHAU.
CHAU I TO WRITE TO AYE GONZALEZ
HI CAN SALAS AYE HOLDEN.
KALRA.
KILEY [inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN.
HI MAIENSCHEIN I OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE AYE PETRIE-NORRIS.
PETER NORTH AYE RADIUS.
REYES.
THE BILL IS OUT.
THANK YOU WE HAVE ONE MORE WHICH
IS ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN A. B.
THIRTEEN NINETY SIX MISTER
OBERNOLTE.
AND I'M NOT SURE I ANNOUNCED
THAT I DO NUMBER SIX AB TEN
SEVENTY THREE RUBIO WAS PULLED
FROM OUR AGENDA TODAY.
THIS OBERNOLTE SECOND HAVE A
MOTION AND WE HAVE A SECOND
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
THE COMMITTEE THE SPECTER OF
ELDER ABUSE IS OF KING
INCREASING CONCERN IN OUR
SOCIETY.
IT'S ESTIMATED THAT ONE IN TEN
ELDERS WILL EXPERIENCE ABUSE AND
THAT ONLY FOR ONE AND FOURTEEN
EPISODES OF ABUSE IS REPORTED TO
AUTHORITIES WHICH MEANS THAT THE
ACTUAL INCIDENCE IS LIKELY MUCH
HIGHER.
THIS IS OF A SPECIAL CONCERN TO
CALIFORNIA OR ELDER POPULATION
IS ESTIMATED WILL DOUBLE BY THE
YEAR TWENTY TWENTY SIX AND WE
HAVE I WAS VERY SURPRISED TO
FIND OUT.
A INCIDENTS OF ELDER ABUSE THAT
IS OVER TWICE AS HIGH AS THE
NATIONAL AVERAGE.
WHEN A JUDGE ISSUES A DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE RESTRAINING ORDER THEY
HAVE UNDER CALIFORNIA STATE LAW?
THE ABILITY TO WERE FOR A
BATTERER TO A BATTERERS
INTERVENTION PROGRAM THIS BILL
AB THIRTEEN NINETY SIX WOULD
GIVE A SIMILAR OPTION TO JUDGES
WHO ISSUE.
A ELDER ABUSE RESTRAINING ORDER
THEY WOULD GIVE THEM THE ABILITY
TO WERE FOR THE PERPETRATOR TO
EITHER A CAL CLINICAL COUNSELING
SESSION OR ANGER MANAGEMENT
COURSES WHICH WILL GIVE THEM
JUST ANOTHER TOOL TO TRY AND
PREVENT THIS FROM OCCURRING.
IN THE FUTURE MISTER CHAIR LIKE
TO THANK YOU AND THE MEMBERS OF
YOUR STAFF FOR WORKING WITH ME
ON THE BILL.
THEY AMENDMENTS TO THAT ARE
PROPOSED THE COMMITTEE HOUSES I
BELIEVE MAKE THE BILL MUCH
BETTER AND I'LL CERTAINLY BE
ACCEPTING THEM TODAY THANK YOU.
GREAT.
FIRST WITNESS PLEASE.
LARRY DO ON BEHALF OF CONFERENCE
A CALIFORNIA BAR ASSOCIATIONS
WITH THE SPONSOR OF THE BILL --
THIS BILL COMES OUT OF SOME
pJUDGES IN ORANGE COUNTY WHO.
RECOMMENDED TO WILL CEASE TO BE
A DELEGATE -- THAT.
REALLY PROBATE JUDGES NEEDED THE
SAME AUTHORITY TO TRY TO CRAFT
SOLUTIONS TO PROBLEMS OF ELDER
ABUSE THAT WORK ENJOYED BY
FAMILY.
COURT JUDGES -- THE RECORD
ANALYSIS MAKES A NUMBER OF
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR TECHNICAL
CHANGES TO FOR FURTHER
IMPROVEMENT AND WE WILL
CERTAINLY -- ENJOY WORKING WITH
THE COMMITTEE -- AS THE BILL
CONTINUES TO MOVE ALONG
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE OPPOSITION.
SEE NONE QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER OVER
TO FOR WORKING WITH ME ON THIS.
THAT.
WORST IN AND ANOTHER ARENA
STRUGGLING WITH THE BETTER
INTERVENTION PROGRAM TRYING TO
PROVE THAT PROCESS SO I
APPRECIATE YOU TAKING THE
AMENDMENTS PUT AT THE ELDER
BECAUSE I THINK IN THE RIGHT
PLACE BUT ABSOLUTELY.
SHARE YOUR CONCERNS.
WITH THAT YOU MAY CLOSE I JUST
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST DRIVE VOTE
ON THIS VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE.
THANK YOU SO THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO AGING.
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE STONE BY
STONE AYE GALLAGHER.
CHOW.
CHOW I CHIU.
CHIU AYE GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I HOLDEN.
KALRA [inaudible]
KILEY.
KILEY AYE MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MAIENSCHEIN AYE OBERNOLTE AYE
OBERNOLTE AYE PETRIE-NORRIS.
PETRIE-NORRIS AYE RADIUS.
REYES AYE.
THAT BILL IS OUT THANK YOU.
FOR ALL RIGHT LET'S GO BACK
THROUGH THE AGENDA WE HAVE A
NUMBER OF BILLS ON CALL
INCLUDING CONSENT THEY CAN SEND
A JET IS ON CALL I'M GONNA LIFT
THE CALL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
GALLAGHER CHIU [inaudible]
CONSENT CONSENT. TWO I HOLDEN
[inaudible]
KALRA [inaudible]
PETRIE-NORRIS.
PETRIE-NORRIS I KILEY.
THOSE BILLS ARE OUT THAT IS THE
BE THREE FIFTY FIFTY ONE CHOI A.
B. ELEVEN SEVENTY NINE RUBIO.
AB. THIRTEEN SIXTY ONE OBERNOLTE
A. B. SIXTEEN THIRTY SEVEN SMITH
AND THEN A. B. EIGHTEEN
SEVENTEEN AND AB AT. EIGHTEEN
EIGHTEEN WHICH ARE BOTH
COMMITTEE L..
ALL RIGHTS SO ITEM NUMBER.
ONE ALL THEY HAVE TO MEMBERS
PLEASE GALLAGHER CHIU. TO AYE
HOLDEN KALRA [inaudible]
KILEY.
ITEM NUMBER TWO AB THREE THIRTY
GABRIEL.
WE HAVE SOME MEMBERS GALLAGHER
CHIU.
CHIU AYE MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE NOW.
THANK YOU ITEM NUMBER THREE IS
ON CALL THIS IS AB SIX TWENTY
EIGHT BONTA LIFT THE CALL.
GALLAGHER.
MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I OBERNOLTE
OBERNOLT NO PETRIE-NORRIS
[inaudible]
REYES [inaudible]
REYES AYE.
THE BILL IS OUT.
ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB.
SEVEN FORTY NINE CALL THE OF THE
MEMBERS GALLAGHER CHIU.
CHIU AYE HOLDEN [inaudible]
KALRA.
KILEY.
KILEY NO PETRIE-NORRIS
[inaudible]
NORRIS HI [inaudible]
HOLDEN I THE BILL IS OUT THANK
YOU WITH THAT I'LL CALL. FOR IT
DOES MATTER AT THIS POINT SO
ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB SEVEN EIGHTY
FIVE BLOOM CALL THE OF SOME
MEMBERS GALLAGHER.
CHIU.
CHIU AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I OBERNOLTE
OBERNOLTE AYE.
THANK YOU ITEM SIX WAS PULLED
FROM THE AGENDA.
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN A. B. O.
ELEVEN THIRTEEN CHU IS ON CALL
IN A LIFT THE CALL.
GALLAGHER [inaudible]
GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I KALRA.
KILEY.
KILEY NO MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN
I OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE NO RADIUS.
REYES AYE.
THE BILL IS OUT.
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT ELEVEN SIXTY
FIVE BAUER-KAHAN CALL THE OF THE
MEMBERS GALLAGHER.
TO CHIU AYE KALRA.
MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I OBERNOLTE
OBERNOLTE AYE.
RIGHT I KNOW NUMBER NINE AB
TWELVE SEVENTY STONE.
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
GALLAGHER.
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE KALRA.
KILEY.
KILEY NO.
THANK YOU ITEM NUMBER TEN IS AB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY FIVE SANTIAGO IS
ON CALL AND LIFT THE CALL
[inaudible]
GALLAGHER GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I KALRA [inaudible]
KILEY.
KILEY NO MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN
AYE OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE NO
RADIUS.
REYES AYE.
THE BILL IS OUT ITEM NUMBER.
ELEVEN AB THIRTEEN NINETY SIX
OBERNOLTE.
WE HAVE EVERYBODY BUT OKAY CALL
THE OF THE MEMBERS GALLAGHER.
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE KALRA.
RIGHT ITEM NUMBER TWELVE A. B.
FIFTEEN TEN RACES ON CALL I'M
GONNA LIFT THE CALL.
GALLAGHER CHIU.
CHIU AYE KALRA [inaudible]
KILEY [inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I OBERNOLTE
[inaudible]
PETRIE-NORRIS [inaudible]
NORTH SIDE.
THAT BILL IS OUT.
ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN AB
SEVENTEEN OH EIGHT RODRIGUEZ IS
ON CALL THE MIDDLE IF THE CALL.
GALLAGHER CHIU. TWO I
MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE NO PETRIE-NORRIS.
NORRIS I REYES.
RESIDE.
THE BILL IS OUT ITEM NUMBER
FOURTEEN AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY ONE
PARTNER HORVATH WHEN A LIST THE
CALL.
GALLAGHER [inaudible]
TO HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I KALRA [inaudible]
KILEY.
KILEY NO MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE NO RADIUS [inaudible]
REYES I THE BILL IS OUT
[inaudible]
ITEM NUMBER. FIFTEEN AB
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY TWO CHAO IS ON
CALL AND IF THE CALL.
GALLAGHER. TO TWO I HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE KALRA [inaudible]
HIGHLY.
MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE NO PETRIE-NORRIS.
PETRIE-NORRIS AYE RADIUS
[inaudible]
REYES I THE BILL IS OUT.
ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN A. B.
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN A JUDICIARY
BILL CALLED THE OF SOME MEMBERS
GALLAGHER.
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY [inaudible]
KILEY AYE.
ITEM NUMBER SEVENTEEN IS AB
EIGHTEEN TWENTY ONE A JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE BILL. EIGHTEEN I'VE AB
EIGHTEEN TWENTY ONE CALL THE US
MEMBERS GALLAGHER [inaudible]
HOLDEN [inaudible]
KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY [inaudible]
KILEY NO [inaudible]
SEVERAL OUT.
SO THAT BILL IS OUT IS ALREADY
OUT ALRIGHT LET'S GO THROUGH ONE
MORE TIME [inaudible]
ON CONSENT.
WE DON'T HAVE [inaudible]
SIR HOLDEN.
DID HE JUST THOUGHT HE WAS JUST
HERE WE WANT TO CONSENT
[inaudible]
OKAY.
SO WE'RE STILL MISSING MISTER
HOLDEN I THINK HE THOUGHT HE WAS
DONE.
HE WILL COME BACK.
OKAY LET'S RUN THROUGH ONE MORE
TIME AND WE'LL CATCH UP WE'LL
SEE WHO'S LEFT.
OKAY CONSENT [inaudible]
GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER AYE HOLDEN KALRA
[inaudible]
KALRA.
ITEM NUMBER ONE AB EIGHT TWENTY
FOUR WOULD.
GALLAGHER [inaudible]
HOLDEN [inaudible]
KALRA [inaudible]
CALL RIGHT.
ITEM NUMBER TWO AB THREE THIRTY
GABRIEL [inaudible]
GALLAGHER.
ITEM NUMBER THREE AB SIX TWENTY
EIGHT BONTA [inaudible]
GALLAGHER.
AND GALLAGHER NO.
ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB SEVEN FORTY
NINE STONE.
GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER NO KALRA.
KALRA AYE.
ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB SEVEN EIGHTY
FIVE BLOOM [inaudible]
GALLAGHER [inaudible]
GALLAGHER AYE.
I REMEMBER SIX IS PULLED ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN AB. ELEVEN THIRTEEN
CHIU [inaudible]
GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER NO KALRA.
KALRA HI SURE BY VOTERS ON FIVE
BLOOM I THINK IT WAS PRESENTING
HAD LEAVE I'M SORRY WHICH NUMBER
ON ITEM FIVE BLOOM THAT.
AB SEVENTY FIVE WHICH IS CALLED
A MOMENT AGO.
WE DO HAVE YOU EVER OKAY HI.
I'M SORRY WHERE ARE WE I
REMEMBER EIGHT AB ELEVEN SIXTY
FIVE BAUER-KAHAN.
GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER I KALRA [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
ITEM NUMBER NINE AB TWELVE
SEVENTY STONE [inaudible]
GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER NO KALRA [inaudible]
KALRA AYE.
ITEM NUMBER TEN A. B. THIRTEEN
EIGHTY FIVE SANTIAGO
[inaudible]
GALLAGHER [inaudible]
KALRA [inaudible]
KALRA AYE.
ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN AB THIRTEEN
NINETY SIX OBERNOLTE.
GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER I KALRA.
ALL RIGHT.
ITEM NUMBER TWELVE AB FIFTEEN
TEN PRESS [inaudible]
GALLAGHER [inaudible]
GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER NOT VOTING KALRA.
KALRA AYE.
ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN AB
SEVENTEEN OH EIGHT RODRIGUEZ
[inaudible]
GALLAGHER [inaudible]
GALLAGHER NOW.
ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN AB
SEVENTEEN THIRTY ONE BURNER HAVE
FOR BATH [inaudible]
GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER NO KALRA.
CALLER HI.
ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN AB SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY TWO CHAU [inaudible]
GALLAGHER.
NOT VOTING KALRA.
KALRA AYE.
ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN A. B.
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN COMMITTEE BILL
[inaudible]
GALLAGHER [inaudible]
GALLAGHER I ITEM NUMBER
SEVENTEEN AB EIGHT TWENTY
EIGHTEEN TWENTY ONE COMMITTEE
BILL [inaudible]
GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER NO CALL HOLDEN.
THANK YOU. FOR HOLDING
.
HI ITEM NUMBER TEN AB.
THIRTEEN EIGHTY FIVE GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER NOT VOTING T<c.cyan></c>
.
ALL RIGHT MR HOLDEN.
WE HAVE -- THREE ITEMS FOR YOU
THE CONSENT AGENDA.
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE ITEM NUMBER WHAT
NUMBER ONE AB EIGHT TWENTY FOUR
WOULD.
HOLDEN AYE.
AND THEN ITEM NUMBER SEVENTEEN
AB.
EIGHTEEN TWENTY ONE HOLDEN AYE
RIGHT WITH THAT THANK YOU ALL
VERY MUCH WE ARE ADJOURNED